hello everyone
welcome to this full course video on
data science data science is one of the
most evolving fields in the industries
these days
in this video we will cover everything
you need to know to become a data
scientist
our experienced instructors with rich
industry experience will take you
through this course
first you will understand the basics of
data science in 5 minutes from an
animated video
then we'll tell you how to become a data
scientist in 2021
you will understand the top python
libraries for data science
we'll then focus on some of the
essential data science algorithms such
as linear regression
logistic regression decision trees
random forest
support vector machines and k-means
clustering you will also learn about
principal component analysis
then we'll focus on the data science
jobs salary
skills and resume finally we'll look at
some of the top data science interview
questions
so let's begin are you one of the many
who dreams of becoming a data scientist
keep watching this video if you're
passionate about data science because we
will tell you
how does it really work under the hood
emma is a data scientist
let's see how a day in her life goes
while she's working on data science
project
well it is very important to understand
the business problem first
in our meeting with the clients emma
asks relevant questions
understands and defines objectives for
the problem that needs to be tackled
she is a curious soul who asks a lot of
eyes
one of the many traits of a good data
scientist
now she gears up for data acquisition to
gather and scrape data from
multiple sources like web servers logs
databases
apis and online repositories oh it seems
like finding the right data takes
both time and effort after the data is
gathered comes data preparation
this step involves data cleaning and
data transformation
data cleaning is the most time consuming
process as it involves handling
many complex scenarios here mr deals
with inconsistent data types
misspelled attributes missing values
duplicate values
and what not then in data transformation
she modifies the data
based on defined mapping rules in a
project etl tools like talent and
informatica are used to perform
complex transformations that helps the
team to understand the data structure
better then
understanding what you actually can do
with your data is very crucial
for that emma does exploratory data
analysis
with the help of eda she defines and
refines the selection of feature
variables that will be used in the model
development but what if
emma skips this step she might end up
choosing the wrong variables which will
produce an inaccurate model
thus exploratory data analysis becomes
the most
important step now she proceeds to the
core activity of a data science project
which is data modelling she repetitively
applies diverse machine learning
techniques like knn
decision tree knife base to the data to
identify
the model that best fits the business
requirement
she trains the models on the training
data set and test them
to select the best performing model emma
prefers
python for modeling the data however it
can also be done using r and sas
well the trickiest part is not yet over
visualization
and communication emma meets the clients
again to communicate the business
findings in a simple
and effective manner to convince the
stakeholders she uses tools like tableau
power bi and qlikview that can help her
in creating
powerful reports and dashboards and then
finally she deploys and maintains the
model
she tests the selected model in a
pre-production environment
before deploying it in the production
environment which is the best practice
right
after successfully deploying it she uses
reports and dashboards
to get real-time analytics further she
also monitors and maintains the
project's performance
well that's how emma completes the data
science project
we have seen the daily routine of a data
scientist is a whole lot of fun
has a lot of interesting aspects and
comes with its own share of challenges
now let's see how data science is
changing the world
data science techniques along with
genomic data provides a deeper
understanding of genetic issues and
reaction to particular drugs
and diseases logistic companies like dhl
fedex have discovered the best rules to
ship the best suited time to deliver
the best mode of transport to choose
thus
leading to cost efficiency with data
science it is possible
to not only predict employee attrition
but to also
understand the key variables that
influence employee turnover
also the airline companies can now
easily predict flight delay
and notify the passengers beforehand to
enhance their travel experience
well if you're wondering there are
various roles offered to a data
scientist
like data analyst machine learning
engineer
deep learning engineer data engineer and
of course data scientist
the median base salaries of a data
scientist can range from
95 000 to 165 000 dollars
so that was about the data science are
you ready to be a data scientist
if yes then start today the world of
data
needs you i am in today's session we are
going to talk about
how to become a data scientist in 2021
now there are a lot of aspiring data
scientists out there
so i'm sure this video will help you all
out
so here are the topics we'll be
discussing today
a brief introduction to data science
laying the groundwork for a data science
career
a short note on who is a data scientist
later we'll discuss the in-demand
technical skills for data scientists
and then the salary of data scientists
after which we'll discuss the future of
data science
and data scientists so now
let's have a brief introduction to the
field of data science
there is no specific definition to
describe data science
if you ask 500 people to describe what
data science
is you'll probably end up getting 500
different responses because data science
is a continually evolving field
well under wikipedia data science is an
interdisciplinary discipline
using computational methods processes
algorithms and systems to derive
information
and insights from both structural and
unstructured data in simple terms
data science is the domain of study that
deals with
vast volumes of data using modern tools
and techniques
these tools and techniques are used to
find unseen
patterns derive meaningful information
and make business decisions the data
used for
analysis can be from multiple sources
and present
in various formats there is a saying
a jack of all traits and a master of
none
when it comes to being a data scientist
you need to be a bit like this
but perhaps a better saying would be a
jack of all traits and a master of
some let's now discuss about laying the
groundwork for a data science career
let's now look at some of the
prerequisites for getting a data science
job
have a relevant degree a solid
educational background is required to be
a data scientist
pursue an undergraduate degree in data
science
or any closely related fields like
statistics
computer science or mathematics after
the undergraduate course
a master's degree in one of the relevant
areas
is an added advantage creativity and
critical thinking
creativity in data science is very much
needed in this field
you will need it for creating a
storyline for innovative modeling
for developing new tools different ways
to collect your data
and lots more parallely critical
thinking is very useful in data science
a data scientist should be able to
develop questions
and at the same time question the data
as well
require technical and non-technical
skills
we'll be discussing in depth the
required technical skills
later on in this video talking about the
other necessary skills in this field
you will need problem solving skills
risk analysis
and many more good communication skills
having a strong command over your
communication skills is very much needed
in this field the outcomes that are
delivered through data science
are quite complicated and hard to
explain
you will have to translate your
technical findings
clearly and fluently to the other teams
you will need good presentation skills
storytelling skills
writing skills and listening skills
in short make sure you focus on building
lasting relationships through your
communication
here are some of the roles in the field
of data science
data scientist machine learning engineer
machine learning scientist data engineer
data analyst statistician
business intelligence developer
infrastructure architect
enterprise architect applications
architect
data scientist is most likely one of the
most sizzling job titles among the lot
and now let's talk about who is a data
scientist
in simple terms a data scientist is the
one
who practices the art of data science
a data scientist analyzes business data
to extract meaningful insights in other
words
a data scientist solves business
problems through various methods
dj patil and jeff hammerbacker coined
the term data scientist
a data scientist's work typically
revolves around data
and his role will be a combination of
three main subjects
computer science statistics and
mathematics
it's time to discuss the in-demand
technical skills for data scientists
to become a data scientist you need
various skills
as mentioned earlier some of the
significant technical skills you will
need to master
include programming there are several
programming languages for data
scientists
learning and mastering at least one of
them is
essential to realize various functions
of data science
but at the same time just a single
language
can't solve problems in all areas
python is the most widely used
programming language in the world today
when it comes to data science the next
widely used language is r there are
still some data scientists who use
r instead of python but if you're doing
applied data science these days then
you've got to learn
python because that's the most valuable
programming language for data scientists
some other languages include javascript
scala sql etc
about python programming language it is
open source
and easy to use language you will need
to understand the basic syntax of this
language initially
you will need to know how to write
functions loops
and modules you should be familiar with
both
object oriented and functional
programming in python
it is a general purpose and dynamic
programming language
that supports multiple paradigms one
of the factors that make python stand
out from the rest
is its flexibility you can use python
for almost
all the steps involved in data science
the next skill will be talking about is
machine
learning the concept of machine learning
has been around for a while now however
the ability to automatically and quickly
apply mathematical calculations
to big data is now gaining a bit of
momentum
you will need to learn techniques such
as supervised machine learning
decision trees logistic regression
and natural language processing one of
the crucial reasons why you need machine
learning in data science
is because of the high value predictions
that can guide
better decisions and smart actions
in real time without human intervention
there are in fact a lot of advantages of
machine learning in data science
it helps analyze large chunks of data
and it changes the way data extraction
and
interpretation works to sum it up
machine learning and data science can
work hand in hand
with machine learning being such a craze
data scientists need to learn it
this is why simply learn has introduced
a revolutionary
machine learning certification program
that provides advanced level training on
the applications
and algorithms it uses we have provided
the link in the description box for the
same
do not forget to check that out here's
to yet another essential skill in data
science
math mathematics is the bedrock of
any contemporary discipline in science
it's one of the major requirements for
data science
some of the major math topics you will
need to know are
calculus linear algebra probability
and statistics some other math topics
that will help you solve data science
problems
are discrete math graph theory
information theory and many more
up next we have analytical tools
they help you extract useful meaningful
insights from data and provide you with
valuable frameworks
for processing big data data analysis
is a core practice of modern day
businesses and choosing the right
analytical tools is very challenging
as no tool fits every needs anyway
some of the most used analytical tools
in data science are
sql spark hadoop hive
and many more coming to data
visualization
it is an interdisciplinary field that
deals with the graphic
representations of data data
visualization
plays two prominent roles
communicating results clearly to a
general audience
and organizing a view of data that
suggests
a new hypothesis of the next step in a
project
some of the data visualization tools are
matplotlib
ggplot and d3.js
data visualization encompasses
techniques that are used to communicate
data
or information by encoding it as visual
objects that are contained in graphics
well as big data keeps growing data
visualization becomes an
increasingly crucial tool
up next we have data wrangling this
is the process of gathering selecting
and transforming data
to answer an analytical question it will
help the data scientists
fasten decision making and hence get
better insights in less time
data wrangling is also known as data
cleaning
or munching at last we have
business acumen when you are a data
scientist
you must have more business sense in
analyzing the data
in other words you need to know whether
the insights gained from the data
is of value to the business or not hence
business acumen plays a very vital role
in structuring
business data analytics when we are
talking about business knowledge
three things come into the picture
general business knowledge
industry specific knowledge and company
specific knowledge
knowing these are very much important
when you are a data scientist
so guys this sums up the end demand
technical skills for data scientists
well let's now discuss the salary of
data scientists
before we go into the topic we would
like to introduce our new platform skill
up
where you can find some of our best
courses for free
we are offering more than 1000 hearts of
content for free
which can help you acquire more than 300
skills
across a number of different categories
take the next step to grow in your
career by joining skill
up by checking out the link in the
description
when we are talking about the salary of
data scientists
many factors come into the picture the
salary would depend on the
experience he or she holds the industry
the company size educational background
and finally the region according to
glassdoor
the average salary of a data scientist
in india
is close to 10 lakh rupees and that in
the united states
is close to 1 lakh 13
309 dollars in the i.t
field the driving factor behind high
data assigned salaries
is that the companies and organizations
are realizing the power of big data
and they want to use it to drive smart
business decisions
to our last topic of today future of
data science and data scientists
with every passing year data science is
improving and expanding
at a significantly faster pace data
science has
found its applications in almost every
industry
healthcare companies are using data
science to build
sophisticated medical instruments to
detect
and cure diseases video and computer
games are now being created with data
science
and that has taken the gaming experience
to the next
level similarly data science has taken
various other fields to a whole new
level
the top three most common search terms
in july 2020
are data science machine learning and
artificial intelligence
according to the 2020 emerging jobs
report
linkedin listed data scientist as the
top third
job with an annual growth rate of 37
percent
for four years in a row data scientist
has been named the number one job in the
us
by glassdoor pursuing a career in data
science is a smart
move not just because it pays well and
is trendy
it is because data is the pivot point on
which
the entire economy turns
however you can also go through our
video on the topic
tips for becoming a data scientist for
more information
we'll link the video on the top right
corner for you to access quickly
also if you want to master data science
you can always go through simply learns
course
on data science and excel in this field
so what is data science data science is
the field of study that deals with
modern
scientific techniques statistical
methods
and algorithms to derive insights from
vast volumes of data
companies using data science are very
numerous
with companies generating data every
minute
there is a need to make sense of this
data
mu sigma fractal fidelity intel
jim pact cubela amazon trindins
connect the dots just about every
business out there
nowadays uses some form of data science
even if it's indirectly to help govern
their business
and help them growth and compete in the
business world and we use the data
science to find
unseen patterns within the data analyze
and draw insights from our data
and solve business problems and make
decisions
and the data science has a life cycle we
start with our data discovery
then we go through data preparation
exploratory data analysis
data modeling interpret the results and
back to data discovery
we talk about data discovery data
discovery involves asking the right
questions identifying the business
problems
finding the best solution and gathering
correct data from relevant sources for
analysis
this is in the data science life cycle
the most important step
now in general it only involves like a
small percentage of the time you spend
on this
but if you're not asking the right
questions you can't go in the right
direction
data preparation data preparation deals
with cleaning the data
finding the inconsistencies tackling
missing values converting it into the
right format and making it ready for
analysis
when i'm running the data science life
cycle this is probably where the most
time
is spent data can be so
messy you have to break it down into
different parts you have to import the
different pieces from different
databases
are you dealing with straight numbers
off of spreadsheets and cells
or are you dealing with text documents
and
natural tokenite language tokenization
exploratory data analysis
analyze and visualize the data using
different charts and graphs to find
significant patterns
and hidden trends that helps to
understand the data better the building
of the charts
is very creative probably one of the
more enjoyable parts is be able to come
in there and describe the data
and show that to the shareholders then
we dive into data modeling
use classification regression and
clustering algorithms to build machine
learning models
that can help predict and forecast
future trends
this is where we start getting into
predictions
what's next where's it going to go and
then interpret the results
validate the model results draw the
final conclusion and check if the
performance of the model is in line
with the requirements the final step is
the one that you set up in front of the
board members and give them suggestions
as to what's next where we're going to
spend our marketing money
where are we going to start preparing
our fire fires for the next fire breaks
next year
what is the weather patterns coming in
this is where you interpret the results
and say how accurate they are
are they valid is it something we're
going to keep are we going to throw it
out and have to start over
we look at data science components
there's the mathematics
statistics domain expertise
data engineering data visualization
and machine learning when we sum this up
in data science
really uh this point
in all of this you want to focus on
first is domain
expertise now when you're taking your
classes obviously you want to go through
the mathematics the statistics the data
engineering the data visualization the
machine learning and learning all those
tools
but it really in the job field the
domain expertise comes in
because if you're really good with
business and you go into business with
these tools
then you're able to ask the right
questions and deal with it
when we talk about the tools in data
science and where they sit
uh there is a data analysis data
analysis focuses more on statistics and
mathematics
where the data science size where the
data science side focuses more on the
machine learning data visualization
and then there's database management
which really focuses on the data
engineering part of it and how to manage
that data in the data flow
and you see all these components come
together and then they form the data
science
and we talk about tools in data science
we have
sas we have matlab we have sql
you have your apache spark your r table
python right now in the programming
languages
python is probably the most widely used
with
r coming in a close second the reason
for that is these are both open source
and anybody can use them
we look at sas and tableau those are two
packages that are paid for
which have a lot of automation behind
them so a lot of the larger companies
will pay for those packages
because they help work out a lot of the
the back end stuff before you even need
to use them
and of course we have apache spark you
almost have to know apache spark in the
growing data
lakes today that's your big data how do
you distribute this if you're going to
process it over
a large amount of data we look at data
science applications
there's internet search very common you
enter your google thing and it uses the
data science
algorithms to figure out what to return
voice
assistance analyzing the voice coming in
and connecting it with whatever patterns
they need to activate so you can ask it
to turn your lights on in the living
room
healthcare biggest field growing right
now how do we analyze health data from a
smart watch
and figure out how to know when a
disease is being
spread across the world healthcare how
do we identify
cancer versus non-cancer so we know who
to prioritize and get them in for
surgery
where other people might not need that
immediate care and even identifying
problems somebody might have with their
health long before they even happen
what a neat thing to do instead of
waiting until you have a heart attack
to know months ahead of time that you're
having heart conditions
logistics how do we get from point a to
point b
if you ever look at some of the major
distributors they pre-ship things based
on what they guess
people are going to need this way you
get your stuff right in the mailbox the
day after you order it
e-commerce it's huge in there because
you have to know
what kind of marketing we're going to
put out who are we selling to what's our
target audience
robotics one of the funner ones when
you're coming up into the future is how
do we automate
the different tasks we have from
self-driving cars
to manufacturing lines to
maybe even a self-robotic chef in the
kitchen
so we talk about solving problems with
data science
we have to ask possible questions and
the desired algorithms
and these really are kind of an overview
of some of the terminology you'll want
to know in
data science so we talk about that how
much or how many we're talking about
regression
regression basically means a number if
you've ever seen
stock charts you see the guess at what
the next sales price is or buy price is
that's all on your regression side
is it a or b classification
is that a dog or a cat that my photo
took a picture of
how is this organized clustering this is
where we take things that look alike and
put them together so that we can then
make predictions on it
how difference is this just like you
have clustering you have the opposite
anomaly detection how do we find things
that don't fit in where the outliers
what are things we might need to look at
that aren't in our model
and what to do next reinforced learning
this is probably the newest market is
how do we set something up whereas the
data comes in
it learns from the new data as to what
the next action is going to take
most of these are combined so when we
talk about regression
classification clustering anomaly
detection reinforced learning
a lot of times when you put your model
together you might have multiple parts
of this
we might look at the clustering of data
and then feed it into a classification
is this a bad loan to make it the bank
or is this a good loan to give
and from there we might start looking at
when we start clustering these things as
good and bad and what kind of
setup is we then might run it through a
regression model to say hey what is the
amount dollar amount this person
should be allowed to take a loan out and
you can see that all of these start
coming in
and then a lot of the models reinforced
learning
we talk about like bank loans and things
like that once a year
they have to rerun those algorithms and
so that's like a human run
reinforced learning now we're starting
to automate that so that as the data
comes in real time
the models start updating themselves
they start figuring out a way to solve
new problems
as they occur and of course in robotics
reinforced learning is one of the
biggest growing fields
algorithms used in data science linear
regression
logistic regression when you're looking
at both of these
uh think numbers we're talking
regression models
and so linear regression figures out the
best line through the data
maybe it's looking for a curved line
logistic regression starts looking at
data
on a continuum so that
it goes to an exponential you have a
spot where it might be one or the other
and then you know what it is as it goes
to one side or the other
decision tree wonderful tool
if you used to call it a hack now it's
becoming mainstream
to look at the back end what made the
decision so it's really easy to trace
back to
how you arrived at the decision decision
trees are kind of nice that way
nearest neighbors k nearest neighbors is
your clustering k means clustering
hierarchical clustering so hierarchical
starts dividing them
and builds a hierarchy where the k-means
and the k-nearest neighbor
look for things that kind of connect
each other how close are they
in data format db scan
another form of clustering your data
principal component analysis
so we start breaking up and looking at
the different components in our data
coming in
these are all algorithms used in data
science and there are more
these are kind of the mainline ones and
each one of these has many settings
which you can play with
to build a better model to predict your
data and where you want it to go
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description
to know more what are the prerequisites
for
data science there are three essential
traits
required for to be a data scientist one
is
curiosity you need to be able to ask
questions
the first step in data science is asking
questions what is the problem we are
trying to solve if you ask the right
question
only then you'll get the right answer
very often this is a very crucial step
where a lot of data science projects
fail because you're you may be asking
the wrong question
and then obviously when you get the
answer that's not the answer you're
looking for so it is very important that
you ask the right question needless to
say then the second part
or the second trait is common sense so
you need to be
creative you need to come up with ways
to use the data that you have
and try to solve the business problem
on hand in many cases you may not have
all the data that you need
in many cases the data may be incomplete
so that is where you need to come up
with ways what are the best
ways to fill these gaps wherever this is
missing and that's where common sense
comes into play last but not least after
doing all this analysis
if you are unable to communicate the
results in the right way
the whole exercise will fail so
communication
is a key trait for a data scientist
maybe
technically you may be a genius but then
if you are unable to communicate those
results
in a proper way once again that will not
help
so these are the three main traits
curiosity common sense
and communication skills in a way you
can say these are the three c's
okay so what are the other prerequisites
first one so machine learning machine
learning is the backbone of data science
data science involves quite a bit of
machine learning in addition to the
basic statistics
that we do so a data scientist needs to
have a good hang or need to be very good
at
data science the second part is modeling
so modeling is also a part of machine
learning in a way
but you need to be good at identifying
what are the algorithms that are more
suitable to solve a given problem
what models can we use and how do we
train these models and so on and so
forth so that is the second
component then statistics statistics is
like
the core foundation of data science so
you need to understand
statistics and you need to have a good
hang of statistics in order to be a good
data scientist
and this will also help in getting good
results
programming is to some extent required
at least some program or the other would
be required
as a part of executing the data science
project
the most common programming languages
are python
and r python specially is becoming a
very
popular programming language in data
science because of
its ease of learning because of the
multiple
libraries that it supports for
performing
data science and machine learning and so
on so
python is by far one of the most popular
languages in data science if any one of
you is wanting to learn a new language
that should be python and then of course
you need to
understand databases how databases work
and
how to handle databases how to get data
out of databases
and so on so these are some of the key
components of data science now coming to
the tools and skills that are used in
data science these are some of the
skills
from a language perspective it is python
or r and from a skills perspective
in addition to some of the programming
languages it would help if you have
a good knowledge or good understanding
of statistics and what are the tools
that are used
in data analysis sas is one of the most
popular tools
it's been there for very long time and
that's the reason it is
very popular and however this is
compared to
most of the other tools it is a
proprietary software
whereas python and r are mostly open
source
the other tools are like jupiter jupiter
notebooks
you have r studio these are more
development environments and development
tools so jupyter
notebooks is a interactive development
environment
similarly rstudio is for performing or
writing our code
and performing analytics and
performing data analysis and machine
learning activities you can perform in
rstudio it has a very nice ui and
initially r was not so popular primarily
because it did not have
user interface and rstudio is a
relatively new edition
and after the advent of rstudio r became
extremely popular and there are other
tools like matlab and of course some
people do with
excel as well as far as data warehousing
is concerned some of the skills
that are required are etl so
in order to extract data and
transform load etl stands for extract
transform load
so you have data in the databases like
your erp system or a crm system
you need to extract that and then do
some transformations and then load it
into your warehouse
so that all the data from various
sources
looks uniform then you need some sql
skills which is basically
querying the data writing sql queries
hadoop is another
important skill especially if you are
handling large amounts of data
and also one of the specialities of
hadoop is it can
be used for handling unstructured data
as well so it can be used for
large amounts of structured and
unstructured data then spark is a
excellent computing engine for
performing
data analysis or machine learning in a
distributed mode
so if you have large amount of data the
combination of spark and hadoop can be
extremely powerful so you store your
data
in hadoop hdfs and use spark as your
computation engine
it works in a distributed mode similar
to hadoop
like a cluster so that those are
excellent skills for data warehousing
and there are some standard tools that
are available
like informatica data stage talent and
also aws redshift if you want to do some
on the cloud i think aws redshift is
again a good tool
data visualization tools for data
visualization some of the skills that
would be required
are let's say r u r provides some
very good visualization capabilities
especially for
for developing during development and
then you have python libraries
matplotlib and so on which
provides very powerful visualization
capabilities
and that is from skills perspective
whereas
tools that can be used are tableau is a
very very
popular visualization tool again that's
a proprietary tool so it's a little
expensive maybe but
excellent capabilities from a
visualization perspective
then there are tools like cognos which
is an ibm product which provides very
good visualization capabilities as well
and then coming to the machine learning
part of it the skills required there are
python which is
more for programming part and then you
will
need some mathematical skills like
algebra
linear algebra especially and then
statistics and maybe a little bit of
calculus and so on
and the tools that are used for machine
learning
are spark mlib and apache
mahot and on cloud if you want to do
something
you can use microsoft azure ml studio as
well
so these are by no means an exhaustive
list there are actually many many tools
and probably
a few more skills also maybe there but
this is this gives a quick
overview like a summarizing of
summarization of
the tools and skills now moving on to
the life of a data scientist what does a
data scientist
do during the course of his work so
let's see
so typically a data scientist is given a
problem
a business problem that he needs to
solve and in order to do that if you
remember from the previous slide
he basically asks the question as to
what is the problem that he needs to
solve so that is the first thing
he has got the problem then the next
thing is to gather the data that is
required to
solve this problem so he goes about
looking for
data from anywhere it could be the
enterprise very often
the data is not provided in the nice
format that he would like to have it or
we would like to have it so first step
is to get whatever data that is possible
what is known as raw data in whatever
format so it could be enterprise data it
could be
it is a probably a requirement to go and
get some public data in some cases so
all that raw data is collected and then
that is processed
and analyzed and in prepared
into a format in which it can be used
and then it is fed into the analytics
system be it a machine learning
algorithm
or statistical model and we get the
output
and then he puts these output in
a proper format for presenting it to the
stakeholders
and communicating those insights or the
results
to the stakeholders so this is a very
high level
view of like a day in the life of a
data scientist so gathering data raw
data performing some
quick analysis on that and maybe
processing or
manipulating this data to bring it into
a certain
good format so that it can be used for
the analysis
feeding this into that analysis system
that has been designed
be it mathematical models machine
learning models
and then get the results the insights
and then present it in a nice way so
that the stakeholders can
understand how about machine learning
algorithms so let's see what are the
various machine learning algorithms that
would be required for a data scientist
so these are a few of the algorithms
again there's not an exhaustive list we
have
regression is one of the supervised
learning models or techniques so in case
of regression
you try to let's say come up with
a continuous number so the difference
between
regression and let's say a
classification
is that in case of classification those
are discrete values whereas here we are
talking about regression where you let's
say you are trying to predict the
temperature which is a continuous value
or the
share price which is a continuous value
so that is regression so you need to
know what is regression how to perform
regression
and we need to understand clustering so
clustering is
one of the unsupervised learning
techniques
in this case there is no label data that
is available
and you get some data and then you want
to put this into some
shape so that you can analyze it and you
try to make sense out of it
let's say you have one example is you
have a list of
cricketers and they have not been marked
as
bowlers and batsmen or all renders or
whatever right so you just have
their names and maybe how many runs this
code how many wickets they have taken
and so on but there is no readily
available
information saying that okay this person
is a batsman this person is a bowler and
so on so i'm talking about cricket
hopefully most of you are familiar with
the game of cricket so
how do we find out so then we put this
into a clustering mechanism
and then the system will say that okay
these are the people
who are all who have all scored good
amount of runs
so they belong to one cluster these are
all the people who have taken
good amount of wickets so they belong to
one cluster and maybe here are some
people who have taken good amount of
wickets and they have made good amount
of runs so they may be
belonging to one group and then we take
a look at it and then we label them as
okay people who have all together
and those who have you know scored many
runs they are
we label them as batsmen people have
taken a lot of wickets
we label them as bowlers and people
who have taken good amount of wickets
and also made some good runs we
label them as all rounders but the
system will just say okay this is
cluster one cluster two cluster three
the names we give the human beings have
to give the names
now decision tree is used for what is
known as classification
primarily it can also be used for
regression but by and large it is used
for
classification and here again it's a
very
logical way in which the algorithm goes
about classifying
the various inputs one of the biggest
advantages of decision tree
is that it's very easy to understand and
it's very easy to explain
why a certain object has been classified
in a certain way
compared to maybe some of the other
mechanisms like say
support vector machines or logistic
regression and so on so that's the
advantage of dictionary but that is also
very popular algorithm
then we have support vector machines
primarily for classification purpose
and then we have naive bayes this is a
a statistical probability based
classification
method so these are a few algorithms
there are a few more
that are not listed here but there are
some more algorithms as well
and by the way there are more detailed
or there are detailed videos about each
of
these algorithms available you can check
in the playlist
so now let's talk about the life cycle
of a data science project okay the first
step
is the concept study in this step it
involves
understanding the business problem
asking questions
get a good understanding of the business
model meet up with
all the stakeholders understand what
kind of data is available
and all that is a part of the first step
so here are a few examples we want to
see
what are the various specifications and
then what is the
end goal what is the budget is there an
example of this kind of a problem
that has been maybe solved earlier so
all this
is a part of the concept study and
another example could be a very specific
one
to predict the price of a 1.35 carat
diamond and there may be
relevant information inputs that are
available
and we want to predict the price the
next step
in this process is data preparation
data gathering and data preparation also
known as
data munching or sometimes it is also
known as
data manipulation so what happens here
is the raw data that is available
may not be usable in its current format
for various reasons so that is why in
this step
a data scientist would explore the data
he will take a look at some sample data
maybe pick
there are millions of records pick a few
thousand records and see how the data is
looking are there any gaps
is the structure appropriate to be fed
into the system
are there some columns which are
probably
not adding value may not be required for
the analysis
very often these are like names of the
customers they will probably not add any
value or much value from an analysis
perspective
the structure of the data maybe the data
is coming from multiple data sources
and the structures may not be matching
what are the other problems
there may be gaps in the data so the
data all the
columns all the cells are not filled if
you're talking about structured data
there are several blank records or blank
columns
so if you use that data directly
you'll get errors or you will get
inaccurate results so how do you
either get rid of the data or how do you
fill this
gaps with something meaningful so all
that
is a part of data munching or
data manipulation so these are some
additional
sub topics within that so data
integration is one of them
if there are any conflicts in the data
there may be data may be redundant yeah
data resident redundancy is another
issue
there may be you have let's say data
coming from two different systems
and both of them have customer table for
example customer information
so when you merge them there is a
duplication issue so how do we resolve
that so
that is one data transformation as i
said there will be situations where
data is coming from multiple sources and
then when we
merge them together they may not be
matching so we need to do some
transformations to make sure
everything is similar we may have to do
some
data reduction if the data size is too
big
you may have to come up with ways to
reduce it
meaningfully without losing information
then data cleaning so there will be
either wrong values or null values or
there are missing values so how do you
handle all of that
a few examples of very specific stuff so
if there are
missing values how do you handle missing
values
or null values here in this particular
slide we are seeing three types of
issues one is missing value
then you have null value you see the
difference between the two right so in
the missing value there is nothing
blank null value it says null now the
system cannot
handle if there are null values
similarly there is improper data so it's
supposed to be numeric value but there
is a
string or a non-numeric value so how do
we clean
and prepare the data so that our system
can work flawlessly
so there are multiple ways and there is
no
one common way of doing this it can vary
from
project to project it can vary from what
exactly is the problem we are trying to
solve
it can vary from data scientist to data
scientist organization to organization
so these are like some
standard practices people come up with
and and of course
there will be a lot of trial and error
somebody would have tried out something
and it worked and will continue to use
that mechanism
so that's how we need to take care of
data cleaning now
what are the various ways of doing you
know if values are missing
how do you take care of that now if the
data is too large
and only a few records have some missing
values
then it is okay to just get rid of those
entire
rows for example so if you have a
million records and out of which
100 records don't have full data so
there are some missing values in about
100 cards so it's absolutely fine
because
it's a small percentage of the data so
you can get rid of the entire records
which are missing values
but that's not a very common situation
very often you will have
multiple or at least you know large
number of a data set
for example out of million records you
may have 50 000 records which are
like having missing values now that's a
significant amount
you cannot get rid of all those records
your analysis will
be inaccurate so how do you handle such
situations so there are again multiple
ways of doing it one is
you can probably if a particular values
are missing in a particular column
you can probably take the mean value for
that particular column
and fill all the missing values with the
mean value so that
first of all you don't get errors
because of missing values and second
you don't get results that are way off
because these values are completely
different from what is
there so that is one way then a few
other could be
either taking the median value or
depending on
what kind of data we are talking about
so something meaningful we will have put
in there
if we are doing some machine learning
activity
then obviously as a part of data
preparation you need to
split the data into training and test
data set the reason being
if you try to test with a data set which
the system has already seen as a part of
training
then it will tend to give reasonably
accurate results because it has already
seen that data
and that is not a good measure of the
accuracy of the
system so typically you take the entire
data set the input data set and split it
into
two parts and again the ratio can vary
from person to person individual
preferences some people like to split it
into
50 50 some people like it as 63.33
and 33.3 is basically two third and one
third and some people
do it as 80 20 80 for training and 24
testing so you split the data perform
the training
with the 80 percent and then use the
remaining 20 percent for testing all
right
so that is one more data preparation
activity
that needs to be done before you start
analyzing or applying the
data or putting the data through the
model then the next step is
model planning now these models can be
statistical models
this could be machine learning model so
you need to decide
what kind of models you're going to use
again it depends on what is the problem
you're trying to solve if it is a
regression problem you need to think of
a regression algorithm and come up with
a regression
model so it could be linear regression
or if you're talking about
classification
then you need to pick up an appropriate
classification algorithm
like logistic regression or decision
tree or svm
and then you need to train that
particular
model so that is the model building or
model planning process
and the cleaned up data has to be fed
into the model
and apart from cleaning you may also
have to in order to determine what kind
of model you will
use you have to perform some exploratory
data analysis
to understand the relationship between
the various variables and
see if the data is appropriate and so on
right so that is the
additional preparatory step that needs
to be done
so a little bit of details about
exploratory data analysis so what
exactly is exploratory data analysis is
basically to
as the name suggests you're just
exploring you just receive the data and
you're trying to explore
and find out what are the data types and
what is the is the data clean in in each
of the columns what is the maximum
minimum value so for example
there are out of the box functionality
available in
tools like r so if you just ask for a
summary of the table it will tell you
for each column it will give some
details as to what is the mean value
what is the maximum value and so on and
so forth
so this exercise or this exploratory
analysis is to get an
understanding of your data and then you
can take steps to
during this process you find there are a
lot of missing values you need to take
steps to
fix those you will also get an idea
about what kind of model
to be used and so on and so forth what
are the various techniques used for
exploratory data analysis
typically these would be visualization
techniques like you use histograms uh
you can use
box plots you can use scatter plots so
these are very quick ways of identifying
the patterns or a few of the trends of
the data and so on
and then once your data is ready you you
decided on the model
what kind of model what kind of
algorithm you're going to use
if you're trying to do machine learning
you need to
pass your 80 percent the training data
or rather you use that training data to
train your model
and the training process itself is
iterative so
the training process you may have to
perform multiple times and once the
training
is done and you feel it is giving good
accuracy
then you move on to test so you
take the remaining 20 of the data
remember we split the data into training
and test
so the test data is now used to
check the accuracy or how well our model
is performing
and if there are further issues let's
say and model is still
during testing if the accuracy is not
good then you may want to retrain your
model
or use a different model so this whole
thing again can be iterative but if the
test process
is passed or if the model passes the
test then it can go into
production and it will be deployed all
right so
what are the various tools that we use
for model planning r is an excellent
tool
in a lot of ways whether you're doing
regular statistical analysis
or machine learning or any of these
activities are in
along with our studio provides a very
powerful
environment to do data analysis
including visualization it has a very
good
integrated visualization of plot
mechanism which can be used for doing
exploratory data analysis and then
later on to do analysis detailed
analysis and machine learning and so on
and so forth then of course you can
write python
programs python offers a rich library
for performing data analysis
and machine learning and so on matlab is
a very popular
tool as well especially during education
so this is a very easy to
learn tool so matlab is another tool
that can be used and then last but not
least
sas sas is again very powerful
it is a proprietary tool and it has
all the components that are required to
perform
very good statistical analysis or
perform data science so
those are the various tools that would
be required for or that
that can be used for model building and
uh so the next step
is model building so we have done the
planning part
we said okay what is algorithm we are
going to use what kind of model we are
going to use
now we need to actually train this model
or build the model rather
so that it can then be deployed so what
are the various
uh ways or what are the various types of
model building activities
so it could be let's say in this
particular example that we have taken
you want to find out the price
of 1.35 carat diamond so
this is let's say a linear regression
problem you have data for various carats
of diamond
and you use that information you pass it
through
a linear regression model or you create
a linear regression model
which can then predict your price for
1.35 carat so this is one example
of model building and then little bit
details of how
linear regression works so linear
regression is basically coming up with a
relation between
an independent variable and a dependent
variable so it is pretty much like
coming up with equation of a straight
line which is the best fit for the given
data
so like for example here y is equal to
mx plus c
so y is the dependent variable and x is
the independent variable
we need to determine the values of m and
c for our given data so
that is what the training process
of this model does at the end of the
training process
you have a certain value of m and c and
that is used for predicting the values
of any new data that comes all right so
the way it works is we use the training
and the test data set
to train the model and then validate
whether the model is working fine or not
using
test data and if it is working fine
then it is taken to the next level which
is put in production
if not the model has to be retrained if
the accuracy is not good enough
then the model is retrained maybe with
more data
or you come up with a newer model or
algorithm and then
repeat that process so it is an
iterative process once the training is
completed
training and test then this model is
deployed
and we can use this particular model to
determine
what is the price of 1.35 carat diamond
remember that was our
problem statement so now that we have
the best fit
for this given data we have the price of
1.35
carat diamond which is 10 000. so this
is
one example of how this whole process
works
now how do we build the model there are
multiple ways
you can use python for example and use
libraries like pandas or numpy
to build the model and implement it this
will be
available as a separate tutorial a
separate video in this
playlist so stay tuned for that moving
on once we have the results the next
step
is to communicate this results to the
appropriate stakeholders so which is
basically
taking this results and preparing like a
presentation or a dashboard and
communicating these results to the
concerned people so
finishing or getting the results of the
analysis is not the last step
but you need to as a data scientist take
this results
and present it to the team that has
given you this problem in the first
place
and explain your findings explain the
findings
of this exercise and recommend maybe
what steps they need to take in order to
overcome this problem or solve this
problem so that is the pretty much once
that is accepted and
the last step is to operationalize so if
everything is fine your data scientists
presentations are
accepted then they put it into practice
and thereby they will be able to improve
or
solve the problem that they stated in
step one
okay so quick summary of the life cycle
you have
a concept study which is basically
understanding the problem
asking the right questions and trying to
see if there is
enough data to solve this problem and
then even maybe gather the data then
data preparation
the raw data needs to be manipulated you
need to do data munching
so that you have the data in a certain
proper format
to be used by the model or our analytics
system and then you need to do the model
planning what kind of a model what
algorithm you will use for a given
problem
and then the model building so the exact
execution of that model
it happens in step four and you
implement and execute
that model and put the data through the
analysis in this step
and then you get the results these
results are then
communicated packaged and presented and
communicated to the stakeholders
and once that is accepted that is
operationalized so that is the final
step
now in the end let's take a quick look
at the demand for data scientists
data science is an area of great demand
the demand for data scientists is
currently
huge and the supply is very low so there
is a huge
gap so what are some of the industries
with high demand for data scientists
i think gaming is definitely one area
where it's a industry which is consumer
facing industry and a lot of people play
games and
growing industry and it requires a lot
of data science
so that is an area where data scientists
are in demand then we have health care
for example data science is used for
diagnosis
and several other activities within
healthcare predicting for example
a disease so healthcare is definitely
finance
definitely banks insurance companies all
of these
there is a huge demand for data
scientists marketing is like a
horizontal functionality across all
industries
there's a demand for data scientists
there then of course in technology area
so
pretty much all of these areas there is
a lot of demand
globally there is a huge demand so this
is a very very
critical skill that would be required
currently
as well as in the future python is the
most widely used programming language
today when it comes to solving data
science tasks
and challenges python never ceases to
surprise its audience
most data scientists out there are
already leveraging the power of python
every day hi i'm apeksha from
simplylearn and well after some thought
and a bit more research
i was finally able to narrow down my
choice of top python libraries for data
science
what are they let's find out so let's
talk about this amazing library
tensorflow which is also one of my
favorites so tensorflow is a library for
high performance numerical computations
with around 35
000 github comments and a vibrant
community of around 1500 contributors
and it's used across various scientific
domains
it's basically a framework where we can
define and run computations which
involves
tensors and tensors we can see are
partially defined computational objects
again
where they will eventually produce a
value that was about tensorflow
let's talk about the features of
tensorflow so tensorflow is majorly used
in deep learning models and neural
networks
where we have other libraries like torch
and theano also but tensorflow has hands
down better computational
graphical visualizations when compared
to them also tensorflow reduces the
error
largely by 50 to 60 percent in neural
machine translations
it's highly parallel in a way where can
train multiple neural networks
and multiple gpus for highly efficient
and scalable models
this parallel computing feature of
tensorflow is also called pipelining
also tensorflow has the advantage of
seamless performance as it's backed by
google
it has quicker updates frequent new
releases with the latest of features
now let's look at some applications
tensorflow is extensively used in speech
and image recognition
text based applications time series
analysis and forecasting and various
other applications involving video
detection
so favorite thing about tensorflow that
it's already popular among the machine
learning community and most are open to
trying it
and some of us are already using it now
let's look at an example of a tensorflow
model in this example we will not dive
deep into the explanation of the model
as it is beyond the scope of this video
so here we're using amnest dataset which
consists of
images of handwritten digits handwritten
digits can be easily recognized by
building a simple
tensorflow model let's see how when we
visualize our data using matplotlib
library the inputs will look something
like this
then we create our tensorflow model to
create a basic tensorflow model
we need to initialize the variables and
start a session then after training the
model
we can validate the data and then
predict the accuracy this model has
predicted
92 accuracy let's see which is pretty
well for this model
so that's all for tensorflow if you need
to understand this tutorial in detail
then you can go ahead and watch our deep
learning tutorial from simply learn as
shown in the right corner interesting
right let's move on to the next library
now let's talk about
a common yet a very powerful python
library called numpy
numpy is a fundamental package for
numerical computation in python it
stands for numerical python as the name
suggests it has around
18 000 comments on github with an active
community of
700 contributors it's a general purpose
array processing package
in a way that it provides high
performance multi-dimensional objects
called arrays and tools for working with
them
also numpy addresses the slowness
problem partly by providing these
multi-dimensional arrays that we talked
about and then
functions and operators that operate
efficiently on these arrays
interesting right now let's talk about
features of numbai
it's very easy to work with large arrays
and mattresses using numpy
numpy fully supports object oriented
approach for example
coming back to nd array once again it's
a class possessing numerous
methods and attributes ndra provides for
larger
and repeated computations numpy offers
vectorization it's more faster and
compact than traditional methods
i always wanted to get rid of loops and
vectorization of
numpy clearly helps me with that now
let's talk about the applications of
numpy numpy along with pandas is
extensively used in data analysis which
forms the basis of data science
it helps in creating the powerful
n-dimensional array whenever we talk
about
numpy the mention of the array we cannot
do it
without the mention of the powerful
n-dimensional array
also number is extensively used in
machine learning when we are creating
machine learning models
as in where it forms the base of other
libraries like sci-fi
scikit-learn etc when you start creating
the machine learning models in data
science you will realize
that all the models will have their
basis numpy or pandas
also when number is used with scipy and
matplotlib it can be used as a
replacement of
matlab now let's look at a simple
example of an
array in numpy as you can see here there
are multiple array manipulation
routines like there are basic examples
where you can copy the values from one
array to another we can give a new shape
to an
array from maybe one dimensional we can
make it as a two-dimensional array we
can return a copy of the
array collapsed into one dimension now
let's look at an example where
this is a jubilee notebook and we will
just create a basic
array and for detailed explanation you
can watch our other videos
which targets on these explanations of
each libraries so first of all whenever
we are using any library in python we
have to import it so now
this np is the areas which we will be
using let's create a simple
array
let's look what is the type of this
array
so this is an end array type of array
also let's look what's the shape of this
array
so this is a shape of the array now here
we saw that we can
expand the shape of the array
so this is where you can change the
shape of the array using
all those functions now let's create
another using arrange functions if i
give
arrange 12 it will give me a 1d array of
12 numbers
like this now we can reshape this array
to 3 comma 4 or we can write it here
itself
so this is how arrange function and the
reshape function works
for numpy now let's discuss the next
library which is scipy
so this is another free and open source
python library
extensively used in data science for
high level computations
so this library as the name suggests
stands for scientific python
and it has around 19 000 comments on
github with an
active community of 600 contributors it
is extensively used for scientific and
technical computations
also as it extends numpy it provides
many user-friendly and efficient
routines for scientific calculations
now let's discuss about some features of
scipy so scipy has this collection of
algorithms and functions which is built
on the numpy extension of python
secondly it has various high level
commands for data manipulation
and visualization also the nd image
function of scipy
is very useful in multi-dimensional
image processing
and it includes built-in functions for
solving differential equations
linear algebra and many more so that was
about the features of sci-fi
now let's discuss its applications so
cyber is used in multi-dimensional
image operations it has functions to
read images from disk into number
arrays to write arrays to discuss images
resize
images etc solving differential
equations
fourier transforms then optimization
algorithms
linear algebra etc let's look at a
simple example to learn what kind of
functions are there in sci-fi
here i'm importing the constants package
of scipy library
so in this package it has all the
constants so here
i'm just mentioning c or h or any
and this library already knows what it
has to fetch like speed of light
planck's constant etc so this can be
used in further calculations
data analysis is an integral part of
data science data scientists spend most
of the day
in data munching and then cleaning the
data also hence mention of pandas is a
must in data science life cycle
yes pandas is the most popular and
widely used python library for data
science along with numpy and matplotlib
the name itself stands for python data
analysis with around 17 000 comments on
github and an
active community of 1200 contributors it
is heavily used for data analysis and
cleaning as it provides fast
flexible data structures like data
frames series which are designed
to work with structured data very easily
and intuitively
now let's talk about some features of
pandas so panas offers this eloquent
syntax and rich functionalities like
there are
various methods in pandas like drop n a
fill n a which gives you the freedom
to deal with missing data also panas
provides a powerful apply function
which lets you create your own function
and run it across a series of data now
forget about
writing those for loops while using
pandas also
this library's high level abstraction
over low level numpy which is written in
pure c
then it also contains these high level
data structures and manipulation tools
which makes it very easy to work with
pandas like their data structures and
series now let's discuss the
applications of pandas
so panas is extensively used in general
data wrangling and data cleaning then
pandas also finds its usage in edl jobs
for data transformation and data storage
as it has excellent support for loading
csv files into its data frame format
then pandas is used in a variety of
academic and commercial domains
including statistics finance
neuroscience economics web analytics etc
then pandas is also very useful in time
series specific functionality
like date range generation moving window
linear regression
date shifting etc now let's look at a
very simple example
of how to create a data frame so
dataframe is a very
useful data structure in pandas and it
has very powerful functionalities
so here i'm only enlisting important
libraries in data science you can
explore more of our videos to learn
about these libraries in detail so let's
just go ahead and create a data frame
i'm using jupyter notebook again and in
this
before using pandas here i'm importing
the
pandas library let me go and run this
so in dataframe we can import a file a
csv file
excel files there are many functions
doing these things
and we can also create our own data and
put it into data frame so here i am
taking random data and putting in a data
frame also i'm creating an index
and then also giving the column names so
pd
is the alias we've given pandas random
data of 6x4
index which is taking a range of six
numbers and column name i'm giving as
abcd
now let's go ahead and look at it so
here
it has created a data frame with my
column names up abcd
my list has six numbers zero to five
and a random data of six by four
so dataframe is just another table with
rows and columns where you can do
various functions over it
also i can go ahead and describe this
data frame
to see so it's giving me all these
functionalities where count and mean and
standard
deviation etc okay so that was about
pandas
now let's talk about next library and
the last one so matplotlib for me is the
most
fun library out of all of them why
because it has such
powerful yet beautiful visualizations
we'll see in the coming slides
plot and matplotlib suggests that it's a
plotting library for python
it has around 26 000 comments on github
and a very vibrant community of 700
contributors
and because of such graphs and plots
that it produces it's majorly used for
data visualization
and also because it provides an object
oriented api which can be used to embed
those plots into our applications
let's talk about the features of
matplotlib the pi plot module of
matplotlib provides matlab-like
interface
so matplotlib is designed to be as
usable as matlab with an advantage
of being free and open source also it
supports
dozens of back-ends and output types
which means you can use it
regardless of which operating system
you're using or which output format you
wish
pandas itself can be used as wrappers
around matplotlibs api
so as to drive matplotlib via cleaner
and more modern apis
also when you start using this library
you will realize that it has a very
little memory consumption
and a very good runtime behavior now
let's talk about the applications of
matplotlib
it's important to discover the unknown
relationship between the variables in
your data set
so this library helps to visualize the
correlation analysis of variables
also in machine learning we can
visualize 95 percent confidence interval
of the model just to communicate how
well our model fits the data
then matlab finds its application and
outlier detection using scatter plot etc
and to visualize the distribution of
data to gain instant insights
now let's make a very simple plot to get
a basic idea i've already imported the
libraries here so this function
matplotlib inline will help you
show the plots in the jupiter notebook
this is also called a magic function
i won't be able to display my plots in
the jupiter notebook if i don't use this
function
i am using this function in numpy
to fix random state for reproducibility
now i'll take
my n as 30 and will assign random values
to my variables
so this function is generating 30 random
numbers
here i'm trying to create a scatter plot
so i
want to decide the area let's
put this so this is multiplying 30 with
random numbers
to the power 2 so that we get the area
of the plot which we will see in just a
minute
so using the scatter function and the
alias of
matplotlib as plt i've created this
if i don't use this and i have very
small
circles as my scatter plot it's colorful
it's nice
so that's one very easy plot i suggest
that you explore more of matplotlib and
i'm sure you will enjoy it
let's create a histogram so i'm using my
the style as ggplot
and assigning some values to these
variables
any random values now we are assigning
bars and colors and alignment to the
plot and here we get the graph
so we can create different type of
visualizations
and plots and then work upon them using
matplotlib
and it's just that simple so that was
about the leading python libraries in
the field of data science
but along with these libraries data
scientists are also leveraging the power
of some other useful libraries
for example like tensorflow keras is
another popular library which is
extensively used for deep learning and
neural network modules
keras drafts both tensorflow and theano
backends so it is a good option if you
don't want to dive into details of
tensorflow
then scikit learn is a machine learning
library it provides
almost all the machine learning
algorithms that you need and it is
designed to interpolate with numpy and
scipy then we have c
bond which is another library for data
visualization we can say that seaborn is
an enhancement of matplotlib as it
introduces
additional plot types let's understand
linear regression and dig into the
theory
understanding linear regression linear
regression
is the statistical model used to predict
the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable
and the second one that we need to look
at closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest
possible accuracy if it's inaccurate we
can't use it
so it's very important we find out the
most accurate line we can get
since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data
we're going to jump back and take a look
at some euclidean geometry the simplest
form of a simple linear regression
equation
with one dependent and one independent
variable is represented
by y equals m times x plus c
and if you look at our model here we
plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2
y being the dependent variable remember
that from before
and x being the independent variable so
y
depends on whatever x is m in this case
is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the y
2 minus y 1 and x 2 minus x
1. and finally we have c which is the
coefficient
of the line or where it happens to cross
the zero axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression
we're going to go back to plotting the
amount of crop yield
based on the amount of rainfall and here
we have
our rainfall remember we cannot change
rainfall
and we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall
so we have our independent and our
dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data
and then we look at that we put the red
point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on
we can guess how good our crops are
going to be and we've created a nice
line right through the middle
to give us a nice mathematical formula
let's take a look and see what the math
looks like behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line
now before we dive into the math and the
formulas that go behind this
and what's going on behind the scenes i
want you to note
that when we get into the case study and
we actually apply some python script
that this math that you're going to see
here is already done automatically for
you
you don't have to have it memorized it
is however
good to have an idea what's going on so
if people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample
data set with five rows and find out how
to draw the regression line
we're only going to do five rows because
if we did like the rainfall with
hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics
so we'll go ahead and create our own two
sets of data
and we have our independent variable x
and our dependent variable
y and when x was 1 we got y equals 2
when x was 2 y was 4
and so on and so on if we go ahead and
plot this data on a graph
we can see how it forms a nice line
through the middle
you can see where it's kind of grouped
going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the
data coming in the x and the y the means
doesn't mean anything other than the
average
so we add up all the numbers and divide
by the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4
plus 5
over 5 equals 3 and the same for y
we get 4. if we go ahead and plot the
means on the graph
we'll see we get 3 comma 4 which draws a
nice line down the middle
a good estimate here we're going to dig
deeper into the math behind the
regression line
now remember before i said you don't
have to have all these formulas
memorized or fully understand them even
though we're going to go into a little
more detail of how it works
and if you're not a math wiz and you
don't know if you've never seen the
sigma character before
which looks a little bit like an e
that's opened up
that just means summation that's all
that is so when you see the sigma
character it just means we're adding
everything in that row
and for computers this is great because
as a programmer
you can easily iterate through each of
the xy points
and create all the information you need
so in the top half you can see where
we've broken that down into pieces and
as it goes through the first two points
it computes the squared value of x the
squared value of y
and x times y and then it takes all of x
and adds them up all of y adds them up
all of x squared adds them up and so on
and so on and you can see we have the
sum of
equal to 15 the sum is equal to 20 all
the way up to x
times y where the sum equals 66. this
all comes from our formula for
calculating a straight line where y
equals the slope
times x plus the coefficient c so we go
down below
and we're going to compute more like the
averages of these
and we'll explain exactly what that is
in just a minute and where that
information comes from is called the
square means error
but we'll go into that in detail in a
few minutes all you need to do is look
at the formula
and see how we've gone about computing
it line by line
instead of trying to have a huge set of
numbers
pushed into it and down here you'll see
where the slope
m equals and then the top part if you
read through the brackets you have the
number
of data points times the sum
of x times y which we computed one line
at a time there and that's just the 66
and take all that and you subtract it
from the sum of x
times the sum of y and those have both
been computed so you have 15
times 20. and on the bottom we have the
number of lines
times the sum of x squared easily
computed as
86 for the sum minus i'll take all that
and subtract
the sum of x squared and we end up as we
come across
with our formula you can plug in all
those numbers which is very easy to do
on the computer
you don't have to do the math on a piece
of paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6
and you'll get your c coefficient if you
continue to follow through that formula
you'll see it comes out as equal to 2.2
continuing deeper into what's going
behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x
using the linear equation where m equals
0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values
and we're going to go ahead and plot
them we're going to predict them so y
equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8
so on and so on and here the blue points
represent the actual
y values and the brown points represent
the predicted y
values based on the model we created the
distance between the actual and
predicted values
is known as residuals or errors
the best fit line should have the least
sum of squares of these errors
also known as e-square if we put these
into a nice
chart where you can see x and you can
see why what the actual values were
and you can see why i predict it you can
easily see where we take y
minus y predicted and we get an answer
what is the difference between those two
and if we square that
y minus y prediction squared we can then
sum those squared values
that's where we get the 0.64 plus the
0.36
plus one all the way down until we have
a summation equals two point four
so the sum of squared errors for this
regression line is two point four
we check this error for each line and
conclude the best fit line having the
least
e square value in a nice graphical
representation
we can see here where we keep moving
this line through the data points to
make sure the best fit line
has the least square distance between
the data points
and the regression line now we only
looked at the most
commonly used formula for minimizing the
distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points
like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors
root mean square error etc what you want
to take away from this is whatever
formula
is being used you can easily using a
computer programming and iterating
through the data
calculate the different parts of it that
way these complicated formulas you see
with the different summations and
absolute values are easily computed one
piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values
x and y well in the real world it's very
rare that you only have two values when
you're figuring out a solution
so let's move on to the next topic
multiple linear regression
let's take a brief look at what happens
when you have multiple
inputs so in multiple linear regression
we have uh well we'll start with the
simple linear regression where we had
y equals m plus x plus c and we're
trying to find the value of
y now with multiple linear regression we
have multiple variables coming in
so instead of having just x we have x1
x2 x3 and instead of having just
one slope each variable has its own
slope attached to it
as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3 and
we still just have the single
coefficient
so when you're dealing with multiple
linear regression you basically take
your single linear regression
and you spread it out so you have y
equals m1 times
x1 plus m2 times x2 so on all the way to
m to the nth x to the nth and then you
add your coefficient
on there implementation of linear
regression now we get into my favorite
part
let's understand how multiple linear
regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before
we were looking at a company and just
based on its rnd
trying to figure out its profit we're
going to start looking at the
expenditure
of the company we're going to go back to
that we're going to predict his profit
but instead of predicting it just on the
r d we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs
marketing costs and so on and from there
we're going to see if we can figure out
what the profit of that company is going
to be
to start our coding we're going to begin
by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression
we're going to take a look at the data
to see what we're playing with then
we'll go ahead
and format the data to the format we
need to be able to run it in the linear
regression model and then from there
we'll go ahead and solve it
and just see how valid our solution is
so let's start with importing the basic
libraries
now i'm going to be doing this in
anaconda jupiter notebook a very popular
ide
i enjoy it it's such a visual to look at
and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this
so break out your favorite python ide so
here we are in our jupiter notebook
let me go ahead and paste our first
piece of code in there and let's walk
through what libraries we're importing
first we're going to import numpy as in
p and then i want you to skip one line
and look at import pandas as
pd these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np
and you have to almost have that for
your sk learn toolbox you always import
that right off the beginning
pandas although you don't have to have
it for your sklearn libraries it does
such a wonderful job of importing data
setting it up into a data frame so we
can manipulate it rather easily and it
has a lot of tools also in addition to
that so we usually like to use the
pandas when we can and i'll show you
what that looks like
the other three lines are for us to get
a visual of this data and take a look at
it
so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as
plt and then seaborn as sns
seborn works with the matplot library so
you have to always import matplot
library and then seaborn sits on top of
it
and we'll take a look at what that looks
like you could use any of your own
plotting libraries you want there's all
kinds of ways to look at the data
these are just very common ones and the
seaborn is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody
and the final line is the amber scion
map plot library inline that is only
because i'm doing an
inline ide my interface in the anaconda
jupiter notebook
requires i put that in there or you're
not going to see the graph when it comes
up
let's go ahead and run this it's not
going to be that interesting so we're
just setting up variables
in fact it's not going to do anything
that we can see but it is importing
these different
libraries and setup the next step is
load the data set and extract
independent and dependent variables
now here in the slide you'll see
companies equals pd.read csv and it has
a long
line there with the file at the end 1000
companies.csv
you're going to have to change this to
fit whatever setup you have
and the file itself you can request just
go down to the commentary below this
video
and put a note in there and simply learn
we'll try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself
so we're going to add this code in here
and we're going to see that i have
companies equals pd.reader
underscore csv and i've changed this
path to match my computer
c colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot csv
and then below there we're going to set
the x equals to companies
under the i location and because this is
companies as a pd data set
i can use this nice notation that says
take every row
that's what the colon the first colon is
comma except for the last column that's
what the second part is
or we have a colon minus one and we want
the values set into there
so x is no longer a data set a pandas
data set but we can easily extract the
data from our pandas data set with this
notation
and then y we're going to set equal to
the last row
well the question is going to be what
are we actually looking at
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and we're going to look at the
companies dot
head which lists the first five rows of
data and i'll open up the file in just a
second so you can see where that's
coming from but let's look at the data
in here
as far as the way the pandas sees it
when i hit run
you'll see it breaks it out into a nice
setup this is what panda is
one of the things pandas is really good
about is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet
you have your rows and remember when
we're programming we always start with
zero
we don't start with one so it shows the
first five rows
zero one two 3 4 and then it shows your
different columns
r d spend administration marketing spend
state profit it even notes that the top
are column names it was never told that
but pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows
why don't we go ahead and open this file
up in a csv so you can actually see the
raw data so
here i've opened it up as a text editor
and you can see at the top we have rnd
spend comma administration comma
marketing spin comma state comma profit
carrier's return i don't know about you
but i'd go crazy trying to read files
like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that
top part the first five row now as nice
as this format is
where i can see the data to me it
doesn't mean a whole lot
maybe you're an expert in business and
investments and you understand
what uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents
compared to the administration cost of a
hundred and thirty six thousand eight
hundred ninety seven dollars and eighty
cents so on so on
helps to create the profit of 192
261 and 83 cents that makes no sense to
me whatsoever
no pun intended so let's flip back here
and take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means
so at this point we're going to use a
single line of code
to get a lot of information so we can
see where we're going with this
let's go ahead and paste that into our
notebook and see what we got going and
so we have the visualization
and again we're using sns which is
pandas
as you can see we imported the map plot
library dot pi plot as plt
which then the seaborn uses and we
imported the seaborn as sns
and then that final line of code helps
us show this
in our inline coding without this it
wouldn't display and you could display
it to a file in other means and that's
the matte plot library in line with the
amber sign at the beginning so here we
come down to the single line of code
seaborn is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame
so i can just take the companies dot
core for coordinates
and i can put that right into the
seaborn and when we run this
we get this beautiful plot and let's
just take a look at what this plot means
if you look at this plot on mine the
colors are probably a little bit more
purplish and blue than the original one
we have the columns and the rows we have
r and d spending we have administration
we have marketing spending and profit
and if you cross index any two of these
since we're interested
in profit if you cross index profit with
profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark
why because those are the same data they
have an exact correspondence
so r and d spending is going to be the
same as
rnd spending and the same thing with
administration costs so right down the
middle
you get this dark row or dark um
diagonal row that shows that this
is the highest corresponding data that's
exactly the same and as it becomes
lighter there's less connections between
the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit
and next it has a very high correlation
with r d spending
which we looked at earlier and it has a
slightly less
connection to marketing spending and
even less to how much money we put into
the administration so now that we have a
nice
look at the data let's go ahead and dig
in and create some actual useful
linear regression models so that we can
predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data
we're going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values
so let's see what that looks like we're
going to set up our linear regression
model
in two steps the first one is we need to
prepare
some of our data so it fits correctly
and let's go ahead and paste this code
into our jupiter notebook and what we're
bringing in is we're going to bring in
the sklearn
pre-processing where we're going to
import the label encoder
and the one hot encoder to use the label
encoder we're going to create a variable
called label encoder and set it equal to
capital l
label capital e encoder this creates a
class that we can reuse
for transferring the labels back and
forth now about now you should ask what
labels are we talking about
let's go take a look at the data we
processed before and see what i'm
talking about here
if you remember when we did the
companies dot head we printed the top
five rows of data we have our columns
going across
we have column zero which is r and d
spending
column one which is administration
column two which is marketing spending
and column three is state and you'll see
under state we have new york california
florida now to do a linear regression
model it doesn't know how to process
new york it knows how to process a
number so the first thing we're going to
do is we're going to change that new
york california and florida
and we're going to change those to
numbers that's what this line of code
does here
x equals and then it has the colon comma
3
in brackets the first part the colon
comma means that we're going to look at
all the different rows so we're going to
keep them all together but the only row
we're going to edit
is the third row and in there we're
going to take the label coder
and we're going to fit and transform the
x
also the third row so we're going to
take that third row we're going to set
it equal to a transformation
and that transformation basically tells
it that instead of having
a new york it has a zero or a one or a
two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x
and we go ahead and do that equal to one
hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation
preps our data force so it's completely
set the way we need it is just a row of
numbers
even though it's not in here let's go
ahead and print x
and just take a look what this data is
doing you'll see you have an array of
arrays
and then each array is a row of numbers
and if i go ahead and just do row 0
you'll see i have a nice organized row
of numbers that the computer now
understands
we'll go ahead and take this out there
because it doesn't mean a whole lot to
us it's just a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding
dummy variable trap this is very
important
why because the computers automatically
transformed
our header into the setup and it's
automatically transferred
all these different variables so when we
did the encoder
the encoder created two columns
and what we need to do is just have the
one because it has both the variable and
the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x
equals x colon comma one colon
all this is doing is removing that one
extra
column we put in there when we did our
one hot encoder in our label encoding
let's go ahead and run that and now we
get to create our linear regression
model
and let's see what that looks like here
and we're going to do that in two steps
the first step is going to be in
splitting the data
now whenever we create a predictive
model of data we always want to split it
up so we have a training set
and we have a testing set that's very
important otherwise we'd be very
unethical without testing it to see how
good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model
and train it and set it up let's go
ahead and paste this next piece of code
in here
and i'll go ahead and shrink it down a
size or two so it all fits on one line
so from the sklearn module selection
we're going to import train test split
and you'll see that we've created four
completely different variables we have
capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test that is the standard
way that they usually reference these
when we're doing different
models you usually see that a capital x
and you see the train and the test and
the lowercase
y what this is is x is our data going in
that's our rnd span our administration
our marketing
and then why which we're training is the
answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity that's what we're going
to shoot for in this
tutorial the next part train test split
we take
x and we take y we've already created
those
x has the columns with the data in it
and y has a column with profit in it and
then we're going to set the test size
equals point two that basically means
twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're going to put them off
to the side
so since we're using a thousand lines of
data that means that
200 of those lines we're going to hold
off to the side to test for later
and then the random state equals zero
we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this
it's not overly exciting cause it's
setting up our variables but the next
step
is the next step we actually create our
linear regression model now that we got
to the linear regression model
we get that next piece of the puzzle
let's go ahead and put that code in
there and walk
through it so here we go we're going to
paste it in there and let's go ahead and
since this is a shorter line of code
let's zoom up there so we can get a good
look and we have from the sklearn
dot linear underscore model we're going
to import linear regression
now i don't know if you recall from
earlier when we were doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
where we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this
summarization
and then we also looked at setting it up
with a different
lines and then we also looked all the
way down to
multiple linear regression where we're
adding all those formulas together
all of that is wrapped up in this one
section so what's going on here is i'm
going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually and then we do the
regressor dot fit
in this case we do x train and y train
because we're using the training data
x being the data in and y being profit
what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line
we've created the whole linear
regression model and we fit the data to
the linear regression model and you can
see that when i run the regressor
it gives an output linear regression it
says copy x equals true
fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model
now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it
and if you remember we kept a bunch of
data aside so we're going to do a y
predict variable and we're going to put
in the x test
and let's see what that looks like
scroll up a little bit paste that in
here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y
predict equals regressor dot predict x
test going in and this gives us y
predict
now because i'm in jupiter inline i can
just put the variable up there
and when i hit the run button it'll
print that array out
i could have just as easily done print
why predict
so if you're in a different ide that's
not an inline setup like the jupyter
notebook you can do it this
way print y predict and you'll see that
for the 200 different test variables we
kept off to the side
it's going to produce 200 answers this
is what it says the profit are for those
200 predictions
but let's don't stop there let's keep
going and take a couple look we're going
to take just a short
detail here and calculating the
coefficients and the intercepts
this gives us a quick flash at what's
going on behind the line
we're going to take a short detour here
and we're going to be calculating the
coefficient and intercepts
so you can see what those look like
what's really nice
about our regressor we created is it
already has a coefficients for us
we can simply just print regressor dot
coefficient
underscore when i run this you'll see
our coefficients here
and if we can do the regressor
coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that
this all came from the multiple
regression model and we'll flip over so
you can remember where this is going
into where it's coming from
you can see the formula down here where
y equals m1 times
x1 plus m2 times x2 and so on and so on
plus c
the coefficient so these variables fit
right into this formula
y equals slope 1 times column one
variable
plus slope two times column two variable
all the way to the
m into the n and x to the n plus c the
coefficient
or in this case you have minus eight
point eight nine
to the power of two cetera etc etc times
the first column and the second column
and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus
1 0 3 0 0 9 point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations
easy to understand and calculate now i
told you that was a short detour and
we're coming towards the end of our
script
as you remember from the beginning i
said if we're going to divide this
information we have to make sure it's a
valid model that this model works and
understand how good it works
so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use
to predict how good our prediction is
and let's take a look what that looks
like in code and so we're going to use
this
from sklearn.metrics we're going to
import
r2 score that's the r squared value
we're looking at the
error so in the r2 score we take our y
test versus our y predict y
test is the actual values we're testing
that was the one that was given to us
that we know are true
the y predict of those 200 values is
what we think it was true and when we go
ahead and run this
we see we get a 0.9352 that's the r2
score now it's not exactly a straight
percentage
so it's not saying it's 93 percent
correct but you do want that in the
upper 90s
o and higher shows that this is a very
valid prediction based on the r2 score
and if r-squared value of 0.91 or 92 as
we got on our model
remember it does have a random
generation involved this proves the
model is a good
model which means success yay we
successfully trained our model with
certain predictors and estimated the
profit
of the companies using linear regression
what is logistic regression as i
mentioned earlier logistic regression
is an algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how
this works let's say your car has not
been serviced for
quite a few years and now you want to
find out if it
is going to break down in the near
future so this is like
a classification problem find out
whether your car will break down
or not so how are we going to perform
this
classification so here's how it looks if
we plot
the information along the x and y axis
x is the number of years since the last
service was performed
and y is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was
this data rather was collected from
several car
users it's not just your car but several
car users so that is our
labeled data so the data has been
collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car
broke down and what was the probability
and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides
an idea or from this graph we can find
out whether
your car will break down or not we'll
see how so first of all
the probability can go from zero to one
as you all aware probability can be
between zero and one
and as we can imagine it is intuitive as
well
as the number of years are on the lower
side maybe
one year two years or three years till
after the service
the chances of your car breaking down
are very limited right so for example
chances of your car breaking down the
probability of your car breaking down
within two years of your last service
are 0.1
probability similarly 3 years is maybe
0.3
and so on but as the number of years
increases
let's say if it was six or seven years
there is almost a certainty that your
car is going to break down that is what
this
graph shows so this is an example of a
application of the classification
algorithm and we will see in little
details how exactly logistic regression
is applied here one more thing needs to
be added here is that the dependent
variable's outcome is discrete so
if we are talking about whether the car
is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about
what we are looking at is whether the
car is going to break down or not yes
or no that is what we are talking about
so here the outcome
is discrete and not a continuous value
so this is how the logistic regression
curve
looks let me explain a little bit what
exactly
how exactly we are going to determine
the class at the outcome rather so
for a logistic regression curve a
threshold has to be said
saying that because this is a
probability calculation remember this is
a probability calculation
and the probability itself will not be
0 or 1 but based on the probability
we need to decide what the outcome
should be so there has to be a threshold
like for example
0.5 can be the threshold let's say in
this case
so any value of the probability below
0.5
is considered to be 0 and any value
above 0.5
is considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of
1 and let's say an output of 0.29
is considered as 0 which means that the
car will not break down
so that's the way logistic regression
works now let's do a quick comparison
between
logistic regression and linear
regression because they both have
the term regression in them so it can
cause confusion
so let's try to remove that confusion so
what is linear regression
linear regression is a process is once
again
an algorithm for supervised learning
however
here you're going to find a continuous
value you're going to
determine a continuous value it could be
the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price
these are all continuous values these
are not discrete compared to a yes or
no kind of a response that we are
looking for in logistic regression so
this is one example of
a linear regression let's say the hr
team of a company
tries to find out what should be the
salary hike of an employee so they
collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available
and the system learns from us it is
trained and it learns from this labeled
information
so that when a new employees information
is fed
based on the rating it will determine
what should be the high so this is
a linear regression problem linear
regression
example now salary is a continuous
value you can get 5000 thousand five
hundred
five thousand six hundred it is not
discrete
like a cat or a dog or an apple or a
banana these are discrete or a
yes or no these are discrete values
right so this way
you're trying to find continuous values
is where
we use linear regression so let's say
just to extend on this scenario
we now want to find out whether this
employee is going to get a promotion
or not so we want to find out if that is
a discrete problem right a yes or no
kind of a
problem in this case we actually cannot
use
linear regression even though we may
have labeled data so this is the label
data so based on the employee rating
these are the ratings and then some
people got the
promotion and this is the ratings for
which people did not get promotion
that is a no and this is a rating for
which
people got promotion we just plotted the
data about
whether a person has got an employer has
got promotion
or not yes no right so there is nothing
in between and what is the employees
rating okay
and ratings can be continuous that is
not an issue but
the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes
no okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find
a straight line this is how it would
look and as you can see it doesn't look
very right because
looks like there will be lot of errors
this root mean square error if you
remember for
linear regression would be very very
high and also
the the values cannot go beyond zero
or beyond one so the graph should
probably look somewhat like this
clipped at 0 and 1. but still
the straight line doesn't look right
therefore instead of using a linear
equation
we need to come up with something
different and therefore the logistic
regression
model looks somewhat like this so we
calculate the probability
and if we plot that probability not in
the form of a straight line but we need
to use some other equation we will see
very soon what that equation is
then it is a gradual process right so
you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions
and then slowly uh at certain rating
they get promotion so that is a gradual
process
and this is how the math behind
logistic regression looks so we are
trying to find the
odds for a particular event happening
and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening
divided by the probability of the event
not happening
so p if it is the probability of the
event happening
probability of the person getting a
promotion and divided by the probability
of the person not getting
a promotion that is 1 minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds
range from 0 to infinity so when this
probability
is 0 then the odds will the value of the
odds is equal to zero
and when the probability becomes one
then the value of the odds is
one by zero that will be infinity but
the probability itself remains between
zero and one now this is how an equation
of a straight line looks so
y is equal to beta 0 plus beta 1 x where
beta 0 is the y intercept
and beta 1 is the slope of the line if
we take the
odds equation and take a log
of both sides then this would look
somewhat like this and
the term logistic is actually derived
from the fact that
we are doing this we take a log of px by
1 minus px
this is an extension of the calculation
of odds that we have seen right
and that is equal to beta0 plus beta1 x
which is the equation of the straight
line and now from here if you want to
find out the value of px we will
see we can take the exponential on both
sides
and then if we solve that equation we
will get the equation
of p x like this p x is equal to 1 by
1 plus e to the power of minus beta0
plus beta 1 x
and recall this is nothing but the
equation of the line
which is equal to y y is equal to beta0
plus
beta 1x so that this is the equation
also known as the sigmoid function and
this is the equation of the logistic
regression all right and if this is
plotted this is how the sigmoid curve
is obtained so let's compare
linear and logistic regression how they
are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or
used to solve regression problems and
logistic regression is used to solve
classification problems
so both are called regression but linear
regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have
had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression
are continuous in nature whereas here
they are categorical or discrete in
nature
and linear regression helps to estimate
the dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability
or the possibility of a particular event
happening and linear regression as the
name
suggests is a straight line that's why
it's called linear regression
whereas logistic regression is a sigmoid
function and
the curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s-shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression
in weather prediction whether it's going
to rain or not drain
now keep in mind both are used in
weather prediction if we want to find
the discrete values like whether it's
going to rain
or not rain that is a classification
problem we use logistic regression but
if you want to determine what is going
to be the temperature tomorrow then we
use
linear regression so just keep in mind
that in weather prediction we actually
use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be
rain or not it's going to be sunny or
not but it's going to snow or not these
are all
logistic regression examples a few more
examples
classification of objects this is a
again
another example of logistic regression
now here of course one distinction is
that
these are multi-class classification so
logistic regression is not used in its
original form but it is used in a
slightly different form
so we say whether it is a dog or not a
dog i hope you understand so instead of
saying is it a dog or a cat or an
elephant
we convert this into saying so because
we need to keep it
to binary classification so we say
is it a dog or not a dog is it a cat or
not a cat
so that's the way logistic regression
can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare
logistic regression is used to find the
survival rate of a patient so they take
multiple parameters
like trauma score and age and so on and
so forth
and they try to predict the rate of
survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and
see how we can apply logistic regression
to
predict the number that is shown in the
image so this is
actually a live demo i will take you
into jupyter notebook
and show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do
so let's say you have an eight by eight
image and
there the image has a number one two
three four and you need to train your
model to
predict what this number is so how do we
do this
so the first thing is obviously in any
machine learning process
you train your model so in this case we
are using logistic regression
so and then we provide a training set
to train the model and then we test how
accurate our model
is with the test data which means that
like any machine learning
process we split our initial data into
two parts training set and test set with
the training set we train our model
and then with the test set we test the
model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models
so let's take a look at the code and see
what we are doing so i will not go line
by line but just take you through some
of the blocks so first thing we do
is import all the libraries and then we
basically take a look at the
images and see what is the total number
of images
we can display using matplotlib some of
the images are a sample of these images
and then we split the data into training
and test as i mentioned earlier
and we can do some exploratory analysis
and then we build our model we train our
model with the training set
and then we test it with our test set
and
find out how accurate our model is using
the confusion matrix
the heat map and use heat map for
visualizing this and
i will show you in the code what exactly
is the confusion matrix and how it can
be used for
finding the accuracy in our example we
got we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so
what is the confusion matrix this is an
example of a confusion matrix
and this is used for identifying the
accuracy
of a classification model or like a
logistic regression model
so the most important part in a
confusion matrix
is that first of all this as you can see
this is a matrix and the size of the
matrix depends on how many outputs
we are expecting right so the most
important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum
numbers in its diagonal like in this
case that's why it has almost 93 94
percent because
the diagonals should have the maximum
numbers
and the others other than diagonals the
cells other than the diagonals should
have
very few numbers so here that's what is
happening so there is a two
here there are there's a one here but
most of them
are along the diagonal this what does
this mean this means that
the number that has been fed is zero
and the number that has been detected is
also
zero so the predicted value and the
actual value are the same so
along the diagonals that is true which
means that
let's let's take this diagonal right if
the maximum number is here that means
that
like here in this case it is 34 which
means that 34
of the images that have been fed or
rather actually there are two
misclassifications in there so
36 images have been fed which have
number four and out of which
34 have been predicted correctly as
number four
and one has been predicted as number
eight
and another one has been predicted as
number nine so these are two
misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagonal so if you have all of them so
for an ideal
model which has let's say 100 accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like a
hundred percent accurate
model okay so that's uh just of how to
use this
matrix uh how to use this uh confusion
matrix i know the name
uh is a little funny sounding confusion
matrix
but actually it is not very confusing
its very straightforward so you are just
plotting
what has been predicted and what is the
labeled information or what is the
actual data
that is also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more
information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that
all of them have been predicted
correctly there have been 38 zeros
and the predicted value and the actual
value is
is exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has
there are i think 37 plus 5 yeah 42
have been fed the images 42 images
are of digit three and uh the
accuracy is only 37 of them have been
accurately predicted
three of them have been predicted as
number seven
and two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook
and see how the code looks so this
is the code in in jupiter notebook
for logistic regression in this
particular demo what we are going to do
is
train our model to recognize
digits which are the images
which have digits from let's say 0 to 5
or 0 to 9
and and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these
numbers correctly or not so let's get
started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and then
the last line in this block is to load
the
digits so let's go ahead and run this
code then here we will visualize
the shape of these digits so we can see
here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
1797
by 64. these are like eight by eight
images
so that's that's what is reflected in
this shape now
from here onwards we are basically once
again importing some of the libraries
that are required like numpy and matplot
and we will take a look at uh some of
the sample
images that we have unloaded so this one
for example creates a figure
and then we go ahead and take a few
sample images
to see how they look so let me run this
code and
so that it becomes easy to understand so
these are about
five images sample images that we are
looking at
zero one 2 3 4. so this is how the image
is this is how the data is
okay and based on this we will
actually train our logistic regression
model
and then we will test it and see how
well it is able to
recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an eight
by eight pixel kind of a image and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not
activated that is the information
available for each pixel
now based on the pattern of this
activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified
as a zero for example right similarly as
you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to
learn uh for which a number what is the
pattern of the activation of the pixels
right so that is what we are going to
train our model okay
so the first thing we need to do is to
split our data
into training and test data set
right so whenever we perform any
training we split the data into training
and test so that the training data set
is used to train the system so we pass
this
probably multiple times and then we
test it with the test data set and the
split is
usually in the form of there and there
are various ways in which you can split
this data it is up to the individual
preferences in our case here we are
splitting
in the form of 23 and 77
so when we say test size as 20.23
that means 23 percent of that entire
data
is used for testing and the remaining 77
percent is used for training
so there is a readily available function
which is
uh called train test split so we don't
have to write any special code for the
splitting it will automatically
split the data based on the proportion
that we give here which is test size so
we just give the test size
automatically training size will be
determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and
the the results will be stored in x
underscore train
and y underscore train for the training
data set
and what is x underscore train these are
these are the features
right which is like the independent
variable and
why underscore train is the label right
so in this case what happens is we have
the input value which is or the features
value which is in x underscore train
and since this is the labeled data for
each of them
each of the observations we already have
the label information saying whether
this digit is a zero or a one
or a two so that this this is what will
be used for
comparison to find out whether the the
system is able to
recognize it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right
so this is the labor so the same way x
underscore train y underscore train
is for the training data set x
underscore test y
underscore test is for the test data set
okay so let me go ahead and execute this
code as well
and then we can go and check quickly
what is the
how many entries are there and in each
of these so x underscore train
the shape is 13 83
by 64. and y underscore train has 1383
because there is
nothing like the second part is not
required here
and then x underscore test shape
we see is four one four so actually
there are 414
observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically
what these four lines of code are are
saying okay
then we import the logistic regression
library and which is a part of scikit
learn
so we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these
the function and let me go ahead and
execute that
so that we have the logistic regression
library imported now we create an
instance of logistic regression right so
logistic regr is a is an instance of
logistic regression
and then we use that for training our
model so
let me first execute this code so these
two lines so the first line
basically creates an instance of
logistic regression model
and then the second line is where we are
passing
our data the training data set right
this is our
the the predictors and this is our
target
we are passing this data set to train
our model
all right so once we do this in this
case the data is not large but
by and large the training is what takes
usually a lot of time so we spend in
machine learning
activities in machine learning projects
we spend a lot of time
for the training part of it okay so here
the data set is relatively small so it
was pretty quick so all right so
now our model has been trained using the
training data set
and we want to see how accurate this is
so what we'll do is we will test it out
in probably
faces so let me first try out how well
this is
working for one image okay i will just
try it out with one image my the first
entry in my test
data set and see whether it is uh
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the
fit method there is a method called fit
which is for
training the model and once the training
is done if you want to test for
a particular value new input you use the
predict method
okay so let's run the predict method and
we pass
this particular image and
we see that the shape is or the
prediction is 4.
so let's try a few more let me see
for the next 10 seems to be fine
so let me just go ahead and test the
entire data set okay that's basically
what we will do so now we want to find
out how accurately
this has performed so we use the score
method to find what is the percentages
of accuracy and we see here that it has
performed up to 94 percent to accurate
okay
so that's on this part now what we can
also do is
we can also see this accuracy
using what is known as a confusion
matrix so
let us go ahead and try that as well
so that we can also visualize how well
this model has done so let me
execute this piece of code which will
basically import some of the libraries
that are required
and we we basically create
a confusion matrix and instance of
confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these
values so we have so this confusion
underscore matrix method
takes two parameters one is the y
underscore test
and the other is the prediction so what
is the y underscore test these are the
labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the
test data set okay so this is known to
us
and this is what the system has the
model has generated so we kind of create
the
confusion matrix and we will print it
and this is how the confusion matrix
looks as the name suggests it is a
matrix and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model
is determined by how many numbers are
there in the diagonal the more the
numbers
in the diagonal the better the accuracy
is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set
that is the first thing right so if you
add up all these numbers that will be
equal to the
number of observations in the test data
set and then
out of that the maximum number of them
should be in the diagonal that means the
accuracy is pretty good
if the the numbers in the diagonal are
less and in all other places there are a
lot of numbers
which means the accuracy is very low the
diagonal indicates a correct prediction
that this means that the actual value is
same as the predicted value here again
actual values same as the predictive
value and so on right so the moment
you see a number here that means the
actual value is something
and the predicted value is something
else right similarly here the actual
value is something
and the predicted value is something
else so that is
basically how we read the confusion
matrix now
how do we find the accuracy you can
actually add up the
total values in the diagonal so it's
like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so on
and divide that by the total number of
test observations
that will give you the percentage
accuracy using a confusion matrix
now let us visualize this confusion
matrix in a slightly
more sophisticated way using a heat map
so we will create a heat map with some
we'll add some colors as well
it's uh it's like a more visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea
so if we let me run this piece of code
and this is how
the heat map looks and as you can see
here the diagonals again are all the
values are
here most of the values so which means
reasonably this seems to be reasonably
accurate
and yeah basically the accuracy score is
94 percent this is calculated as i
mentioned
by adding all these numbers divided by
the total
test values or the total number of
observations in test data set
okay so this is the confusion matrix for
logistic regression all right so
now that we have seen the confusion
matrix
let's take a quick sample and see how
well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples
of the data so if we see here we
we picked up randomly a few of them so
this is
uh number four which is the actual value
and also the predicted value both
are four this is an image of zero so
the predicted value is also 0 actual
value is of course 0
then this is the image of 9 so this has
also been predicted correctly
9 and actual value is 9 and this is the
image of 1
and again this has been predicted
correctly as
like the actual value okay so this was a
quick demo of
logistic regression how to use logistic
regression to
identify images need for confusion
matrixes
classification models have multiple
output categories
most error measures will tell us the
total error in our model
but we cannot use it to find out
individual instances of errors in our
models
so you have your input coming in you
have your classifier
it measures the error and it says oh 53
of these are correct
but we don't know which 53 percent are
correct is it 53 percent correct
on guessing on the spam is it 23
guessing on spam and
27 guessing on what's not spam
this is where the confusion matrix comes
in
so during the classification we also
have to overcome the limitations of
accuracy
accuracy can be misleading for
classification problems
if there is a significant class
imbalance
a model might predict the majority class
for all cases
and have a high accuracy score
and so you can see here we have our
email coming in and there's two spams
the classifier comes in and goes hey it
only catches one of those spams and it
misclassifies one that's not spam
so our model predicted eight out of ten
instruments and will have accuracy of 80
percent
but is it classifying correctly
a confusion matrix represents a table
layout of the different
outcomes of prediction and results of a
classification
problem and helps visualize its outcomes
and so you see here we have our
simple chart predicted and actual
the confusion matrix helps us identify
the correct predictions of a model for
different individual
classes as well as the errors so you'll
see here that the values predicted by
our classifier are along the rows
this is what we're going to guess it is
our cl our model is guessing what this
is based on its
training so we've already trained the
model to
guess whether it's spam or not spam or
whatever it is you're working on
and then the actual values of our data
set are along the columns
so this is the actual value it's
supposed to be
people who can speak english will be
classified as positives
so because they have a remember 001. do
you speak english yes no
and you could extend this that they
might have do you speak
french do you speak whatever languages
and so you might have a whole lot of
classifiers that you would look at each
one of these
people who cannot speak english will be
classified as negatives
so they'll be a zero so zero ones
the number of times our actual positive
values are equal to predicted
positive values gives us true positive
tp
the number of times our actual negative
values are equal to predictive negative
values gives us true negative tn
the number of times our model wrongly
predicts negative values as positives
gives us a false positive
fp and you'll see when you're working
with these a lot
you know memorizing that is false
positive you can easily figure out what
that is and pretty soon you're just
looking at the fp
or the t p depending on what you're
working on and the number of times our
model wrongly predicts positive values
as negatives
gives us a false negative fp
now i'm going to do a quick step out
here
let's say you're working in the medical
and we're talking about
cancer uh do you really want
a bunch of false negatives you want zero
under false negative
uh so when we look at this confusion
matrix if you have five percent false
positives
and five percent false negatives it'd be
much better to even have
twenty percent false positives because
they go in and test it and
zero false negatives the same might be
true
if you're working on uh say a car
driving
is this a safe place for the car to go
well you really don't want any false
positives
you know yes this is safe right over the
cliff
so again when you're working on the
project or whatever it is you're working
on
this chart suddenly has huge value
we were talking about spam email how
many
important emails say from your banking
overdraft charge coming in
that you want to be a a true a false
negative you don't want it to go in the
spam folder
likewise you want to get as much of the
spam out of there but you don't want to
miss anything really important
confusion matrix metrics are performance
measures which help us find the accuracy
of our classifier
there are four main metrics accuracy
precision recall and f1 score
the f1 score is the one i usually hear
the most and accuracy is usually what
you put
on your chart uh when you're standing in
front of the shareholders how accurate
is it people understand
accuracy f1 score is a little bit more
on
the math side and so you got to be a
little careful when you're quoting f1
scores in the
when you're sitting there with all the
shareholders because a lot of them will
just glaze over
so confusion matrix metrics are
performance measures
which help us find the accuracy of our
classifier there are four main metrics
accuracy the accuracy is used to find
the portion of the correctly classified
values
it tells us how often our classifier is
right
it is the sum of all true values divided
by the total values
and this makes sense uh again it's one
of those things
i don't want to fall you know what
depends on what you're looking for
are you looking for uh not to miss any
spam mails
are you looking to drive down the road
and not run anybody over
precision is used to calculate the
model's ability to classify
positive values correctly it answers the
question
when the model predicts a positive value
how often is it right
it is the true positive divided by the
total number of predicted positive
values again this one depends on what
project you're working on
whether this is what you're going to be
focusing on
so recall it is used to calculate the
model's ability to predict positive
values
how often does the model actually
predict the correct
positive values it is the true positives
divided by the total number of
actual positive values and then your f1
score
it is the harmonic mean of recall and
precision it is useful when you need to
take both precision
and recall into account
consider the following two confusion
matrix derived from two different
classifier
to figure out which one performs better
we can
find the confusion matrix for both of
them
and you can see we're back to does it
classify
whether they can speak english or or
non-speaker they speak some they don't
know the english language and so we put
these two uh
confusion matrixes out here we can go
ahead and do the math behind that we can
look up the accuracy
that's a tpn plus tn over the tf plus tn
plus fp
plus fn and so we get an accuracy of
0.8125
and we have a precision if you do the
precision which is your
tp truth positive over tp plus
fp we get 0.891
and if we do the recall we'll end up
with the 0.825 that's your tp over tp
plus fn
and then of course your f1 score which
is two times precision times recall
over precision plus recall and we get
the 0.857
and if we do that with another model
let's say we had two different models
and we're trying to see which one
we want to use for whatever reason
we might go ahead and compute the same
things we have our accuracy
our precision and our recall and our f1
score
and as we're looking at this we might
look at the accuracy
because that's really what we're
interested in is how many people
are we able to classify as being able to
speak
english i really don't want to know if
i'm you know i i really don't want to
know if
they're non-speakers i'd rather miss 10
people speaking english
instead of 15. and so you can see from
these charts we'd probably go with the
first model
because it does a better job guessing
who speaks english and has a higher
accuracy because in this case
that is what we're looking for so uh
with that we'll go ahead and pull up a
demo so you can see what this looks like
in the python setup in in the actual
coding
for this we'll go into anaconda
navigator
if you're not familiar with anaconda
it's a really
good tool to use as far as doing display
in demos and for quick development
as a data scientist i just love the
package
now if you're going to do something
heavier lifting there's some limitations
with anaconda and with the setup
but in general you can do just about
anything in here with your python
and for this we'll go with jupiter
notebook jupiter lab is the same as
jupiter notebook
you'll see they now have integration
with pycharm if you work in pie charm
certainly there's a lot of other
integrations that anaconda has
and we've opened up i simply learned
files i work on
and create a new file called confusion
matrix demo
and the first thing we want to note is
the data we're working with
here i've opened it up in a word pad or
notepad or whatever
you can see it's got a row of headers
comma separated and then all the data
going down below
and then i save this in the same file so
i don't have to remember what path i'm
working on
uh of course if you have your data
separated and you're working with a lot
of data you probably want to put it into
a different folder or file depending on
what you're doing
and the first thing we're going to do is
go ahead and import our tools
we're going to use the pandas that's our
data frame
if you haven't had a chance to work with
the data frame please review panda's
data frame
going to simply learn you can pull up
the pandas data frame
tutorial on there and then we're going
to use uh
the scikit framework which is all
denoted as
sk learn and i can just pull this in you
can see here's the
scikit-learn.org with the stable version
that you can import into your python
and from here we're going to use the
train test split
for splitting our data we're going to do
some pre-processing
we're going to do use the logistic
regression model
that's our actual machine learning model
we're using
and then what this course this
particular setup is about is we're going
to do the accuracy score
the confusion matrix and the classifier
report
so let me go ahead and run that and
bring all that information in
and just like we open the file we need
to go ahead and load our data in here
so we're going to go ahead and do our
pandas read csv
and then just because we're in jupyter
notebook we can just put data to read
the data in here
a lot of times we'll actually let me
just do this i prefer to do the
just the head of the date or the top
part and you can see we have
age sex i'm not sure what cp stands for
test bps cholesterol so a lot of
different
measurements if you were in this domain
you want to know what all these
different
measurements mean i don't want to focus
on that
too much because when we're talking
about data science a lot of times you
have no idea what the data means
if you've ever looked up the breast
cancer measurement it's just a bunch of
measurements and numbers
unless you're a doctor you have no idea
what those measurements mean
but if it's your specialty and your
domain you better know them
so we're going to go ahead and create y
and it's going to we're going to set it
equal to the target
so here's our target value here and
there's either one or
zero so we have a classifier if you're
dealing with one zero true false
what do you have you have a classifier
and then our x is going to be
everything except for the target
so we're going to go ahead and drop the
target axis equals
one remember that's columns versus the
index or rows
axis equals zero would would give you an
error but you would
drop like row two and then we'll go
ahead and just print that out so you can
see what we're looking at
and here we have y data x data
and you can see from the x data we have
the x head and we can go ahead and just
do print
the y head data and run that
so this is all loading the data that
we've done so far
if there's a confusion in there go back
and rewind the tape and review it
and then we need to go ahead and split
our data into our x train
x test y train y test
and then keep in mind you always want to
split the data before
we do the scalar and the reason is is
that
you want the scalar on the training data
to be set on the training data
data or fit to it but not on the test
data think of this as being out in the
field
you're not it could actually alter your
results
so it's always important to do make sure
whatever you do to the training data
or whatever fit you're doing is always
done on the training
not on the test and then we want to go
ahead and
scale the data now we are working with
a linear regression model i'll mention
this here in a minute when we get to the
actual model
so some sometimes you don't need to
scale it when you're working with linear
regression models it's not going to
change your result as much as say a
neural network where it has a huge
impact uh but we're going to go ahead
and take here's our x train
x test y train y test we create our
scalar
we go ahead and scale the scale is going
to fit the x
train and then we're going to go ahead
and take our x train and transform it
and then we also need to take our x test
and transform it based on the scale on
here so that our x is now
between that nice minus one to one and
so this is all
uh our pre-data setup
and hopefully uh all of that looks
fairly familiar to you if you've done a
number of our other classes and you're
up to
the setup on here and then we want to go
ahead and do is create our model and
we're going to use the
logistic regression model and from the
logistic regression model
we're going to go ahead and fit our x
train and y train and then we'll run our
predicted value on here
and let's go ahead and run that and so
now
we are we actually have like our x test
and our prediction so if you remember
from
our matrix we're looking for the actual
versus the prediction
and how those compare and
if i take us back up here you're going
to notice that we imported the accuracy
score
the confusion matrix and the
classification report
and there's of course our logistic
regression the model we're using for
this
and i did mention i was going to talk a
little bit about scalar and the
regression model
the scalar on a lot of your regression
models uh your basic mass standard
regression models
and i'd have to look it up for the
logistic regression model when you're
using a standard regression model you
don't need to scale the data
it's already just built in by the way
the model works
in most cases but if you're in a neural
network and
there's a lot of other different setups
then you really want to take this
and fit that on there and so
we can go in and do the accuracy and
this is if you remember correctly we
were looking at the accuracy
with the english speaking so this is
saying
our accuracy as to whether this person
is
i believe this is the heart data set
it's going to be accurate about 85
percent of the time as far as whether
it's going to predict the person's going
to have
a heart condition or the one as it comes
up with the zero one on there
which would mean at this point that you
have an 85 percent uh being correct on
telling someone they're extremely high
risk for a heart attack kind of thing
and so we want to go ahead and create
our confusion matrix
and let me just do that
of course the software does everything
for us so we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see right here um here's our
25
prediction uh correct predictions right
here
and if you remember from our slide i'll
just bring this over says a nice visual
we have our true positive
false positive so we had 25 which were
true
that it said hey this person is going to
be high risk at heart
and we had four that were still high
risk that it said were false
so out of these 25 people or out of
these 29 people and that makes sense
because you have 0.85
out of 29 people it was correct on 25 of
them
and so uh here's our accuracy score we
were just looking at that
our accuracy is your true positive and
your true negative
over all of them so how true is it and
there's our accuracy
coming up here 0.85 and then we have our
nice matrix generated from that
and you can see right here is a similar
matrix we had going for the from the
slide
and this starts to this should start
asking questions at this point
um so if you're in a board meeting or
you're working with this
you really want to start looking at this
data here and saying well
is this good enough is this number of
people
and hopefully you'd have a much larger
data set it might is my
confusion matrix showing for the true
positive and uh
false positive is that acceptable for
what we're doing
uh and of course if you're going to put
together whatever data you're putting
out you might want to separate the
true negative false positive false
negative true positive
and you can simply do that by doing the
confusion matrix
and then of course the ravel part lets
you set that up so you can just split
that right up into a nice tuple
and the final thing we want to show you
here in the
coding on this part is the confusion
matrix metrics and so we can come in
here and just use the
matrix equals classification report the
y test and the predict
and then we're going to take that
classification report and go ahead and
print that out
and you can see here it does a nice job
giving you your accuracy your micro
average
your weighted average you have your
precision
your recall your f1 score and your
support
all in one window so you can start
looking at this data and saying oh okay
our precision's at point eight three uh
point eight seven for getting a a
positive and
point eight three for the negative side
for a zero
and we start talking about whether this
is a valid information or not to use
and when we're looking at a heart attack
prediction we're only looking at
one aspect what's the chances of this
person having a heart attack or not
you might have something where we went
back to the languages
maybe you also want to know whether they
speak english or
hindi or french and you can see right
here that we can now
take our confusion matrix and just
expand it as big as we need to depending
on how many different classifiers we're
working on
what is a decision tree let's go through
a very simple example before we dig in
deep
decision tree is a tree shape diagram
used to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision occurrence or reaction
let's start with a simple question
how to identify a random vegetable from
a shopping bag so we have this group of
vegetables in here
and we can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not
then it's going to be the purple fruit
to the left probably an eggplant
if it's true it's going to be one of the
red fruits is it diameter greater than 2
if false is going to be a what looks to
be a red chili
and if it's true it's going to be a bell
pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum problems that
decision tree can solve so let's look at
the two different categories the
decision tree can be used on
it can be used on the classification the
true false yes no
and it can be used on regression where
we figure out what the next value
is in a series of numbers or a group of
data in classification the
classification tree
will determine a set of logical if-then
conditions to classify
problems for example discriminating
between three types of flowers
based on certain features in regression
a regression tree is used when the
target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree
let's take a look at the advantages of
using a decision tree and we'll also
take a glimpse at the disadvantages
the first thing you'll notice is that
it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree
little effort is required for data
preparation so you don't have to do
special scaling there's a lot of things
you don't have to worry about when using
a decision tree it can handle
both numerical and categorical data as
we discovered earlier
and non-linear parameters don't affect
its performance
so even if the data doesn't fit an easy
curved graph you can still use it
to create an effective decision or
prediction if we're going to look at the
advantages of a decision tree
we also need to understand the
disadvantages of a decision tree
the first disadvantage is overfitting
overfitting occurs when the algorithm
captures
noise in the data that means you're
solving for one specific
instance instead of a general solution
for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree
a highly complicated decision tree tends
to have a low bias
which makes it difficult for the model
to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further
we need to look at some basic terms we
need to have
some definitions to go with our decision
tree in the different parts we're going
to be using we'll start with
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example
we have a group of animals in this
picture there's four different kinds of
animals and this data set
is considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals
as a big clump of uh entities so as we
start splitting it into subgroups we
come up with our
second definition which is information
gain
information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy
after the data set is split so in this
case based on the color yellow we've
split
one group of animals on one side as true
and those who aren't yellow
as false as we continue down the yellow
side we split based on the height
true or false equals ten and on the
other side height is less than 10 true
or false
and as you see as we split it the
entropy continues to be less and less
and less
and so our information gain is simply
the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute
entropy finally we went on the different
parts of our tree and they call the leaf
node
leaf node carries the classification or
the decision so it's the final
end at the bottom the decision node has
two or more branches
this is where we're breaking the group
up into different parts and
finally you have the root node the
topmost decision node is known as the
root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals i'll get in the
jungle today
maybe you're the hunter with the gun or
if you're more into photography
you're a photographer with a camera so
let's look at this group of animals
and let's try to classify different
types of animals
based on their features using a decision
tree so the problem statement is to
classify the different types of animals
based on their features using a decision
tree the data set is looking quite messy
and the entropy is high in this case so
let's look at a training set or a
training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at
height and then we have our different
animals we have our elephants our
giraffes our monkeys and our tigers
and they're of different colors and
shapes let's see what that looks like
and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data
in such a way that the information gain
is the highest
note gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy
after splitting so the formula for
entropy is the sum
that's what this symbol looks like that
looks like kind of like a
e funky e of k where i equals 1 to k
k would represent the number of animals
the different animals in there
where value or p value of i
would be the percentage of that animal
times the log
base two of the same the percentage of
that animal let's try to calculate the
entropy for the current data set
and take a look at what that looks like
and don't be afraid of the math you
don't really have to memorize this math
just be aware that it's there and this
is what's going on in the background
and so we have three giraffes two tigers
one monkey
two elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy
that equals three over eight so we have
three giraffes a total of eight
times the log usually they use base two
on the log so log base two
of three over eight plus in this case
it's yellow fence
two over eight two elephants over total
of eight times log base two
two over eight plus one monkey over
total of eight
log base two one over eight and plus two
over eight of the tigers log base two
over eight
and if we plug that into our computer or
calculator i obviously can't do logs in
my head
we get an entropy equal to 0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain now we're not
going to go through each set one at a
time to see what those numbers are we
just want you to be aware that this is a
formula or the mathematics behind it
gain can be calculated by finding the
difference of the subsequent entropy
values after a split
now we'll try to choose a condition that
gives us the highest
gain we will do that by splitting the
data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split
can you guess what that first split will
be just by looking at this image
as a human is probably pretty easy to
split it let's see if you're right
if you guessed the color yellow you're
correct let's say the condition that
gives us the maximum gain
is yellow so we will split the data
based on the color yellow
if it's true that group of animals goes
to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has to
decreased considerably however we still
need some splitting of both the branches
to attain an entropy value
equal to zero so we decide to split both
the nodes using
height as a condition since every branch
now contains
single label type we can say that
entropy in this case has reached the
least
value and here you see we have the
giraffes the tigers the monkey and the
elephants
all separated into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present
in the dataset with a hundred percent
accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python
and see what the programming code in the
scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be
whether they're going to repay their
loan or not for his bank and from that
we want to generate a problem statement
to predict if a customer will repay loan
amount
or not and then we're going to be using
the decision tree algorithm in python
let's see what that looks like and let's
dive into the code
in our first few steps of implementation
we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like
so the first thing i need is i need
something to edit my python and run it
in so let's flip on over
and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupyter notebook's really nice
for doing things on the fly
and let's go ahead and just paste that
code in the beginning and before we
start
let's talk a little bit about what we're
bringing in and then we're going to do a
couple things in here we have to make a
couple changes as we go through this
first part of the import
the first thing we bring in is numpy as
np
that's very standard when we're dealing
with mathematics especially with uh
very complicated machine learning tools
you almost always see the numpy come in
for your num
your numbers it's called number python
it has your mathematics in there in this
case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with
and then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the
pandas is a data frame setup and you can
liken this to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks
like an excel spreadsheet so as we come
back to this when you see
np or pd those are very standard uses
you'll know that that's the pandas and
i'll show you a little bit more we
explore the data in just a minute
then we're going to need to split the
data so i'm going to bring in our train
test and split
and this is coming from the sk learn
package cross validation
in just a minute we're going to change
that and we'll go over that too
and then there's also the sk.tree import
decision tree classifier that's the
actual tool we're using
remember i told you don't be afraid of
the mathematics it's going to be done
for you
well the decision tree classifier has
all that mathematics in there for you so
you don't have to figure it back out
again and then we have sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score our
setup that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data
and finally we still need the sklearn
import tree
and that's just the basic tree function
is needed for the decision tree
classifier and finally we're going to
load our data down here
and i'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here
one we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning
let's see what that looks like so the
first thing we had is we have an
error why is this error here well it's
looking at this it says
i need to read a file and when this was
written
the person who wrote it this is their
path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full
file name and you'll see it's on my c
drive and this is very lengthy
setup on here where i stored the
data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer will be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated
by if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below
and request it here in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to
full file name so let's go ahead and run
it now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding understanding these
different warnings and these different
errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a
opportunity to understand what's going
on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation
is depreciated so it's a warning on it's
being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation
and if you research this and go to the
sklearn site you'll find out that you
can actually just swap it right in there
with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning what they've done
is they've had two different developers
develop it in two different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one
that's all that is and very easy and
quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv let's talk a little bit
more about that and see what that looks
like both as a text file
because it's a comma separated variable
file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header
and it's got one two three four five
columns
and each column has data in it and let
me flip this over because we're also
going to look at this uh
in an actual spreadsheet so you can see
what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as
excel and zoomed in and you can see
we've got our columns
and our rows of data a little easier to
read in here we have a result
yes yes no we have initial payment last
payment credit score
house number if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a programmer if you're looking at
a small amount
of data i usually start by pulling it up
in different sources so i can see what
i'm working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be
too too large so you need to either
bring in a small amount that you can
look at it like we're doing right now
or we can start looking at it through
the python code so let's go ahead and
move on and take the next couple steps
to
explore the data using python let's go
ahead and
see what it looks like in python to
print the length and the shape of the
data
so let's start by printing the length of
the database
we can use a simple lin function from
python
and when i run this you'll see that it's
a thousand long and that's what we
expected there's a thousand lines of
data in there if you subtract
the column head this is one of the nice
things when we did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row 0 so
it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscore data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines
it also tells me there's five columns so
we were looking at the data we had five
columns of data
and then let's take one more step to
explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape
let's go ahead and use the pandas
module for head another beautiful thing
in the data set that we can utilize
so let's put that on our sheet here and
we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
panda's print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there
and then we went ahead and gave a label
for a print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and we run that and let's just take a
closer look at that let me zoom in here
there we go pandas do such a wonderful
job
of making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it
when you put it as the head it prints
the first five lines of the data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you
to start with the zero position and that
is what the data head does it pulls the
first five rows of data
puts in a nice format that you can look
at and view very powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet
or open office cal or trying to look at
a
word doc where it's all scrunched
together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape
of a thousand long five wide so we have
five columns
and we do the full date ahead you can
actually see what this data looks like
the initial payment last payment credit
scores house number
so let's take this now that we've
explored the data and let's start
digging into the decision tree
so in our next step we're going to train
and build our data tree
and to do that we need to first separate
the data out we're going to separate
into two groups
so that we have something to actually
train the data with and
then we have some data on the side to
test it to see how good our model
is remember with any of the machine
learning you always want to have some
kind of test set to weigh it against
so you know how good your model is when
you distribute it let's go ahead and
break this code down
and look at it in pieces so first we
have our x and
y where do x and y come from
well x is going to be our data and y is
going to be the
answer or the target you can look at
source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in
and the data that we're actually trying
to guess what the answer is going to be
and so to separate it we can simply put
in
x equals the balance of the data.values
the
first brackets means that we're going to
select all the lines
in the database so it's all the data and
the second one says we're only going to
look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero
zero is a yes or no and that's whether
the loan went default or not
so we want to start with one if we go
back up here that's the initial payment
and it goes all the way through the
house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers
and we're going to set that just equal
to the zero row
so it's just the zero row and then it's
all rows going in there so now we've
divided this into
two different data sets one of them with
the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test
your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it
and we have to know the answer to train
it with and then we have
x test where we're going to test that
data and we have to know in the end what
the y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules
this does it all for us and you can see
they set the test size equal to 0.3
so it's roughly 30 percent will be used
in the test and then we use a random
state so it's completely random which
rows it takes out of there
and then finally we get to actually
build our decision tree
and they've called it here clf
underscore entropy
that's the actual decision tree or
decision tree classifier
and in here they've added a couple
variables which we'll explore in just a
minute
and then finally we need to fit the data
to that
so we take our clf entropy that we
created
and we fit the x train and since we know
the answers for x trade or the y train
we go ahead and put those in and let's
go ahead and run this
and what most of these sklearn modules
do
is when you set up the variable in this
case we set the clf entropy called
decision tree classifier it
automatically prints out what's in that
decision tree
there's a lot of variables you can play
within here and it's quite beyond the
scope
of this tutorial to go through all of
these and how they work
but we're working on entropy that's one
of the options we've added that it's
completely a random state
of 100 so 100 percent and we have a max
depth of three
now the max depth if you remember above
when we were doing the different graphs
of animals
means it's only going to go down three
layers before it stops
and then we have minimal samples of
leaves is five so it's going to have at
least five leaves at the end so i'll
have at least three splits
i'll have no more than three layers and
at least five
end leaves with the final result at the
bottom now that we've
created our decision tree classifier not
only created it but trained it
let's go ahead and apply it and see what
that looks like so let's go ahead and
make a prediction
and see what that looks like we're going
to paste our predict code in here and
before we run it let's just take a quick
look at what it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our variable clf
entropy that we created and then you'll
see dot predict
and it's very common in the sk learn
modules
that their different tools have to
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use and
actual commercial use and
distributed it this would be the new
loans you're putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not
in this case so we need to test out the
data and just see how good our
sample is how good of our tree does at
predicting the loan payments
and finally since anaconda jupiter
notebook is it works as a command line
for python we can simply put the y
predict e in to print it i could just as
easily have put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out
we'll go ahead and do that it doesn't
matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly
300 in here remember it's 30 percent of
a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our
test went in there and this is what our
y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data
and try to figure out just how good a
model we have so here we go since
sklearn does all the heavy lifting for
you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is
and let's go ahead and go through that
and see what that means and what that
looks like let's go ahead and paste this
in
and let me zoom in a little bit there we
go
so you have a nice full picture and
we'll see here we're just going to do a
print accuracy
is and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see
where that's coming from that's coming
from here down here from sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score and you could
probably run a script make your own
script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right
and so we put in our y test that's the
one we ran the predict on
and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got
and we're just going to multiply that by
a hundred because this is just going to
give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like and if you see here we got an
accuracy of 93.6667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit
we can tell people it has about a 93.65
fitting to it
so just a quick recap on that we now
have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not
the accuracy of the model is about 94.6
percent
the bank can now use this model to
decide whether it should approve the
loan request from a particular customer
or not
and so this information is really
powerful we may not be able to as
individuals understand all these numbers
because they have thousands of numbers
that come in but you can see that this
is a smart decision for the bank
to use a tool like this to help them to
predict how good their
profit's going to be off of the loan
balances and how many are going to
default or not how does a random
forest work as a whole so to begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have
built three trees and we're going to
start with the first tree that looks
like this
just like we did in the example this
tree looks at the diameter if it's
greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger
diameter and if the color is orange it's
going to go to the right
true we're using oranges now instead of
lemons and if it's red it's going to go
to the left
false we build a second tree very
similar but
split differently instead of the first
one being split by a diameter
this one when they created it if you
look at that first bowl it has a lot of
red
objects so it says is the color red
because that's going to bring our
entropy down the fastest
and so of course if it's true it goes to
the left if it's false it goes to the
right
and then it looks at the shape false are
true and so on and so
on and tree three is the diameter equal
to one
and it came up with this because there's
a lot of cherries in this bowl
so that would be the biggest split on
there is is the diameter equal to one
that's going to drop the entropy the
quickest
and as you can see it splits it into
true if it goes false and they've added
another category
does it grow in the summer and if it's
false it goes off to the left if it's
true
it goes off to the right let's go ahead
and bring these three trees so you can
see them all in one image
so this would be three completely
different trees categorizing a fruit
and let's take a fruit now let's try
this and this fruit if you look at it
we've blackened it out
you can't see the color on it so it's
missing data remember one of the things
we talked about earlier
is that a random forest works really
good if you're missing data
if you're missing pieces so this fruit
has an image but maybe the person had a
black and white
camera when they took the picture and
we're going to take a look at this
and it's going to have to put the color
in there so ignore the color down there
but the diameter equals 3 we find out it
grows in the summer equals yes
and the shape is a circle and if you go
to the right you can look at what one of
the decision trees did
this is the third one is the diameter
greater than equal to three
is the color orange well it doesn't
really know on this one but
if you look at the value it'd say true
and you go to the right tree
two classifies it as cherries is the
color
equal red is the shape of circle true it
is a circle
so this would look at it and say oh
that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal
one well that's false does it grow in
the summer
true so it goes down and looks at as
oranges so
how does this random forest work the
first one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says
it's an orange and you can guess if you
have two oranges and one says it's a
cherry
when you add that all together the
majority of the vote says
orange so the answer is it's classified
as an orange
even though we didn't know the color and
we're missing data on it i don't know
about you
but i'm getting tired of fruit so let's
switch
and i did promise you we'd start looking
at a case example
and get into some python coding today
we're going to use the case
the iris flower analysis this is the
exciting part as we roll up our sleeves
and actually look at some python coding
before we start the python coding we
need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to
let's try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in
python let's see how it can be done so
here we begin to go ahead and
implement our python code and you'll
find that the first half of our
implementation
is all about organizing and exploring
the data coming in
let's go ahead and take this first step
which is loading the different modules
into python and let's go ahead and put
that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using
the anaconda jupiter notebook which is
one of my favorites
certainly there's notepad plus plus and
eclipse and dozens of others or just
even
using the python terminal window any of
those will work just fine to go ahead
and explore
this python coding so here we go let's
go ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook
and i've already opened up a new page
for python 3 code
and i'm just going to paste this right
in there and let's take a look and see
what we're bringing into
our python the first thing we're going
to do is from the sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module
that allows us to bring in the data the
load iris
and the iris is so popular it's been
around since 1936
when ronald fisher published a paper on
it and they're measuring the different
parts of the flower
and based on those measurements
predicting what kind of flower it is
and then if we're going to do a random
forest classifier we need to go ahead
and import a random forest classifier
from the sklearn module
so sklearn.ensemble import random fourth
classifier
and then we want to bring in two more
modules and these are
probably the most commonly used modules
in python and data science
with any of the other modules that we
bring in
and one is going to be pandas we're
going to import pandas as pd
pd is a common term used for pandas and
pandas is basically
creates a data format for us where when
you create a pandas
data frame it looks like an excel
spreadsheet
and you'll see that in a minute when we
start digging deeper into the code
panda is just wonderful because it plays
nice with all the other modules in there
and then we have numpy which is our
numbers python
and the numbers python allows us to do
different mathematical sets on here
we'll see right off the bat
we're going to take our np and we're
going to go ahead and seed the
randomness with it with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded
and then let's take a look at the next
module on here the next six slides
including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this
is about looking at the data and getting
it all set so let's go ahead and take
this code right here the script and
let's get that over into our jupiter
notebook
and here we go we've gone ahead and run
the imports
and i'm going to paste the code down
here and let's take a look and see
what's going on
the first thing we're doing is we're
actually loading the iris
data and if you remember up here we
loaded the module that tells it how to
get the iris data now we're actually
assigning that data to the variable iris
and then we're going to go ahead and use
the df to define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if you
remember that's pandas as
pd so that's our pandas and panda data
frame and then we're looking at iris
data and columns equals iris feature
names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created
what looks like an excel spreadsheet and
in this excel spreadsheet we have set
the columns
so up on the top you can see the four
different columns
and then we have the data iris.data down
below it's a little confusing without
knowing where this data is coming from
so let's look at the bigger picture and
i'm going to go print
i'm just going to change this for a
moment and we're going to print all of
iris
and see what that looks like so when i
print all of iris
i get this long list of information and
you can scroll through here and see all
the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary and in a
python dictionary
you'll have a key or a label
and this label pulls up whatever
information comes after it
so feature names which we actually used
over here under columns
is equal to an array of sepal length
sepal width
pedal length pedal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns
and if you scroll down far enough you'll
also see data down here oh
goodness it came up right towards the
top and data is equal to the different
data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names
the target names which is further down
and we'll show you that also in a minute
let's go ahead and set that back to the
head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas
and panda data frames is when you do
df.head
or the pandadataframe.head it'll print
the first
five lines of the data set in there
along with the headers if you have it in
this case we have the column header set
to iris features
and in here you'll see that we have zero
one two
three four in python most arrays always
start at zero so when you look at the
first five it's going to be zero
one two three four not one two three
four five so now we've got our iris data
imported into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section here
of the code we're going to take a look
at the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our jupyter notebook
i'm going to put the code in here
and before i run it i want to look at a
couple things going on
so we have df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column
and here we have iris.target now these
are both in the
pandas setup on here so in pandas we can
do
either one i could have just as easily
done iris
and then in brackets target depending on
what i'm working on
both are acceptable let's go ahead and
run this code and see how this changes
and what we've done is we've added the
target from the iris data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict
so we have our data which tells us the
answer for all these different pieces
and then we've added a column with the
answer that way when we do
our final setup we'll have the ability
to program our neural network to look
for these
this different data and know what a
setosa is or
a vera color which we'll see in just a
minute or virginica those are the three
that are in there
and now we're going to add one more
column i know
we're organizing all this data over and
over again it's kind of fun
there's a lot of ways to organize it
what's nice about putting everything
onto
one data frame is i can then do
a printout and it shows me exactly what
i'm looking at and i'll show you that
where you where that's different where
you can alter that and do it slightly
differently
but let's go ahead and put this into our
script up to that now
and here we go we're going to put that
down here
and we're going to run that and let's
talk a little bit about what we're doing
now we're exploring data and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is
did your model work and to do this we
need to split the data and we split it
into two different
parts they usually call it the training
and the testing and so in here
we're going to go ahead and put that in
our database so you can see it clearly
and we've set it df remember you can put
brackets this is creating another column
is train so we're going to use part of
it for training and this equals
np remember that stands for
numpy.random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1.
and we're going to do it for each of the
rows that's where the length df comes
from
so each row gets a generated number and
if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
75 percent of the data roughly because
there's a randomness involved
and we're going to use that to train it
and then the other 25
we're going to hold off to the side and
use that to test it later on so
let's flip back on over and see what the
next step is so now that we've
labeled our database for which is
training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables
train and test and let's take this code
and let's bring it into our project
and here we go let's paste it on down
here and before i
run this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here
is we have up above we created remember
there's our
def dot head which prints the first five
rows and we've added a column
is train at the end and so we're going
to take that we're going to create two
variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test seventy-five percent
in train twenty-five percent in test
and then to sort that out we're going to
do that by doing df our main original
data frame with the iris data in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is train equals false it goes in the
test
and so when i run this we're going to
print out the number in each one
let's see what that looks like and
you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module
and it puts 32 in the testing module
which lets us know that there was 150
lines of data in here so if you went and
looked at the original data you could
see that there's 150 lines
and that's roughly 75 percent and one
and 25
for us to test our model on afterward so
let's jump back to our code and see
where this goes
in the next two steps we want to do one
more thing with our data
and that's make it readable to humans i
don't know about you but i hate looking
at
zeros and ones so let's start with the
features and let's go ahead and take
those and make those readable to humans
and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done
a couple very basic things we know that
the columns in our data frame again this
is a panda thing
the df columns and we know the first
four of them zero one two three that'd
be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sipa length sepa width
pedal length and pedal width and this
should be familiar because if you look
up here here's our column titles going
across
and here's the first four one thing i
want you to notice here
is that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupyter notebook or
you're running command line in the
terminal window
if you just put the name of it it'll
print it out this is the same as doing
print
features and the shorthand is you just
put features in here
if you're actually writing a code and
saving the script and running it by
remote
you really need to put the print in
there but for this when i run it you'll
see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter
and this is one of the fun thing about
jupiter notebooks is i'm just building
the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing
is we're going to go ahead and convert
the species on here
into something the computer understands
so let's put this code into our script
and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd dot
factorize train species
of zero so let's break this down just a
little bit
we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what's factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second
let's look at what train species is and
why we're looking at
the group 0 on there and let's go up
here
and here is our species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see
virginica and vera color we need to
convert that into something the computer
understands zeros and ones
so the train species of zero
because this is in the format of a of an
array of arrays
so you have to have the zero on the end
and then species is just that column
factorize goes in there looks at the
fact
that there's only three of them so when
i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set
and it's zeros ones and twos
representing the three different kinds
of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally
we get to actually start doing the
predicting so here we go
we have two lines of code oh my goodness
that was a lot of work to get to two
lines of code but there is a lot in
these two lines of code
so let's take a look and see what's
going on here and put this into
our full script that we're running and
let's paste this in here
and let's take a look and see what this
is we have we're creating a variable
clf and we're going to set this equal to
the random forest
classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with
as far as these two are concerned
they're very standard in
jobs all that does is to prioritize it
not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data
and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that
and then the random state is just how it
starts zero is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more
clf dot fit so we're fitting we're
training it we are actually
creating our random forest classifier
right here
this is a code that does everything and
we're going to take our training set
remember we kept our test
off to the side and we're going to take
our training set with the features
and then we're going to go ahead and put
that in and here's our target
the y so the y is 0 1 and 2
that we just created and the features is
the actual data going in
that we put into the training set let's
go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out
the random force classifier
and everything around it and so when
you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here
and i typed in y and printed out y
instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out
but if you're actually running your code
that wouldn't be the case
and what is printed out is it shows us
all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two you can see the random state
equals zero those are the two that we
sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these
the different meanings of all these
different settings on here some of them
are self-explanatory if you kind of
think about it a little bit like max
features as auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to
automatically take all four of them
whatever we send it it'll take
some of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be
like 1.4 million features in there
because you're doing legal documents and
that's how many different words are in
there
at that point you probably want to limit
the maximum features that you're going
to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we had the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this
we're looking at a lot of stuff here so
you might have in this case there's
probably only think
three leaf nodes maybe four you might
have thousands of leaf nodes at which
point you do need to put a cap on that
and say okay can only go
so far and then we're going to use all
of our resources on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is
limiting the process and making sure we
don't uh overwhelm a system and there's
some other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false
warm start is if you're programming it
one piece at a time externally
since we're not we're not going to have
like we're not going to continually to
train this
particular learning tree and again like
i said there's a lot of things in here
that you'll want to look up more detail
from the sk learn and if you're digging
in deep and running a major
project on here for today though all we
need to do is fit our train our features
and our target y so now we have our
training model
what's next if we're going to create a
model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside
the test feature test group 25
of the data so let's go ahead and take
this code and let's put it into
our script and see what that looks like
okay here we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and
twos which represents the three type of
flowers the setosa the virginica and the
versacolor and what we're putting into
our predict
is the test features and i always kind
of like to know what it is
i am looking at so real quick we're
going to do
test features and remember features is
an array
of sepal length steeple width pedal
length pedal width
so when we put it in this way it
actually loads all these different
columns that we loaded into features
so if we did just features let me just
do features in here seeing what features
looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames
you'll see that it's an index so when
you put an index in like this
into test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case we're going to go ahead
and put those into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2
and we're going to put those in and
we're going to predict what our
new forest classifier is going to come
up with
and this is what it predicts it predicts
0 0 0 1
2 1 1 2 two and and uh
again this is the flower type setosa
virginica and versacolor
so now that we've taken our test
features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts
is we can actually generate a different
prediction model
when i say different we're going to view
it differently it's not that the data
itself is different
so let's take this next piece of code
and put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing
uh predict and we've added underscore
proba for probability
so there's our clf.predict probability
so we're running it
just like we ran it up here but this
time with this we're going to get a
slightly different result
and we're only going to look at the
first 10. so you'll see down here
instead of looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here
that this generates a much larger field
on the probability
and let's take a look and see what that
looks like and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end
and if you remember from all the theory
we did this is the predictors
the first one is predicting a one for
setosa
it predicts a zero for virginica and it
predicts a
0 for versacolor and so on and so on and
so on and let's um you know what i'm
going to change this just a little bit
let's look at 10 to 20
just because we can and we start to get
a little different of data
and you'll see right down here it gets
to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's gonna go with
the first one
so it says uh setosa gets zero votes
virginica gets point five votes
versus color gets point five votes but
let's just go with the
virginica since these two are equal and
so on and so on down the list
you can see how they vary on here so now
we've looked at both how to do a basic
predict of the features
and we've looked at the predict
probability let's see what's next on
here
so now we want to go ahead and start
mapping names for the plants
we want to attach names so that it makes
a little more sense for us
and this we're going to do in these next
two steps we're going to start
by setting up our predictions
and mapping them to the name so let's
see what that looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it
and this goes along with the next piece
of code so we'll skip through this
quickly and then come back to a little
bit
so here's iris dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the
the names that we've been talking about
this whole time the setosa virginica
versus color and then we're going to
go ahead and do the prediction again
we've run that we could have just set a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we'll go
ahead and run it again clf dot predict
test features remember that returns the
zeros the ones and the twos
and then we're going to set that equal
to predictions
so this time we're actually putting it
in a variable and when i run this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa
we're only looking at the first five we
could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there
and you'll see that it starts mapping it
to all the different flower types the
versa color and the virginica in there
and let's see how this goes with the
next one so let's take a look at
the top part of our species in here and
we'll take this code and put it in our
script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together the first one
is our predictions and i went ahead and
did predictions through 25 let's just do
five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our
test model and then we come down here we
look at test
species i remember i could have just
done test dot species
dot head and you'll see it says setosa
satosa setosa setosa
and they match so the first one is what
our
forest is doing and the second one
is what the actual data is now is we
need to combine these so that we can
understand what that means we need to
know how good
our forest is how good it is at
predicting the features so that's where
we come up to the next step which is
lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals
so we have a nice chart to look at and
let's go ahead and put that in our
script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm going to
because i'm on the jupiter notebook i
can do a control minus so you can see
the whole line there
there we go resize it and let's take a
look and see what's going on here
we're gonna create in pandas remember pd
stands for pandas
and we're doing a cross tab this
function takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica
and the actual species setosa versacolor
virginica and so
the way to read this chart and let's go
ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here
when you read this chart you have setosa
where they meet
you have versus color where they meet
and you have virginica where they meet
and they're meeting where the actual and
the predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate
so now we have two two inaccurate
predictions
and 30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy
is 93 that's just 30 divided by 32
and if we multiply it by a hundred we
can say that it is
93 percent accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting
before we wrap it up so let's flip back
on over to my script
in here we're going to take this line of
code from up above
i don't know if you remember it but
predix equals the iris dot
target underscore names so we're going
to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features
but you know we're not just testing it
we want to actually deploy it
so at this point i would go ahead and
change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe
let's just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in
and we'll put two flowers in here and
then i actually want to see what the
answer are
is so let's go ahead and type in preds
and print that out
and when i run this you'll see that i've
now predicted two flowers that maybe i
measured in my front yard as
versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual end product
going out to be used on data that you
don't know the answer
for so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this
why support vector machine so in this
example last week
my son and i visited a fruit shop dad is
that an apple or a strawberry
so the question comes up what fruit do
they just pick up from the fruit stand
after a couple of seconds you could
figure out that it was a strawberry
so let's take this model a step further
and let's uh
why not build a model which can predict
an unknown data and in this
we're going to be looking at some sweet
strawberries or crispy apples we want to
be able to label those two and decide
what the fruit is
and we do that by having data already
put in so we already have a bunch of
strawberries we know our strawberries
and they're already labeled as such we
already have a bunch of apples we know
our apples and are labeled as such
then once we train our model that model
then can be given the new data and the
new data is this image in this case you
can see a question mark on it
and it comes through and goes it's a
strawberry in this case we're using
the support vector machine model svm is
a
supervised learning method that looks at
data and sorts it into one of two
categories
and in this case we're sorting the
strawberry into the strawberry site
at this point you should be asking the
question how does the prediction work
before we dig into an example with
numbers let's apply this to our fruit
scenario we have our support vector
machine
we've taken it and we've taken labeled
sample of data
strawberries and apples and we draw on a
line down the middle
between the two groups this split now
allows us to take
new data in this case an apple and a
strawberry and place them in the
appropriate group based on which side of
the line they fall in
and that way we can predict the unknown
as colorful and tasty as the fruit
example is
let's take a look at another example
with some numbers involved and we can
take a closer look at how the math works
in this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with
a set of people with a different height
and a different weight
and to make this work we'll have to have
a sample data set
of female we have their height and
weight 174
65 174 88 and so on and we'll need a
sample data set of the male they have a
height 179
90 180 to 80 and so on let's go ahead
and put this on a graph so we have a
nice visual so you can see here we have
two groups
based on the height versus the weight
and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier
let's add a new data point and figure
out if it's male or female
so before we can do that we need to
split our data first
we can split our data by choosing any of
these lines
in this case we've drawn two lines
through the data in the middle
that separates them in from the women
but to predict the gender of a new data
point we should split the data in the
best possible way and we say the best
possible way
because this line has a maximum space
that separates
the two classes here you can see there's
a clear split between the two
different classes and in this one
there's not so much a clear split
this doesn't have the maximum space that
separates the two that is why this line
best splits the data we don't want to
just do this by eyeballing it
and before we go further we need to add
some technical terms to this
we can also say that the distance
between the points and the line should
be as far as possible
in technical terms we can say the
distance between the support vector
and the hyperplane should be as far as
possible
and this is where the support vectors
are the extreme points in the data set
and if you look at this data set they
have circled two points which seem to be
right on the outskirts of the woman and
one on the outskirts of the men
and hyperplane has a maximum distance to
the support vectors of
any class now you'll see the line down
the middle and we call this the
hyperplane because when you're dealing
with multiple dimensions
it's really not just a line but a plane
of intersections
and you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in
dashed lines the math behind this is
very simple
we take d plus the shortest distance to
the closest
positive point which would be on the min
side and d minus is the shortest
distance to the closest
negative point which is on the women's
side the sum of d
plus and d minus is called the distance
margin or the distance between the two
support vectors that are shown
in the dashed lines and then by finding
the largest distance margin we can get
the optimal hyperplane once we've
created an optimal hyperplane we can
easily see which side the new data fits
in and based on the hyperplane we can
say the new data point belongs to the
male gender
hopefully that's clear how that works on
a visual level as a data scientist you
should also be asking what happens if
the hyperplane is not
optimal if we select a hyperplane having
low margin
then there is a high chance of
misclassification this particular svm
model
the one we discussed so far is also
called referred to as the
ls vm so far so clear but a question
should be coming up
we have our sample data set but instead
of looking like this
what if it looked like this where we
have two sets of data
but one of them occurs in the middle of
another set you can see here where we
have the blue and the yellow
and then blue again on the other side of
our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this
it's necessary to move away from a 1d
view of the data to a two-dimensional
view of the data and for the
transformation we use what's called a
kernel function the kernel function will
take the 1d input and transfer it to a
two-dimensional output as you can see in
this picture here
the 1d when transferred to a
2-dimensional makes it very easy to draw
a line between the two data sets
what if we make it even more complicated
how do we perform an svm for this type
of data set
here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside
in this case we're going to segregate
the two classes
we have our sample data set and if you
draw a line through it's obviously not
an optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that
we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d array
and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data
before we start looking at a programming
example and dive into the script
let's look at the advantage of the
support vector machine we'll start with
high dimensional
input space or sometimes referred to as
the curse of dimensionality we looked at
earlier one dimension two dimension
three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
most algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space
one of the high dimensional space one
high dimensional space that we work on
is sparse document vectors
this is where we tokenize the words and
documents so we can run our machine
learning algorithms over them i've seen
ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at
and finally we have regularization
parameter the realization parameter or
lambda
is a parameter that helps figure out
whether we're going to have a bias or
overfitting of the data whether it's
going to be overfitted is very specific
instance or it's going to be biased to a
high or low value with the svm
it naturally avoids the overfitting and
bias problems that we see in many other
algorithms
these three advantages of the support
vector machine make it a very powerful
tool to add to your repertoire of
machine learning tools
now we did promise you a used case study
we're actually going to dive into some
python programming and so we're going to
go into a problem statement and start
off with the zoo
so in the zoo example we have family
members going to the zoo we have the
young child going dead
is that a group of crocodiles or
alligators well that's hard to
differentiate
and zoos are a great place to start
looking at science and understanding how
things work
especially as a young child and so we
can see the parents sitting here
thinking well what is the difference
between a crocodile and an alligator
well one crocodiles are larger in size
alligators are smaller in size snout
width the crocodiles have a narrow snout
and alligators have a wider snout
and of course in the modern day and age
the father is sitting here thinking how
can i turn this into a lesson for my son
and he goes let a support vector machine
segregate the two groups
i don't know if my dad ever told me that
but that would be funny now in this
example
we're not going to use actual
measurements and data we're just using
that for imagery
and that's very common in a lot of
machine learning algorithms and setting
them up but let's roll up our sleeves
and we'll talk about that more in just a
moment
as we break into our python script so
here we arrive
in our actual coding and i'm going to
move this into a
python editor in just a moment but let's
talk a little bit about what we're going
to cover
first we're going to cover in the code
the setup how to actually create our svm
and you're going to find that there's
only two lines of code that actually
create it and the rest of it is done
so quick and fast that it's all here in
the first page
and we'll show you what that looks like
as far as our data because we're going
to create some data i talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two
blobs and we'll go through that in just
a second and then the second part
is we're going to take this and we're
going to bump it up a notch we're going
to show you what it looks like behind
the scenes
but let's start with actually creating
our setup i like to use
the anaconda jupiter notebook because
it's very easy to use
but you can use any of your favorite
python editors or setups and go in there
but let's go ahead and switch over there
and see what that looks like
so here we are in the anaconda python
notebook or anaconda jupiter notebook
with python we're using
python 3. i believe this is 3.5 but it
should be work
in any of your 3x versions and you'd
have to look at the sklearn and make
sure if you're using a
2x version an earlier version let's go
and put our code in there
and one of the things i like about the
jupiter notebook is i go up to view
and i'm going to go ahead and toggle the
line numbers on to make it a little bit
easier
to talk about and we can even increase
the size because this is edited
in this case i'm using google chrome
explorer and that's how it opens up for
the editor
although anyone any like i said any
editor will work now the first step is
going to be our imports
and we're going to import four different
parts the first two i want you to look
at are line one and line two
are numpy as np and matplot library dot
pi plot as
plt now these are very standardized
imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python
we need that because part of the
platform we're using uses app for the
numpy array
and i'll talk about that in a minute so
you can understand why we want to use a
numpy array versus the standard python
array
and normally it's pretty standard setup
to use np for numpy
the map plot library is how we're going
to view our data so this says
you do need the np for the sk learn
module but the map plot library is
purely for our use for visualization
and so you really don't need that for
the svm but we're going to put it there
so you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like that's
really important at the end when you
finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at
and then finally we're gonna i'm gonna
jump one ahead to
line number four that's the
sklearn.datasets.samplesgenerator
import make blobs and i told you that we
were going to make up data
and this is a tool that's in the sk
learning to make up data i personally
don't want to go to the zoo
get in trouble for jumping over the
fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as i work on
measuring their snouts and width and
length instead we're just going to make
up some data
and that's what that make blobs is it's
a wonderful tool if you're ready to test
your
your setup and you're not sure about
what data you're going to put in there
you can create this blob and it makes it
real easy to use
and finally we have our actual svm the
sklearn import svm on line three
so that covers all our imports we're
going to create remember i used to make
blobs to create data
and we're going to create a capital x
and a lowercase y
equals make blobs in samples equals 40.
so we're going to make 40 lines of data
it's going to have two centers with a
random state equals 20. so each
each each group is going to have 20
different pieces of data in it
and the way that looks is that we'll
have under x um an x y
plane so i have two numbers under x and
y will be zero
one that's the two different centers so
we have yes or no in this case alligator
or crocodile that's what that represents
and then i told you that the actual sk
learner the svm is in two lines of code
and we see it right here with clf equals
svm
dot svc kernel equals linear and i set
sql to one
although in this example since we are
not regularizing the data
because we want to be very clear and
easy to see i went ahead you can set it
to a thousand a lot of times when you're
not doing that
but for this thing linear because it's a
very simple linear example
we only have the two dimensions and
it'll be a nice linear
hyperplane will be a nice linear line
instead of a full plane so we're not
dealing with a huge amount of data
and then all we have to do is do clf dot
fit
x comma y and that's it clf has been
created
and then we're going to go ahead and
display it and i'm going to talk about
this display here in just a second but
let me go ahead and run this code
and this is what we've done is we've
created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish
on the other side that's our two sets of
data they represent one represents
crocodiles and one represents alligators
and then we have our measurements in
this case we have like the
width and length of the snout and i did
say i was going to come up here and talk
just a little bit about
our plot and you'll see plt that's what
we imported we're going to do a scatter
plot that means we're just putting dots
on there
and then look at this notation i have
the capital x and then in brackets i
have a colon comma 0.
that's from numpy if you did that in a
regular array you'll get an
error in a python array you have to have
that in a numpy array
it turns out that our makeblobs returns
a numpy array
and this notation is great because what
it means is the first part
is the colon means we're going to do all
the rows that's all the data
in our blob we created under capital x
and then the second part has a comma
zero we're only going to take the first
value and then
if you notice we do the same thing but
we're going to take the second value
remember we always start with zero and
then one
so we have column zero and column one
and you can look
at this as our x y plots the first one
is the x plot and the second one is the
y plot so the first one is on the bottom
0 2 4 6 8 and 10 and then the
second one x of the 1 is the 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 going up the left hand side
s equals 30 is just the size of the dots
we can see them it says real tiny dots
and then the c map equals plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color
we're using two colors zero one and
that's why we get the nice blue
and the two different colors for the
alligator and the crocodile now you can
see here that we did this the actual
fit was done in two lines of code a lot
of times there'll be a third line where
we regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary
and it's also kind of nice because you
can actually see what's going on
and then if we wanted to we wanted to
actually run a prediction let's take a
look and see what that looks like
and to predict some new data and we'll
show this again
as we get towards the end of digging in
deep you can simply assign your new data
in this case i'm giving it a width and
length 3
4 and a width and length 5 6. and note
that i put the data as
a set of brackets and then i have the
brackets inside
and the reason i do that is because when
we're looking at data
it's designed to process a large amount
of data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time
and so in this case i'm processing two
lines and then i'm just going to print
and you'll see clf dot predict
new data so the clf and the dot predict
part
is going to give us an answer and let's
see what that looks like and you'll see
zero one so predicted the first one the
three four is going to be on
the one side and the five six is going
to be on the other side so one came out
as an
alligator and one came out as a
crocodile now that's pretty short
explanation
for the setup but really we want to dug
in and see what it's going on behind the
scenes
and let's see what that looks like so
the next step is to dig in deep
and find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
than we did actually generating the
original model
and you'll see here that we go through a
few steps and i'll move this over to our
editor in just a second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain why we redid
that and show you how not to redo that
and then we're going to go in there
and add in those lines we're going to
see what those lines look like and how
to set those up
and finally we're going to plot all that
on here and show it and you'll get a
nice graph
with the what we saw earlier when we
were going through the theory behind
this
where it shows the support vectors and
the hyperplane
and those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line
i want you to notice line 13 has plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here
and i'm going to paste that code in and
you'll see that the plot show has moved
down below
let's scroll up a little bit and if you
look at the top here of our new section
1 2 3 and 4 is the same code we had
before
and let's go back up here and take a
look at that we're going to fit the
values
on our svm and then we're going to plot
scatter it and then we're going to do a
plot
show so you should be asking why are we
redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here
re-running it and then coming down here
and then we wouldn't have to rerun these
first four lines of code
now in this it doesn't matter too much
and you'll see the plot show was down
here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out
our screen we want to move on to the
next setup so we can go ahead and just
skip the first four lines because we did
that before
and let's take a look at the ax equals
plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here
okay so this is how we display a nice
graph with our
results in our data ax is a very
standard node used variable when you
talk about plt
and it's just setting it to that axis
the last axis in the plt
it can get very confusing if you're
working with many different layers of
data on the same graph
and this makes it very easy to reference
the ax so this
reference is looking at the plt that we
created and we already mapped out our
two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is
we can find out the x limit and the y
limit simply with the
get x limit and get y limit commands
which is part of our metplot library
and then we're going to create a grid
and you'll see down here we have we've
set the variable xx equal to
np.line space x limit 0 x limit 1 comma
30
and we've done the same thing for the y
space and then we're going to go in here
and we create a mesh grid and this is a
numpy command
so we're back to our numbers python
let's go through what these numpy
commands mean
with the line space in the mesh grid
we've taken x
x small s x x equals np line space
and we have our x limit 0 and our x
limit 1
and we're going to create 30 points on
it and we're going to do the same thing
for the y-axis
now this has nothing to do with our
evaluation it's
all we're doing is we're creating a grid
of data
and so we're creating a set of points
between 0 and the x limit
we're creating 30 points and the same
thing with the y and then the mesh grid
loops those all together so it forms a
nice grit so if we were going to do this
say between the limit 0 and 10 and do 10
points
we would have a 0 0 1 1 0 1
0 2 zero three zero four to ten and so
on you can just imagine a point at each
corner one of those boxes
and the mesh grid combines them all so
we take the y y and the x x we created
and creates the full grid
and we've set that grid into the y y
coordinates and the x
x coordinates now remember we're working
with numbi and python
we like to separate those we like to
have instead of it being
x comma 1 you know x comma y
and then x 2 comma y 2 and this in the
next set of data it would
be a column of x's and a column of y's
and that's what we have here is we have
a column of y's and we put it as a
capital y y
and a column of x's capital x x with all
those different points being listed
and finally we get down to the numpy v
stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into
one array x y array now that we've
created the stack of data points
we're going to do something interesting
here we're going to create a value z
and the z equals the clf that's our
that's our support vector machine we
created and we've already trained
and we have a dot decision function
we're going to put the x
y in there so here we have all this data
we're going to put that x
y in there that data and we're going to
reshape it and you'll see that we have
the x
x dot shape in here this literally takes
the xx
resets it up connected to the y and the
z
value lets us know whether it is the
left hand side is going to generate
three different values the z value does
and it'll tell us whether that data is a
support vector to the left
the hyperplane in the middle or the
support vector to the right
so it generates three different values
for each of those points
and those points have been reshaped so
they're right on a line on those three
different lines
so we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas
and we've reshaped it and we've just
taken 30 points in each direction
if you do the math you have 30 times 30
so that's 900 points of data and we
separate it between the three lines and
reshaped it to fit those three lines
we can then go back to our map plot
library we've created the ax
and we're going to create a contour and
you'll see here we have contour capital
xx capital yy
these have been reshaped to fit those
lines z is the labels
so now we have the three different
points with the labels in there and we
can set the colors equals k
and i told you we had three different
labels but we have three
levels of data the alphas just makes it
kind of see-through so it's only 0.5 of
the value in there so when we graph it
the data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go and finally the
line styles this is where we set
the two support vectors to be dash dash
lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does
and then finally we take our ax dot
scatter we're going to go ahead and plot
the support vectors but we've programmed
it in there so that they look nice like
the dash dash line and the dashed line
on that grid and you can see here when
we do the clf
dot support vectors we are looking at
column 0 and column 1
and then again we have the s equals 100
so we're going to make them larger
and the line width equals 1 face colors
equals none let's take a look and see
what that looks like when we show it
and you can see we get down to our end
result it creates a really nice graph
we have our two support vectors and
dashed lines
and they have the near data so you can
see those two points or in this case the
four points where those lines
nicely cleave the data and then you have
your hyper plane down the middle
which is as far from the two different
points as possible creating the maximum
distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout
and we've easily separated the two
groups of crocodile and alligator
congratulations you've done it we've
made it course these are pretend
data for our crocodiles and alligators
but this hands-on example will help you
to encounter any support vector machine
projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in-depth
what is k-means clustering k-means
clustering
is an unsupervised learning algorithm
in this case you don't have labeled data
unlike in supervised learning so you
have a set of data
and you want to group them and as the
name suggests you want to
put them into clusters which means
objects that are similar in nature
similar in characteristics need to be
put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about
the term k is basically is a number
so we need to tell the system how many
clusters we need to perform
so if k is equal to two there will be
two clusters if k is equal to three
three clusters and so on and so forth
that's what the k stands for
and of course there is a way of finding
out what is the best
or optimum value of k for a given data
we will look at that
so that is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios
but let's take an example of cricket the
game of cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country
or all over the world and this data has
information about the runs scored
by the people ordered by the player and
the wickets
taken by the player and based on this
information
we need to cluster this data into two
clusters
batsman and bowlers so this is an
interesting example
let's see how we can perform this so we
have
the data which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the
wickets so the bowlers basically take
wickets and the batsmen
score runs there will be of course a few
bowlers who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will
who would have taken a few wickets but
with this information we want to
cluster those players into batsmen and
bowlers
so how does this work let's say this is
how the data
is so there are information there is
information
on the y-axis about the run scored
and on the x-axis about the wickets
taken by the players
so if we do a quick plot this is how it
would look
and when we do the clustering
we need to have the clusters like shown
in the third diagram rtms we need to
have a cluster which consists of
people who have scored high runs which
is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken
a lot of wickets which is typically the
bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering
we will have here that means k is equal
to 2 and we will have
two clusters which is batsman and
bowlers so how does this work
the way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering
is the allocation of two centroids
randomly
so two points are assigned as
so-called centroids so in this case
we want two clusters which means k is
equal to
two so two points have been randomly
assigned as centroids keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not
initially they are not really the
centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set
but in this case when it starts off it's
not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them
one point closer to these data points
and another closer to these data points
they can be assigned randomly anywhere
okay so that's the first step the next
step is to determine the distance of
each of the data points from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point
and find the distance from this centroid
and
the distance from this center right this
point is taken
and the distance is found from this
centroid and the center and so on and so
forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from
both the centroids and then whichever
distance is less
that point is assigned to that centroid
so for example in this case
visually it is very obvious that all
these
data points are assigned to this
centroid and all these data points are
assigned to this centroid
and that's what is represented here in
blue color and in this
yellow color the next step is to
actually
determine the central point or the
actual
centroid for these two clusters so we
have this one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the
central position of this data set
central position of this data set so
that is what
needs to be determined as the next step
so the central point of the actual
centroid is determined
and the original randomly allocated
centroid
is repositioned to the actual centroid
of these
new clusters and this process is
actually repeated now what might happen
is some of these points may get
reallocated in our example that is not
happening probably
but it may so happen that the distance
is found between
each of these data points once again
with these centroids
and if there is if it is required some
points may be reallocated we will see
that in a later example
but for now we will keep it simple so
this process is continued
till the centroid repositioning stops
and that is our final cluster
so this is our so after iteration we
come
to this position this situation where
the centroid doesn't need any more
repositioning
and that means our algorithm has
converged convergence has occurred and
we have the cluster
two clusters we have the clusters with a
centroid
so this process is repeated
the process of calculating the distance
and repositioning
the centroid is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that
the algorithm has converged and we have
the final
cluster with the data points and the
centroids
so this is what you're going to learn
from this session we will talk about the
types of clustering what is k-means
clustering
application of k-means clustering
k-means clustering is
done using distance measure so we will
talk about the common distance measures
and then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works
and go into the details of k-means
clustering algorithm
and then we will end with a demo and a
use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering
there are primarily two categories of
clustering hierarchical clustering
and then partitional clustering and each
of these categories are further
subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and
k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at
what each of these types of clustering
are in hierarchical clustering
the clusters have a tree-like structure
and hierarchical clustering is further
divided into
agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach
we begin with each element as a separate
cluster and merge them into successively
larger clusters so for example we have
abcdef
we start by combining b and c from one
cluster d e and e
form one more then we combine d e and f
one more bigger cluster and then
add b c to that and then finally a to it
compared to that
divisive clustering or divisive
clustering
is a top-down approach we begin with the
whole set and proceed to divide it into
successively smaller clusters so we have
abcdef
we first take that as a single cluster
and then break it down
into a b c d e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into
two subtypes k means clustering and
fuzzy c means
in k means clustering the objects are
divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k
that's where the k comes from so if we
say k is equal to 2
the objects are divided into two
clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics
are compared and all objects having
similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how k
means clustering is done
we will see it in more detail as we move
forward and fuzzy c means is very
similar
to k-means in the sense that it clubs
objects that have similar
characteristics together but
while in k-means clustering two objects
cannot belong to
or any object a single object cannot
belong to two different
clusters in c means objects can belong
to more than one cluster so that is the
primary difference between
k-mains and fuzzy c means so what are
some of the applications
of k-means clustering k-means clustering
is used in a variety
of examples or variety of business cases
in real life
starting from academic performance
diagnostic systems
search engines and wireless sensor
networks and many more so let us take a
little
deeper look at each of these examples
academic performance so
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b
c and so on clustering forms a backbone
of search engines
when a search is performed the search
results need to be grouped together
the search engines very often use
clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks
the clustering algorithm plays the role
of finding the cluster
heads which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k means clustering
uses distance measure so let's take a
look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of
clustering in this video we will focus
on
k-means clustering so distance measure
tells how similar some objects
are so the similarity is measured using
what is known as distance measure and
what are the various types of distance
measures there is euclidean distance
there is manhattan distance then we have
squared euclidean distance measure
and cosine distance measure these are
some of the distance measures supported
by
k-means clustering let's take a look at
each of these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points
so we have learnt in high school how to
find the distance between two points
this is a little sophisticated formula
for that
but we know a simpler one is square root
of
y2 minus y1 whole square plus x2 minus
x1 whole square so this is an extension
of that
formula so that is the euclidean
distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure
it's nothing but the square of the
euclidean distance as the name suggests
so instead of taking the square root
we leave the square as it is and then we
have
manhattan distance measure in case of
manhattan distance
it is the sum of the distances
across the x-axis and the y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure
in this case we take the angle between
the two vectors
formed by joining the points from the
origin so that is the cosine distance
measure okay so that was a quick
overview about the various distance
measures
that are supported by k-means now let's
go and check how
exactly k-means clustering works
okay so this is how k-means clustering
works this is like a flowchart
of the whole process there is a starting
point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are
a couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then
as we progress we keep changing until we
get the best clusters
or there is a technique called elbow
technique
whereby we can determine the value of k
what should be the best value of k how
many clusters should be formed
so once we have the value of k we
specify that
and then the system will assign that
many
centroids so it picks randomly that to
start with
randomly that many points that are
considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of
each of the data points from these
centroids and assigns those points to
the corresponding
centroid from which the distance is
minimum so each data point
will be assigned to the centroid which
is closest
to it and thereby we have k number of
initial clusters however this is not the
final clusters
the next step it does is for the
new groups for the clusters that have
been
formed it calculates the mean position
thereby calculates the new centroid
position
the position of the centroid moves
compared to the randomly allocated one
so it's an iterative process once again
the distance of each point is measured
from this new centroid point
and if required the data points are
reallocated to the new centroids
and the mean position or the new
centroid is calculated once again
if the centroid moves then the iteration
continues
which means the convergence has not
happened the clustering has not
converged so
as long as there is a movement of the
centroid
this iteration keeps happening but once
the centroid stops moving which means
that the cluster
has converged or the clustering process
has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have
the final position of the centroid and
the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest
centroid i know it's a little difficult
to understand from this
simple flowchart so let's do a little
bit of
visualization and see if we can explain
it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop
so let's say we have a data set for a
grocery shop
and now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across
so how do we find the optimum number of
clusters
there is a technique called the elbow
method so when
these clusters are formed there is a
parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower
this value is the better the cluster is
that means all these points are very
close to each other
so we use this within sum of squares
as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set
so we create clusters or we let the
system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10 10 clusters and for each
value of k the within ss is
measured and the value of k which has
the least
amount of within ss or wss
that is taken as the optimum value
of k so this is the diagrammatic
representation
so we have on the y axis the within sum
of squares or wss
and on the x axis we have the number of
clusters so
as you can imagine if you have k is
equal to 1 which means
all the data points are in a single
cluster the within s value will be very
high
because they are probably scattered all
over the moment you split it into
two there will be a drastic fall in the
within
ss value that's what is represented here
but then as the value of k increases the
decrease the rate of decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably
the rate of decrease will not be high so
that gives us an idea so from here
we get an idea for example the optimum
value of
k should be either 2 or 3 or at the most
4 but beyond that increasing the number
of clusters
is not dramatically changing the value
in wss because that
pretty much gets stabilized okay now
that we have
got the value of k and let's assume that
these are our delivery points
the next step is basically to assign
two centroids randomly so let's say c1
and c2
are the centroids assigned randomly now
the distance of
each location from the centroid
is measured and each point is assigned
to the centroid which is closest to it
so for example these points are very
obvious that these are
closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1
and these points or locations which are
close to c2 will be assigned to c2
and then so this is the how the initial
grouping is done
this is part of c1 and this is part of
c2
then the next step is to calculate the
actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they
have been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was
the data points which are closest to
them have been assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned
or repositioned there same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position
and c1 is in this new position once
again
the distance of each of the data points
is calculated
from these centroids now remember it's
not necessary that the distance
still remains the or each of these data
points still remain in the same group
by recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated
like so you see this so this point
earlier was closer to c2 because c2 was
here
but after recalculating repositioning
it is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2
so this is the new grouping so some
points will be reassigned
and again the centroid will be
calculated
and if the centroid doesn't change so
that is the repetitive process iterative
process
and if the centroid doesn't change once
the centroid stops changing
that means the algorithm has converged
and this is our final cluster with this
as the centroid
c1 and c2 as the centroids these data
points as a part of each cluster
so i hope this helps in understanding
the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at the k-means
clustering algorithm let's say we have
x1
x2 x3 and number of points as our inputs
and we want to split this into k
clusters
or we want to create k clusters so the
first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point
but they are just called centroids and
we calculate the distance of each and
every
input point from each of the centroids
so the distance of x1 from
c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances we
calculate
and then find out which distance is the
lowest
and assign x1 to that particular random
centroid
repeat that process for x2 calculate its
distance
from each of the centroids c1 c2 c3 up
to ck
and find which is the lowest distance
and assign x2 to that particular center
same with x3 and so on so that is the
first
round of assignment that is done now
we have k groups because there are
we have assigned the value of k so there
are k
centroids and so there are k
groups all these inputs have been split
into k
groups however remember we picked the
centroids randomly so they are not
real centroids so now what we have to do
we have to calculate the
actual centroids for each of these
groups
which is like the mean position which
means that the position of the randomly
selected
centroids will now change and they will
be the mean positions of these newly
formed
k groups and once that is done
we once again repeat this process of
calculating the distance right so this
is what we are doing as a part of step
four
we repeat step two and three so we
again calculate the distance of x one
from the centroid c one c two
c three and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and
assign x2 to that centroid and so on in
this process there may be
some reassignment x1 pro was probably
assigned to cluster c2
and after doing this calculation maybe
now x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen
so we repeat the steps two and three
till the position of the centroids don't
change or stop changing and that's when
we have
convergence so let's take a detailed
look at
each of these steps so we randomly pick
k
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not
initially they are not really the
centroids so we
let us name them c1 c2 up to ck and then
step two
we assign each data point to the closest
center so what we do we calculate the
distance of
each x value from each
c value so the distance between x1
c1 distance between x1 c2
x1 c3 and then we find which is the
lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign
x1 to that particular centroid then we
go next to
x2 find the distance of x2 from c1 x2
from c2
x2 from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on
so that is step number two in step
number three
we now find the actual centroid for each
group so what has happened
as a part of step number two we now have
all the points all the data points
grouped into
k groups because we we wanted to create
k
clusters right so we have k groups each
one may be having
a certain number of input values and
they need not be equally
distributed by the way based on the
distance we will have
k groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups
right we assigned them randomly so now
in step 3 we actually calculate the
centroid of each group
which means the original point which we
thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups
okay and we again calculate the distance
so we go back to step
two which is what we calculate again the
distance of each of these points from
the newly positioned centroids and if
required
we reassign these points to the
new centroids so as i said earlier
there may be a reallocation so we now
have a new set
or a new group we still have k groups
but
the number of items and the actual
assignment
may be different from what was in step
two here okay so that might change
then we perform step three once again to
find the new centroid
of this new group so we have again a new
set of
clusters new centroids and new
assignments
we repeat this step 2 again once again
we find
and then it is possible that after
iterating through
three or four or five times the centroid
will stop
moving in the sense that when you
calculate the new value of the centroid
that will be same as the original value
or there will be
very marginal change so that is when we
say
convergence has occurred and that is our
final cluster that's the formation of
the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will
actually see some live demos in python
notebook using pattern notebook
but before that let's find out what's
the problem that we are trying to
solve the problem statement is let's say
walmart
wants to open a chain of stores across
the state of florida
and it wants to find the optimal
store locations now the issue here is
if they open too many stores close to
each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce
giant they already have the addresses
of their customers in their database so
they can
actually use this information or this
data
and use k-means clustering to find the
optimal
location now before we go into the
python notebook and show you the live
code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary
of the code in the slides and then we
will go into the
python notebook so in this block
we are basically importing all the
required libraries
like numpy matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say
the addresses for simplicity's sake we
will just take them
as some data points then the next thing
we do
is quickly do a scatter plot to see how
they
are related to each other with respect
to each other
so in the scatter plot we see that there
are a few
distinct groups already being formed so
you can actually get an idea about
how the cluster would look and how many
clusters what is the optimal
number of clusters and then starts the
actual
k-means clustering process so we will
assign each of these points to the
centroids and then check whether they
are
the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and
assign each of the points data points to
the centroids and then go through this
iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally
we get an output like this so we have
four distinct clusters
and which is if we can say that
this is how the population is probably
distributed across
florida state and the centroids
are like the location where the store
should be
the optimum location where the store
should be
so that's the way we determine
the best locations for the store and
that's how we can help walmart
find the best locations for their stores
in florida
so now let's take this into python
notebook let's see how this looks when
we are running
running the code live all right so this
is the code for
k-means clustering in jupyter notebook
we have a few examples here which we
will
demonstrate how k-means clustering is
used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well
okay so let's get started okay so this
block
is basically importing the various
libraries that are required like
matplotlib
and numpy and so on and so forth which
would be used
as a part of the code then we are going
and
creating blobs which are similar to
clusters now this is a very neat feature
which is available in
scikit-learn make blobs is a nice
feature
which creates clusters of data sets so
that's a
wonderful functionality that is readily
available for us to create some
test data kind of thing okay so that's
exactly what we are doing here we are
using
make blobs and we can specify how many
clusters we want so centers we are
mentioning here
so it will go ahead and so we just
mentioned four so it will go ahead and
create
some test data for us and this is how it
looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four
distinct classes or clusters
in this data set and that is what
make blobs actually provides
now from here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so
we really don't have to implement
k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available
you just need to feed the data and we'll
create the clusters
so this is the code for that we import k
means and then we create an instance of
k means
and we specify the value of k this n
underscore clusters
is the value of k remember k means in k
means k
is basically the number of clusters that
you want to create
and it is a integer value so this is
where we are specifying that so we have
k is equal to
4 and so that instance is created
we take that instance and as with any
other
machine learning functionality fit is
what we use the function
or the method rather fit is what we use
to train the model here there is no real
training
kind of thing but that's the call okay
so we are calling fit
and what we are doing here we are just
passing the data so x has these values
the data that has been created right so
that is what we are
passing here and this will
go ahead and create the clusters
and then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which uh basically assigns for each of
these
observations which cluster where it
belongs to
all right so it will name the clusters
maybe this is cluster one this is two
three and so on or i will actually start
from zero
cluster zero one two and three maybe and
then
for each of the observations it will
assign based on which cluster it belongs
to
it will assign a value so that is stored
in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation
so this is the cluster number assigned
for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so
we have how many about i think 300
samples right so all the 300 samples
there are 300 values here
each of them the cluster number is given
and the cluster number
goes from 0 to 3. so there are four
clusters so the numbers go
from zero one two three so
that's what is seen here okay now so
this was a quick example of generating
some
dummy data and then clustering that okay
and this can be applied if you have
proper data you can just load it up into
x for example here and then run the game
so this
is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example
so you basically create an instance and
you mentioned how many
clusters you want by specifying this
parameter and underscore clusters
and that is also the value of k and then
pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code
is the implementation of a k-means now
this
is kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means
algorithm so we will just walk you
through i will walk you through the code
uh at each step what it is doing and
then we will see a couple of more
examples of how k-means
clustering can be used in maybe some
real life examples real-life use cases
all right so in this case here what we
are doing is basically
implementing k-means clustering
and there is a function or a library
calculates for a given two pairs of
points
it will calculate the the distance
between them
and see which one is the closest and so
on so this is like this is pretty much
like what k means does
right so it calculates the distance of
each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest
this particular data point is assigned
to that centroid so that is
basically available as a standard
function and we will be using that here
so as explained in the slides the first
step that
is done in case of k-means clustering
is to randomly assign some
centroids so as a first step we randomly
allocate
a couple of centroids which we call here
we are calling as centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance
argument for each of the points we find
out which one which center or which
randomly selected centroid is the
closest
and accordingly we assign that data
or the data point to that particular
centroid
or cluster and once that is done for all
the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position
which is the center position right so we
calculate the
new centroid and then we check if the
new centroid
is the coordinates or the position is
the same
as the previous centroid the positions
we will compare
and if it is the same that means
the process has converged so remember we
do this process still the centroids
or the centroid doesn't move anymore
right so the centroid gets relocated
each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it
doesn't change anymore the position of
the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop
it only breaks when the centers are the
same the new center and the old center
positions are the same and once that is
done we return the centers and the
labels now of course as explained this
is
not a very sophisticated and advanced
implementation
very basic implementation because one of
the flaws in this is that sometimes what
happens is
the centroid the position will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case
also with that is actually convergence
right so for example the change is
0.0001
we can consider that as convergence
otherwise what will happen is this will
either take forever
or it will be never ending so that's a
small flaw here so that is something
additional checks may have to be added
here but again as mentioned
this is not the most sophisticated
implementation
uh this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means clustering
okay so if we execute this code this is
what we get as the output so
this is the definition of this
particular function
and then we call that find underscore
clusters and we pass our data
x and the number of clusters which is
four and if we
run that and plot it this is the output
that we get
so this is of course each cluster is
represented by a different
color so we have a cluster in green
color yellow color and so on and so
forth
and these big points here these are the
centroids this is the final position of
the centroids and as you can see
visually also
this appears like a kind of a center of
all these points here right similarly
this is like the center of
all these points here and so on so this
is the
example or this is an example of an
implementation
of k means clustering and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of
how k-means clustering is used
in maybe some real-life scenarios or use
cases
in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform
color compression we will take a couple
of images
so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress
the colors this is a common situation in
image processing when you have an image
with
millions of colors but then you cannot
render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used
so before again we go into the python
notebook
let's take a look at quickly the the
code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the
image and then we will
flatten it so the reshaping is basically
we have the image information is stored
in the form of pixels and if the image
is like for example
427 by 640 and it has three colors
so that's the overall dimension of the
of the initial image we just reshape it
and then feed this to our
algorithm and this will then create
clusters
of only 16 clusters so this this
colors there are millions of colors and
now we need to
bring it down to 16 colors so we use k
is equal to 16
and this is how when we visualize this
is how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors
and we just sub compress it to
16 colors so this is how it would look
when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks
and after compression to 16 colors
this is how the new image looks as you
can see there is
not a lot of information that has been
lost though the image quality
is definitely reduced a little bit
so this is an example which we are going
to now
see in python notebook let's go into the
python node
and once again as always we will import
some libraries
and load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let me
load that and this is how it looks this
is the original image which has i think
16 million
colors and this is the shape of this
image which is basically what is the
shape is nothing but the overall size
right so this is 427 pixel
by 640 pixel and then there are three
layers which is this three basically is
for rgb which is red green blue
so color image will have that right so
that is the shape
of this now what we need to do is data
let's take a look at how data is looking
so let me just
create a new cell and show you what is
in data basically we have captured this
information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so let's take a look at china
what are the values
in china and if we see here this is how
the data is stored
this is nothing but the pixel values
okay so this is like a matrix
and each one has about for this 427 by
640
pixels all right so this is how it looks
now the issue here is these values are
large the numbers are a large so we need
to normalize them to
between zero and one right so that's why
we will basically
create one more variable which is data
which will contain
the values between 0 and 1. and the way
to do that is divide by
255 so we divide china by 255
and we get the new values in data so
let's just run this
piece of code and this is the shape so
we now
have also yeah what we have done is we
changed using reshape
we converted into the three-dimensional
into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert uh probably
a cell here and take a look at how data
is looking all right so this is how data
is looking and now you see
this is the values are between 0 and 1
right so if you
earlier noticed in case of china the
values were large numbers
now everything is between 0 and 1. this
is one of the things we
need to do all right so after that the
next thing that we
need to do is to visualize this and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points
and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this and
so this is how the original the color
the pixel distribution is
these are two plots one is red against
green and another is red against
blue and this is the original
distribution of the color
so then what we will do is we will use
k-means clustering to
create just 16 clusters for the various
colors
and then apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors
using regular k-means may be a little
time-consuming so there is another
version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes
in the overall concept remains the same
but this basically
processes it in smaller batches that's
the only thing
okay so the results will pretty much be
the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code
and also visualize this so that we can
see that there are
this is how the 16 colors would look
so this is red against green and this is
red against
blue there is quite a bit of similarity
between this original
color schema and the new one right so it
doesn't look
very very completely different or
anything like that now
we apply this the newly created colors
to the image and we can take a look uh
how this is
looking now we can compare both the
images so this is our original image
and this is our new image so as you can
see
there is not a lot of information that
has been
lost it pretty much looks like the
original image
yes we can see that for example here
there is a little bit
it appears a little dullish compared to
this one
right because we kind of took off some
of the finer
details of the color but overall
the high level information has been
maintained at the same time
the main advantage is that now this can
be this is an image which can be
rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated
now let's take one more example with a
different image
in the second example we will take an
image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process
this is a high definition color image
with millions of colors and also
three dimensional now we will reduce
that to
16 colors using k means clustering
and we do the same process like before
we reshape it and then we cluster the
colors
to 16 and then we render the
image once again and we will see that
the color the quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here
this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because
there are some devices which may not be
able to handle
this kind of high density images so
let's
run this chord in python notebook all
right so
let's apply the same technique for
another picture which is
uh even more intricate and has
probably much complicated color schema
so this is the image now once again we
can take a look
at the shape which is 427 by 640 by
3 and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this
compared to the flower image so we have
some new values here
and we will also bring this as you can
see the numbers are much
big so we will much bigger so we will
now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and
do that and reshape it okay
so we get a two-dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
does the 16 colors and this is basically
how it would look
16 million colors and now we can
create the clusters out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how
the distribution of the pixels would
look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and apply this
and visualize how it is looking for
with the new just the 16 color so once
again
as you can see this looks much richer
in color but at the same time and this
probably doesn't have as we can see it
doesn't look
as rich as this one but nevertheless the
information is not lost the shape and
all that stuff
and this can be also rendered on a
slightly
a device which is probably not that
sophisticated
okay so that's pretty much it so we have
seen two examples of how
color compression can be done using
k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples
of how to implement k-means the code to
roughly how to implement
k-means clustering and we use some
sample data using blob to
just execute the k-means clustering
dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables
in a data set and so you can see on the
table on the right
shows the orders made at an automobile
parts retailer
the retailer sells different automobile
parts from different companies
and you can see we have company b-packs
isomax and they have the item the tire
the axle
an order id a price number and a
quantity
in order to predict the future cells we
find out
that using correlation analysis that we
just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes from
five to three and clearly we don't
really care about the part number
i don't think the part number would have
an effect on how many tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those
and we just have the item the tire the
price and the quantity
one of the things you should be taking
away from this is in the scheme of
things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data
and we're pre-processing the data what
can we do to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction well number
one less dimensions for a given data set
means less computation or training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models
uh and you're re-running them over and
over again and even if you have seven
gigabytes
of data that can start taking days to go
through all those different models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set redundancy is removed after
removing similar entries from the data
set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data
it might give them a higher weight than
they would if it was just once we want
to get rid of that redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in space required to store
the data is reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it
why would we want to store two whole
extra columns when we added into that
pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots
this is my favorite part very important
you're in your shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing uh
leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four it
makes data easy for plotting
you have a better interpretation when
we're looking at it principle component
analysis
so what is it uh principal component
analysis is a technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets
increasing interpretability but at the
same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the pca
we reduce the variables we end up with
the reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because
if you look at the end result we have
the different colors all lined up
so what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from
so if we come up here we look at this we
say okay this is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling
a lot of the people in the class are
missing so we have a huge amount off to
the right of blank space
maybe from up here again we have the
back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from
might be this bottom left angle you look
at it you say hey that makes sense it's
a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data it's not you really can't do it by
what you think is going to be the best
we need to have some kind of
mathematical
formula so it's consistent and so it
makes sense in the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen uh in
the petals and they have width and they
have length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal
we could just as easily do the
width to length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
a very simplified example on my iris
pedal example when we look at the
similarity
in pca we find the best picture or
projection
of the data points and so we look down
at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there we can see
these data points based on in this case
just two variables now keep in mind
we're usually talking about 36
40 variables almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27
different variables they're looking at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the xy
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this
x y this time from a different direction
here for our e's we can consider that we
get two principal components
namely pc1 and pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2
and that's what they're coming up with
what is going to give us the best look
for these data points when we combine
them and we're looking at them from just
a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much
more difficult therefore we accept the
pc1 and not the pc2 as the data points
are more spaced
now obviously the back-end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable this gives you an
idea though that when we're talking
about this we're talking about the
perspective
which would help in understanding how
pca
analysis works we want to go ahead and
do is dive into the important
terminologies
under pca and important terminologies
are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation
and they're not taking the time to
reduce it to something that the
average person shareholders can
understand you might hear them refer to
it as the different views what view are
we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
and we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions um
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27
different features minimal and then you
have the principal component
new variables that are constructed as
linear combinations or mixtures of the
initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination
if you remember my flower example it
would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in
the ratio instead which is a single
number versus two separate numbers
projections the perpendicular distance
between the principal component
and the data points and that goes to
that line
we had earlier it's that right angle
line of where those point
how those points fall onto the line
important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense you're not
going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through
principal components are orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2 we want to make sure
that pc1 does not equal pc2
we don't want to have the same two
principal points
when we do two points the priority of
principal components
decreases as their numbers increase
this is important to understand if
you're going to
create uh one principle
component everything is summarized into
that one component
as we go to two components the priority
how much it holds value decreases as we
go down so if you have five different
points
each one of those points is going to
have less value than just the one point
which has everything summarized in it
how pca works i said there was more in
the back end we talked about the math
this is what we're talking about is how
does it actually work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca
performs the following operations in
order to evaluate the principal
components for a given data set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance
matrix computation and we use that to
generate our i gene vectors and i gene
values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene
vector is like a translation for
moving the data from x equals one to x
equals two or whatever we're altering it
and the ign value is the final value
that we generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step is to standardize
the range of the attributes so that each
one of them
lie within similar boundaries this
process
involves removal of the mean from the
variable values and scaling the data
with respect to the standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean
over the standard deviation the
covariance matrix
computation covariance matrix is used to
express the correlation between
any two or more attributes in
multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
tribute values
the variance is denoted by var and the
covariance is denoted by
cove on the right we can see the
covariance matrix for two attributes and
their values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this
so you can see what we're talking about
and what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x
to y on the right side we can see the
covariance
table for more than two attributes in a
multi-dimensional data set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature
two features we're usually looking at 25
30 features going on and so if we do
a setup like this we should see all
those different features as the
different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related
positive covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is directly
proportional to the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is
inversely proportional to the other
variable that is always important to
note whenever we're doing any of these
matrixes that we're going to be looking
at that positive and negative whether
it's inverted or not
and then we have the i gene values and
the i gene vectors
i gene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables
which further lead to the construction
of the principal components
igen vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
i gene values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the i gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data
so we're going to change uh the vector b
to the b prime as denoted on the chart
and so we have like multiple variables
how do we calculate
that new variable and then we have
feature vectors
feature vectors is simply a matrix that
has igen vectors of the components that
we decide to keep as the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps
this becomes really important as we
start
looking at the back end of this and
we'll do this in the
demo but one of the more important steps
to understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k
columns or variables now for this matrix
we would construct a variable space with
as many dimensions as
the variable but for our simplicity
let's consider this three dimensions for
now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k variable space such
that the rows in the data table form a
swarm of points
in this space now we find the mean of
all the observations and then place it
along the data points on the plot
the first principal component is a line
that best accounts for the shape of the
point swarm
it represents the maximum variance
direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1
this value is known as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set
thus a second principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second
largest source of variation in the data
while being orthogonal to
pc1 pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example i believe there's even
like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use
especially with the neural networks are
stable in 3 6.
then we open up our jupiter i'm in
chrome
and we go ahead and create a new python
three
and for ease of use uh our team in the
back was nice enough to put this
together for me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries the first thing i like to do
whenever i'm looking at
any new setup well you know what let's
do let's do the libraries first
we're going to do our basic libraries
which is matplot library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
our data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the plot that actually sits on matplot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook map plot
library in line
the newer version actually doesn't
require that but i put it in there
either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the
data and in this case we're going to
pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
and one of the reasons the cancer data
set is it has like 36 35 different
features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set
is we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so what we're looking for in all this
is um well let's take a look at the
description let's go in here and pull up
the description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain
we want to focus on our pca setup
what's important is you start looking at
what the different attributes are what
they mean
if you were in the medical field you'd
want to note all these different things
whether what they're measuring where
it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different measurements they're taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data
in this case our target and if you dig
deep enough to the target
let's actually do this let's go ahead
and print target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target names
run that yeah
so the target name is is it malignant or
is it b9
um so in other words is this a dangerous
growth or is it something we don't have
to worry about that's the bottom line
with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data
and you know let me go up a just a notch
here for easy of reading
sorry to get that just right that's all
you have to do
uh so let's go ahead and look at our
data uh our we're going to use our
pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data
columns equals cancer feature equals
feature names so remember up here we
already loaded the
the names up of our of the features in
there what is going to come out of this
let me just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head and you can see
here we have the mean radius the mean
texture
mean perimeter i don't know about you
this is a wonderful data set if you're
playing with it
because like many of the data that cut
most the data that comes in
half the time we don't even know we're
looking at we're just handed a bunch of
stuff
as a data scientist going what the heck
is this and so this is a good place to
start because this has
a number of different features in there
we have no idea what these feature means
or where they come from
we want to just look at the data and
figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it
as we've noticed before is difficult to
visualize high dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components
and visualize the data this new
two-dimensional space
with a single scatter plot before we do
this we need to go ahead and scale our
data
now i haven't run this to see if you
really have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any
modeling even if it's pre-modeling as
we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization
it's already going to scale it when we
do the means and deviation inside the
pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit
learn uses very similar process to other
pre-processing functions that come with
scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method
then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction
by calling transform we can also specify
how many components we want to keep when
creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead let me
go and run
this code uh so the code for this
is from sklearn decomposition
import pca pca equals pca
in components equals two and that's
really important
to note that because we're only going to
want to look at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody
else if you're showing this to the
shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the
scaled data that we generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals 2.
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different uh
setups you have on there probably the
biggest one to look at would be
um well the biggest one is your
components how many components do you
want
uh which you have to put in there pretty
much and then you also might look at the
svd solver it's on auto right now but
you can override that and do different
things with it
it does a pretty good job as it is
and if we go down all the way down to
there we go to our methods if you notice
we have
fit we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not
used for prediction uh it's used to look
at the data again we're in the described
setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it we've already looked at
our minimum maximum we've already looked
at what's in each quarter
we've done a full description of the
data this is part of describing
the data that's the biggest thing i take
away when i come
zooming in here and of course they have
examples of it down here if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full randomize there's different things
it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform
scaled data so there we go there's our
first transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us
what's going on here we've taken 30
features
i think i said 36 or something like that
but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
uh we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows not data sets we still
have 569 rows of data
but instead of computing 30 features
we're now only doing our model on
two features
so let's go ahead and plot these and
take a look and see what's going
on and
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here
here's our scatter plot xpca
x underscore pca of uh of one
these are two different perceptions
we're using
uh and then you'll see right here c for
color
cancer equals target and so remember we
have zero
we have one and if i remember correctly
zero was malignant one was b9
uh so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be
one and then we're going to use the
plasma map just kind of telling you what
color it is
add some labels first principle
component second principal component
and we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see here
instead of having a chart one of those
heat maps with 30
different columns in it we can look at
this and say hey this one actually did a
pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when i'm looking at
this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign and we
have a huge
area it's still clumped together more
spread out where it's going to be
malignant or i think i had that
backwards and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something in
this particular case
cancer we would try to separate i would
be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result on it
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently versus going in
and saying just cutting into the
can into the cancer so the body absorbs
it and it dissipates
versus uh actively going in there
removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things
that's a big difference you know as far
as what's going to happen
here and that middle line where the
overlap is going to be huge
that's domain specific going back to the
data
we can see here clearly by using these
two components we can easily separate
these two classes so the next step is
what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction
comes the cost of not being able to
easily understand what these components
represent
i don't know what principle component
one licks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features
the components themselves are stored as
an attribute of the filtered pca object
and so we talk
look at that we can go ahead and do uh
look at the pca components this is in
our model we built
we've trained it we can run that and you
can see here's the actual components
uh it's the two components have each
have their own array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores they're using
and these actually give weight to what
features
are doing what so in this numpy matrix
array each row represents a principal
component and each column
relates back to the original features
what's really neat about this
is we can now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map and start
seeing
uh what this means and so let me go
ahead and just
put this down up there to get it down
here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame and we do our pca
components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy and we're
dumping it into a data frame what's
needed about a data frame is when we get
to seaborn
it will pull that data frame apart and
and set it up for us when we want and so
we're just going to do the cn the
seaborn heat map of our data frame
composition and we'll use the plasma
coloring
and it creates a nice little color graph
here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right we have a scale so we can
see we have the dark colors all the way
to
the really light colors which are what's
really shining there this is like the
primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map and the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here
and we might notice that the mean radius
look how on the bottom of the map it is
um
on some of this uh so you have some
interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to a post
scribe you can also use this to try to
guess as what these things mean and what
you want to change to get a better
result
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more who is a data science
engineer are you a data science engineer
or are you going to be looking for a
different field
what exactly is a data science engineer
well a data science engineer is someone
who has
programming experience and python and
our expert level knowledge
ability to write proficient codes and
they
we have python and our i'm going to say
python or
r once you become really proficient at
one language
transferring those skills into another
one is usually fairly
easy now r is a little different because
it is an
analytics platform so going from python
to r
if you already know the data analytics
and python moving to r is pretty easy
now r doesn't have all the other code
that you can
access with python there's so many
things you can do with python that are
not data analytics
so it's important to keep in mind that
you should probably be pretty
well-rounded in python
and really have a solid foundation in r
or have a solid foundation in r
and be well-rounded in another
programming language where you really
get the programming side of it
strong sql and big data experience so
you have to have a strong coding skill
with hands-on
big data experience and of course we're
showing sql here
most commonly used whether you're using
a microsoft sql server or mysql server
you can also start thinking hadoop and
spark
in big data access hadoop file system
is not a huge jump if you've already
learned your sql and you've already
learned your basics and coding
hadoop sits on top of all that and does
a wonderful job creating huge clusters
of data
but you really need to know your sql
because that is so common in most of the
large companies now accessing their data
and an ability to visualize
models and troubleshoot code of the
models this is a kind of an interesting
one because
these models are can get very
complicated so you gotta be able to
break them down
into something that you can put the
pieces together and digest each of the
pieces
so being able to visualize these models
is very important and then being able to
drill down and
troubleshoot the different models or the
pieces in those models they need to be a
versatile problem solver equipped with
strong analytical and quantitative
skills
a self-starter with a strong sense of
personal responsibility and technical
orientation
this is an interesting one because when
you talk about data science engineer
it's such a new field that most
companies don't have it well-defined
they don't know what they're looking for
you might not even know what you're
looking for you might have an idea and
you're looking for patterns but where do
those patterns lead you
so you really need that self-starter
side to jump in there and figure out
where to go
and be able to communicate that back to
the team and there we go we have a
strong
product intuition data analysis skills
and
business presentation skills and this is
what's talking about is
you gotta bring that back to the team so
if you don't have a strong product in
tuition if you don't know what's going
on with the company
what they need and where you're going
with your analysis it's going to be a
dead end
and you've got to be able to present
that to the shareholders to
your co-workers which leads us to great
teammate with excellent interpersonal
skills
and this is kind of a strange one
because you spend so much time behind
your desk so you have to be able to kind
of float between
you're studying all the data and being
able to explain this to people
in simple terms that they can understand
no one wants somebody to come up and say
yeah the p score and the f score is this
that and the other thing
and you might have two people in the
room understand you you have to be able
to sit down and explain
what that means and why so let's take a
look at the data science skill set
we talk about data science engineer
skill set we're talking about
database knowledge statistics
programming tools
data wrangling probably the least
favorite and most used
machine learning data visualization and
then the touch on big data
and so we'll start with database
knowledge the most
common databases of course your sql
structured query language
uh think rows and columns it's an
essential language for extracting a
large amount of data from data sets
so knowledge of the sql is mandatory for
data science engineers
and you can see there's tools required
there's the oracle database
i mentioned my sql server microsoft sql
server
teradata there are so many different
forms of sql
and it'll just keep coming back and
coming back so if you don't have a solid
basic understanding of sql go get it
very important because it will come up
you know it's if you don't know it it's
going to bite you and statistics of
course we are you know that's what this
is all about is figuring out and
predicting things so you need to know
your statistics
statistics is a subset of mathematics
that deals with collecting
analyzing and interpreting data
therefore data scientists needs to know
statistics so you need to understand
your probabilities and what that means
and what the p score means in the f
score and means and
mode and median all that information
standard deviation all of those you need
to
be aware of and then we get into the
programming tools
and i mentioned this earlier a little
bit but you need to master any one of
these specific
programming languages programming tools
such as r python
sas are essential to perform analytics
in
data and again you know you can move in
there and you can be an expert in just r
you can be an expert in just sas and a
little bit you can be an expert in
python
because most of these when we're talking
about data science and data wrangling
you really kind of get down to the point
where you really need to have a full
programming language
at least the basics and if you're going
to be working in
data science python right now is the
main one but you know there's also java
c plus plus so you need to know a solid
language
at least the basics of it so you can
understand how to do basic iterations
and things like that
i always found that interesting that my
sister who runs a university data
analytics center that's the first
question she asks for
people candidates to come and work for
is how do you iterate through data you'd
be amazed at how many people don't
understand that very basic concept in
programming so when we look at r
r is a free software environment for
statistical computing and graphs
supports most machine learning
algorithms for data analytics like
regression
association clustering and etc python
python is an open source general purpose
programming language and there's our
general purpose i was just talking about
you need to know a little bit about
python libraries like numpy and scipy
are used in data science
scipy yeah numpy and scipy are very
central to python and i'd throw pandas
in there also
that module those are very central to
working with python
and data analytics and then sas sas can
mine alter manage and retrieve data from
a variety of sources
it can perform statistical analysis on
the data
so where r is the open source platform
sas is more like the paid for
platform and so it has some things more
automated because people
are paying for it developing it but it's
also if you really start using it as a
company you're gonna have to pay for it
where r rs freestore
is a free software python is also open
source and free to use
so we're going to talk a little bit
about data wrangling and i mentioned
earlier that is
both the probably people's least
favorite
aspects of data science and also
probably one of the places
you spend the most time so we talk about
data wrangling it is a process of
transforming
raw data into an appropriate format to
make it useful for analytics
and it involves cleaning raw data
structuring raw data and
enriching raw data and this gets
interesting because you'll get stuck
on something like in python you might
get stuck on something that
is a date time based on an integer 64
numpy set you might not know what all
those terms mean because you work in r
or something like that but you get the
point that it's all one particular
format and then you have to figure out
how to switch it so that the computer
can see it correctly in whatever format
you're using or whatever analytics
platform you're using
knowledge of machine learning techniques
such as supervised machine learning
decision trees linear regression k n etc
is useful for
few job roles so this is kind of
interesting because sometimes that's the
center of the job role of a data
scientist
and sometimes you just have to be able
to apply
the programming skills to it so you can
get the answer and let somebody else
fine-tune your machine learning
techniques so it really
depends on what it is you're working
with and you can see here we have our
nearest neighbor
set up where it groups things together
that look alike
linear regression you're drawing a line
through the data or curve
so you can predict what the next value
is going to be
and then our nice decision tree which
starts splitting things up and says you
know it's sunny out yes let's go
swimming
uh no it's raining we're not gonna go
swimming yes it's sunny out we might go
swim
it's raining uh we'll stay indoors yes
we'll walk the dog no so you have a
decision tree that helps uh
figure out how you get to the end result
so decision trees can be pretty powerful
and data visualization data
visualization is the study and creation
of visual representation of data
data visualization uses algorithms
statistical graphs
plots information graphics and other
tools to communicate
information clearly and effectively this
one
you really have to master as a data
science this one you really have to
master as a data scientist
and there certainly are so many
different tools to use to visualize it
but when you're communicating a picture
is worth a thousand words
when you can put a picture up and and
people can look at it and go oh
i see what's going on that's worth a lot
more than saying yeah this is good
people hear that and they just kind of
go okay it's good but why
and you might say you know okay these
numbers make it look good no people want
something they can see
and there certainly is uh tabloo is
probably um
one of the most popular ones out there
caleb view
power bi google data studio
in python there's the pi kit
and seaborn there's all kinds of
different options for visualization
you need to master probably at least one
or two of them
so you understand how they work and how
they're different
and then big data big data is a massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
and processed using traditional methods
big data has various benefits like
access to social data can enable
organizations to
tune their business strategies big data
can improve customer experience
uh and so we're usually when you say big
data we're almost
always talking about hadoop and apache
spark it used to be hadoop
as your file system so that's how you
store all your data going across the
nodes and there certainly are other ways
to store it
when we talk about hadoop we're usually
talking about at least 10 terabytes of
data when you're dealing with a hadoop
file structure and then you can use
spark where
hadoop processes on and off the hard
drive so it's continually
reading and writing to the hard drive
spark is running in your ram
and so when you're doing a very
intensive data process
you'll run a spark setup which will
spread those processes over multiple
computers
and of course now the two uh combine and
spark sits on top of hadoop and you get
your big data
there's also uh talent uh tabloo has its
own server set up there's splunk uh
cassandra you'll hear the cassandra
database
pentaho i'm not even sure how to
pronounce that one it's not one i've
worked with
certainly there's a lot of options for
big data the two big players are of
course hadoop and spark
and even your sql servers and mysql
servers will spread across
five different servers and you can be
talking about big data across five
servers with those pulling them into say
apache spark to do your high-end
processing and then there's
non-technical skills
probably the most important one in data
science and
any of our data analytics is
intellectual curiosity
updating knowledge by reading contents
and relevant books on trends in data
science
this is such there's so much going on in
this field and it's exploding now
that it's hard to keep track of it all
so you really need to have that
curiosity
in the data science probably even more
so than a lot of other fields
but i would say in just today's world
you need intellectual curiosity
because things are changing so rapidly
in today's world the way that it's going
with our technology
understanding how the problem solved can
impact
the business business acumen this is the
one where a lot of people kind of skip
over you have to have a little business
sense if you don't know how it's going
to impact the business
you're going to be in trouble why do
they want to even pay you to be there
unless
they know what's going on and they're
getting something in return so this is
your bottom line for your paycheck
is what's going on with the business how
is this going to impact the business
what are you doing for them
and communication skills companies look
for someone who can clearly and fluently
translate
technical findings to a non-technical
team and i've talked about this a bunch
and i i
can't even iterate this enough if you
are struggling with your communication
skills
work on building them they don't have to
be you know this isn't rocket science
where you have to know all these
complicated terms what you need to do is
take the complicated terms you know from
data science and
reduce that down to something that
anybody can understand
so when you come up and you have you
know knn
no one knows what k n is you know unless
they're in data science
nearest neighbor looking for things that
match together
you got to explain that to people who do
not have the technical skill in the data
science arena and a data science
engineer needs to work with
everyone in the organization including
customers
so it's teamwork and that's always one
that throws people for a loop
but ultimately you are analyzing your
customers information
and so sometimes getting in there and
rolling up your sleeves
if you're let's say you're doing data
analysis for the sales team and you're
backing a sales team
you might have to get in there and go
start making some cells and making some
phone calls and see what it's like what
is that team doing
when they call 15 people in cold calls
and then they do a follow-up two weeks
later or three weeks later which one
works better
two or three does it work better to call
and send a fax
call and send an email you know when
should you show up in person if it's
that kind of business
so working with everybody including the
customer is very important with the data
and
with this kind of setup and
non-technical skills for a data
scientist
so let's take a look at some of the
roles a data science plays in the job
market
let's drill in there just a little bit
here so when you have a data scientist
they're going to perform predictive
analysis and identify trend and patterns
that can help in better
decision making companies hiring data
scientists include
apple adobe google microsoft
i would say that's even expanding down
to smaller companies you know where
you're talking about only 100 employees
or something like that
they're starting to look at data
scientists because they need them to
come in
and be a part of that team and the role
is understanding challenges of a system
and offer best solutions this should
always be the goal of a data scientist
is to be looking at the whole system and
then trying to find those patterns that
are going to best
enhance the company or the business or
the
whatever group maybe you're working with
the sales team or the marketing team and
you can see languages
pretty important to have a these are a
number of different languages and again
it depends
on your own specialty there's all kinds
of different variations but
we have r sas python matlab sql
hive pig spark you should have at least
a knowledge of all of these
maybe a python programmer never used r
download it go through the basics so at
least you know
what's going on in r versus python
because r is pretty powerful for doing a
very quick
display and then of course a lot of
things you can do in python you have to
be able to do queries on database from
time to time
create and modify algorithms which can
be used to reduce
information from large databases and
usually this is one of those things you
do at the beginning you set it up
and then you kind of let it go until it
breaks and you have to go back and fix
it because
your query isn't working that certainly
is a very common thing to
to have happen especially if you're
pulling data off the web and the
internet
and then we have some more companies
that are hiring data analysis like ibm
dhl hp and so we're talking about data
analyst
the role is responsible for a variety of
tasks such as visualization
optimization and processing large amount
of data
and so when you talk about a data
analyst we're also we're still talking a
lot of the same stuff but you'll see
we've now thrown in javascript and html
in here
because that's pretty common with a data
analyst versus a data scientist
and you can see that sql is still pretty
solid and also
cc plus is pretty big so some companies
also use
java so i'd put java in the languages
also on that for a data analyst
and then you have a data architect
ensuring that data engineers have
best tools and systems to work with and
so companies hiring a data architect are
like visa
logitech coca-cola they create
blueprints for data management with the
best
security measures i cannot highlight
that a data architect really spends a
lot of time with security measures
that's big how many hacks have we seen
in the last year on large companies have
lost
data for millions of their customers and
how badly that affects them
and we're looking at languages as you
see that sql
is pretty solid across all of these
under a data architect
xml that's one that a lot of the data
science jobs don't really
you don't see as much but you're going
to see more xml with a data architect
because there's a lot of xml files that
are
that have your security measures
embedded in them and of course your hive
pig those are hadoop systems we're doing
some basic queries
so instead of doing the high end queries
you know how these simplified query
systems built into hadoop
and spark so if you're using big data
you're going to want to know your spark
also
and then we have our data engineer the
data engineer
updates the existing systems with better
version of the current technologies to
improve the efficiency
of the databases think admin here a lot
of work tracking down what version
you're in
of the different programs what version
of python are you using what version of
r are using what version of c
plus so companies hiring data engineers
are like amazon
spotify facebook and they develop
construct
test and maintain architectures such as
databases and long-scale
processing systems and here we have our
languages our sql
our matlab sas spss python java ruby c
plus plus pearl hive
pig you pretty much as a data engineer
at this level when you talk about admin
and updating all these databases need to
know all the different stuff that's
being used
in the company and you're testing out
these structures to make sure they work
and so you really are talking admin
level uh kind of setup so if you like
spinning up an admin
onto a google cloud service or amazon
cloud service
now you start to get an idea what we're
talking about because then you can test
it out up there and then you can bring
it back
and update it to the company statition
creates new methodologies
for engineers to apply and so when
we look at this this is where we're
digging into the math of which models to
use
what setups going to work what kind of
activation do we have on our neural
network
these little tweaks are going to make a
big difference
and we look for methodologies at a large
level what kind of data are we going to
be looking at how are we going to pull
it together
companies hiring a data engineer or
we're talking about stations we're
talking about linkedin
pepsico johnson and johnson and of
course these companies probably
hire a little bit of everything but they
have a lot of statisticians working for
them
and so we look at the role extract and
offer valuable reports from the data
clusters
through statistical theories and data
organization
and the languages across the board we're
still seeing sql r matlab sas spss
data that's a new one that i've seen in
some of the other roles
python pearl an older version and that
shouldn't be a surprise because a lot of
these companies probably built a lot of
the original packages on perl if you go
look at johnson and johnson and of
course your big data
hi pig and spark and then our database
administrator
i mentioned the other one is an admin
they're more an admin level for the
software itself
so administrator is another level some
of the tasks involved are monitoring
operating and maintaining databases
installation configuration defining
schemas training users etc
and this is interesting training users
because when you build a database and
you define all the different
tables that are embedded in that
database and how they're all connected
the end user's got to have that
information otherwise you're in trouble
when we have companies hiring data
engineers
of course tabloo twitter reddit uh the
role
ensures that all the databases are
available to all relevant
users again a little security in there
what role do they have
is allowed in and not and is performing
correctly and is being kept
safe and you better be ready to spend
some time in security
because again that's a very big thing
nowadays with the number of people who
hack into these databases
and the languages are going to be
covered you have your
c sharp your java sql ruby on rails
xml again there's that xml because a lot
of your security is embedded in xml
files
um python all the main players depending
on what the company is using
data and analytics manager so when you
see manager that means that somebody's
going to sit on top
and organize the people underneath so
they're going to improve the business
process
as an intermediary between business and
i.t
oh you better have some really good
communication skills for this one
some of the companies hiring a data
engineers are coursera
motorola slack and of course these
companies are hiring
data scientists in almost all of these
fields so the role
oversees the data science operations and
assigns the duties to the team according
to skills and
expertise so that's a big one you better
be able to communicate what's going on
help your team members come out and be
able to communicate with other people so
sometimes your job is
just being able to get people to talk to
each other the big thing on that
is is the whole communication line going
from one end to the other
because you can't communicate all the
information that everybody's working on
you have to pretty much come in there
and and help people communicate what
there's going on
and also know what they're up to without
being micromanagement
because that will crash a company if you
micromanage everybody but if you just
let them do whatever they want and they
never talk to each other that will also
destroy the company you got to find that
nice middle ground and you really have
to have an overview
of everything as a data and analytics
manager
one of the things i mean you know it's
good to have at least one or two
solid bases of programming under your
belt for a data analytics manager
but you do need to have a very general
understanding of all the different tools
being used so that you know what's going
on with your different team members
of course sql r sas java python matlab
all of those are big
business analytics so this is when
you're talking about your bi or your
business intelligence
and your business analytics very
important to
know this is kind of a subdivision of a
lot of the other stuff we've talked
about a lot of the other roles we've
looked at
so you possess specialized knowledge of
their business domain
and apply that knowledge and analysis
specifically to the operation
of the business so you might be a
specialist in banking
you might be a genetics engineer
so you know about genetics you might
just be general business
helping the marketing so a lot of
companies hiring data engineer
oracle uber dell and the role act is a
link between the data engineers and the
management
executives so it's very similar to when
you go back up here we look at data
analytics manager
a business and analytics is going to
also kind of fill that role in between
but they're more specialized in business
and you better know sql because we're
talking about
business specifically uh most of the
large companies are storing their data
that's up and running right now that
people are accessing to
purchase something on the home depot
website or the uber they're logging in
you better know your sql it's very
central to business analytics
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
data science engineer
salary trends and you'll see that our
source is glass door that's we're
pulling a lot of our data from
average base pay is around 117 000
in the us the average salary and we look
at india we're talking about
950 000 a year and those are based on
some of them you need to go ahead and
dig deeper to find out what education
level versus entry level
but those are pretty solid base once
you're in the industry and once you
created your career in there and we look
at the job titles the most common
job title is data scientist business
intelligence manager is the second
greatest one that's kind of good to note
that's why they put that up there as
being its own little subcategory of data
science managers a business intelligence
manager because it's such a high
level of jobs and then we looked at some
of the other ones data architect
business intelligence architect again
your bi
your business intelligence gets its own
ranking because it's such
a high level you know it's a business
people want their businesses to make
money so that's who's hiring of course
data engineer business intelligence
developer business intelligence
consultant business intelligence analyst
business analyst and data analyst so you
can look at the data analysis being the
general one that doesn't go specific to
business
so if you're looking just for your
career as far as getting a job
probably should have some kind of
business understanding in the background
and again you know your companies want
to make money so they're going to hire
someone who knows business
if banking business if you specialize in
banking or retail if you specialize in
retail and marketing and you can see
here on the data science salary trends
and the growth and data science job
listings it's continually going up it's
um
since 2014 to 2012 we've gone from 400
to 600
that's a pretty big increase so you know
a huge growth in this market it's one of
the biggest growing markets right now
for
jobs and careers let's go ahead and take
a look
at building a resume always exciting
putting ourselves out selling ourselves
and if you looked at some of our other
videos dealing with
resumes you'll see a trend here
the top part is so different than what
resumes were in the 90s
uh in the 2000 to 2010
they've evolved they've really evolved
it used to be
2000 2010 maybe linkedin
maybe one other reference now you're
going to see that we want those
references
this is a sales tactic which now has
come into resumes
used to be that if you're a real estate
agent every real estate agent i knew i
used to deal with real estate software
for the real estate industry back in the
90s every real estate agent won their
picture
on their business card they wanted them
their picture if they could
put on their contracts they want people
to see the face
so that's really a big change is to make
sure that it stands out
you stand out here's a picture of
somebody so you're more than just a
couple letters
and a name but of course you need your
contact information should always be at
the top
uh you have your summary what are you
focusing on
be a little careful with your summary
because if you have everything in your
summary and then they scroll down to
experience and education and skills
they're going to stop the second you
repeat yourself in your resume
that usually means to the reader hey
this person doesn't have anything more
to offer me i'm done
so be a little careful how you word your
summary most
companies appreciate when you come in
here
and you've adjusted this summary to be
both about you
and how you're going to serve that
company so it's worth researching
that company to find out how those
connect and
put that in the summary take some time
to do that that's actually a pretty big
deal and the references are huge also
especially in data science when you're
talking about any of the programming or
data science data analytics
having a place to go where they can look
it up and scroll down and see different
things you're doing whether it's
linkedin in this case which is the
business profile most commonly used
github where you have stuff published
facebook
i'm always hesitant because that tends
to push more towards uh
social media type jobs and other jobs
but certainly there's people who have
facebook who do marketing and stuff like
that but these links
having these basic links here is
important people are starting to look
for that for
some other uh setup maybe you have a
personal website
this is a good place to put that so that
they now have a multitude of links
that go back to you and highlight who
you are
and then the next part or next four
parts so for the next four parts
we have a combination of experience
education
skills certifications and you can see
they're organized
if you have you know a lot of people
like to see what kind of degree you have
they want to know where it came from
and if you just got out of college
you're going to put education at the top
and then maybe you'll put skills after
that and then your experience at the
bottom
if you've been in the field for years
you know my degree just to give you my
age goes back to the nine
early 90s so i usually put education at
the very bottom
and then because a lot of the stuff i'm
trying to sell myself on right now
is my skills i actually put that at the
top and i'll put my education my
certifications at the bottom my skills
and then my experience is since it's a
huge part of my resume
goes next you can organize these in
whatever order you want that's going to
work best for you
and sell you so remember you're selling
yourself this is your image
probably don't wear an old tie-dye
t-shirt with holes in it
you know something nice because it is
professional and of course your summary
your and then what do you have to offer
the company and again
when i put out resumes and i haven't
done a resume in a while you go
in there and you can take this and
reorganize this so if the company's
looking for something specific
you might put the experiences specific
to that company
you might even take experience uh if you
have like a long job history like i do
i've gone into a lot of different things
you might leave out those companies or
those experiences that had nothing to do
with data science
because it just becomes overwhelming
resume should only take about
30 seconds to glance over maybe a minute
tops
because after that point you've lost the
person's interest and if they want to
dig deeper they now have links they have
your website they have linkedin
and they can now take this and they come
back to it and they go okay let's look
at this person a little closer
so quick overview this is your sell
sheet selling you
to the company so always tie it to the
company so that
you have that what am i going to give
this company what are they going to get
from me
welcome to data science interview
questions my name is richard kirschner
with the simply learn team that's
www.simple
get certified get ahead before we dive
in and start going through the questions
one at a time
we're going to start with some of the
logical kind of concept that's enters in
a lot of interviews
in this one you have two buckets one of
three liters and the other
five liters you're expected to measure
exactly four liters
how will you complete the task and no
you only have the two buckets you don't
have a third bucket or anything like
that just the two buckets
and the object of the question like this
is to see how well you are
thinking outside the box in this case
you're in a larger box you have two
buckets and also the
pattern which you go on and what that
means is if you look at the two buckets
and we'll show you their answer in just
a second you have a bucket with three
liters and a bucket with five liters
and the first thought is what happens if
you go from left to right
so we have a direction and what happens
if you pour the three liters
into the five liter bucket well if you
pour the three liters into five liter
bucket you have an empty bucket of three
liters and what's really important here
is
i was thinking outside the box you
realize that you have a five liter
bucket that has three liters in it and
two empty leaders so you have two
additional leaders you can fill up
if we continue that process we can
compare from the left to right from the
small bucket to the large bucket you can
now measure in two
additional liters into the five liter
bucket and three minus two
is one and you can keep doing that you
can empty the five liter bucket in
pour those three liters in that one
liter in and then you can pour three
liters in what's cool about these
questions
as you explore them is you realize
there's multiple ways usually to solve
i went from small bucket to big bucket
the simply learned team their solution
that they pulled out was you fill the
five liter bucket and empty it into the
three liter bucket
now you're left with two liters in the
five liter bucket so that's great we can
empty the 3 liter bucket so now we're
going from large to small remember we
went from small to large
so you can go both either way but you
have to go one way or the other it turns
out and you can empty the 3
liter bucket and pour the contents of
the 5-liter bucket in it
so the liter bucket now has two liters
and if it has two liters that means it
has an empty one liter and by now you
probably have guessed
that if you have an empty space you can
start using that empty space of one
liter as a measuring so we fill the five
liter bucket again
and we pour the water in the three liter
bucket it already has the two liters
and so we're only pouring one liter in
there and five minus one is
four so interview questions they break
up into all kinds of different patterns
we have logic like this one which is a
lot of fun
we have questions that come up that are
more vocabulary list the difference
between supervised and
unsupervised learning probably one of
the fundamental breakdowns
in data science and supervised learning
uses known and labeled data as input
supervised
learning has a feedback mechanism most
commonly used supervised learning
algorithms are decision tree
logistic regression support vector
machine and you should know that those
are
probably the most common used right now
and there certainly are so many coming
out so that's a very evolving thing and
be aware of a lot of the different
algorithms that are out there outside of
the deep learning because a lot of these
work faster on raw data numbers
than they do than a deep neural network
would unsupervised learning uses
unlabeled data as input
unsupervised learning has no feedback
mechanism
most commonly used unsupervised learning
algorithms are
k-means clustering hierarchical
clustering the appropriate algorithm
and there certainly are more i'm going
to say k-means definitely is at the top
of the list and the hierarchical
clustering those two
are used so many times so really
important to understand what those are
and how they're used
and most important is understand that
supervised learning is you have
your data set where you have training
data and you have
all those different pieces moving around
but you you're able to train it you know
the answers
and unsupervised we're just grouping
things together that look like they go
together
how is logistic regression done logistic
regression
measures the relationship between the
dependent variable our label
what we want to predict and the one or
more independent variables are features
by estimating probability using its
underlying logistic function
sigmoid and whenever i draw these charts
i always end up drawing them the right
hand side first because you want to know
what your output is what is you want out
of here and the left hand side what do
you have going
in so you have your in and out you can
see we have a nice labeled image here to
help you remember this
we have our inputs we have our linear
model we have our probabilities what are
the probabilities
of it being a certain way based on these
features coming in
the sigmoid function and it's important
to note that the sigmoid function
is maybe the most commonly used but it's
only one of a number of functions that
are out there
and the sigmoid function turns our
probabilities into a value between zero
and one or very close to zero
very close to one between point one and
.009 and based on that we generate an
answer
in this case is zero or one how is
logistic regression done
so last time we talked about the sigmoid
function generally depending on what
your interview and
level of math and what expertise you're
going in for the market you'll have to
understand that formula of the
probability equals 1
over 1 plus e to the negative y and
that's e to the base 2.
so you have your probability function or
your sigmoid function which pushes it
as you can see we have a nice visual of
that that helps a lot to have that
visual
on the sigmoid function you definitely
should know your y equals m
times x plus c your base euclidean
geometry of forming a line
in the slope plus the intercept the
y-intercept
and then you have your natural log and
the natural log
is to the e as opposed to a base 2 or
base 10
so your natural log to the e of the
probability over 1 minus a probability
equals your
m times x plus c or your euclidean line
that helps a lot as far as the graphing
and understanding the sigmoid function
so we'll just keep pushing on to
question number three explain the steps
in making
a decision tree and i noticed last time
we brought up the decision tree in the
forest a lot of questions came up what
is the difference
so let's go through that when you make a
decision tree you're going to take the
entire
data set as input you're going to
calculate entropy of the target variable
as well as the predictor attributes i
remembered entropy is just
how chaotic is it so if you have like
you know
banana and grapes and oranges if you're
mixing in fruit and that's your data
coming in
you have all these different objects
that are so separate from each other and
the more they become
uniform the lower the entropy and we
call that information gain so we gain
information on sorting different objects
from each other so you have your entropy
you have to calculate your information
gain of all attributes
and then you choose the attribute with
the highest information gain as the root
node so if you can separate your group
and each
group chaos in each group is lowered
whichever split lowers the chaos the
most that's where you split it and
that's your root node at that point you
repeat the same procedure on every
branch till the decision node of each
branch
finalized so understanding that setup is
pretty important
as far as decision trees and you can see
here we have a nice visual of decision
tree for example if you want to build a
decision tree to decide whether we
should accept or decline a job offer
since these are interview questions
that's a good one to ask
and just as a tip you should be pretty
aware of the formula for entropy
and information gain so you need to look
those up if you don't remember those
and the salary if it's greater than 50
000 no decline the offer yes
it's got a good salary the commute is
greater than an hour
yes decline the offer no offers
incentives
yes except the offer no incentives
decline the offer
so we use decision tree pretty much for
everything if you want
and if you have a decision tree then you
also should understand how do you build
a random forest model
and remember that a random forest is
built up of a
number of decision trees so if you split
your data up into a lot of different
packages
and you do a decision tree in each of
those different groups of data the
random forest is bringing all those
trees together
so how do you build a random forest
model randomly select
k features from a total of m features
where k
is less than m among the k features
calculate the node d
using the best split point split the
note into daughter nodes using the best
split
repeat steps two and three steps until
leaf nodes are finalized
build force by repeating steps one to
four for end number times to create in
number of
trees so you can see it's got the same
build pattern as the tree but instead
you're
building a number of different trees
little small trees so it all have an end
leaf node
random forest has a vote at the end and
whoever gets the most votes wins
that's the answer how can you avoid
overfitting of your model
very important question in any kind of
mathematical scientific
data science setup in any of them there
are three main methods to avoid
overfitting and you should really
understand overfitting overfitting means
that your model is only set for a very
small amount of data
and ignores the bigger picture keep the
model simple
take into account fewer variables
thereby removing
some of the noise in the training data
good advice for any programming at all
use cross-validation techniques such as
k-folds cross-validation
use regularization techniques such as
lasso that penalize certain model
parameters if they're likely to cause
overfitting
and you should also be well aware that
your cross-validation techniques that's
like a pre-data or your lasso
and your regularization techniques are
usually during the process
so when you're prepping your data that's
when you're gonna do a cross validation
such as like splitting your data into
three groups
and you train it on two groups and test
it on one and then switch which two
groups you tested on that kind of thing
so can you solve another one of these i
love these things
there are nine balls out of which one
ball is heavy
in weight and the rest are of the same
weight
and how many minimum weighings will you
find the heavier ball
and when we say weighing think of a
scale where you can put
objects on one side and the other and
you can see which side is heavier
and you want to minimize that you want
to split the balls up in such a way that
you're going to do as
few measurements as you can you will
need to perform two wangs
so you can get it down to just two wings
and i always think if there's nine balls
and divide them into
three groups of three place three balls
on each side so you can just randomly
pick
six of the balls and three on one side
three on the other and if they balance
out both sides are equal then you know
the heavy weight isn't in any of those
so out of the remaining three balls from
step one
take two balls and place one ball on
each side
a little tricky there because i always
want to put all three i want to put two
on one side and one on the other but no
just take
randomly pick two of those put one on
each side if they balance out then the
left
out ball the one you didn't measure will
be the heavier one otherwise you'll see
it in the balance you'll see which one's
heavier because it'll take one of the
balls down now we go to scenario b
where they did not balance out so now we
know which side has a heavier ball in it
and it's just very similar to what we
did before if the balls in step one do
not balance out
then take those three balls that have
the heavier side on them and reproduce
step two to find out the heavier ball
difference between univariate bivariate
and multivariate analysis and hopefully
if you know a little latin you'll kick
in there that you have uni and you have
bi and you have multi because the answer
is in the words themselves
so the first one this type of data
contains only one
variable so let's see univariate purpose
of the univariate analysis is to
describe the data and find patterns that
exist within it
so when you only see one one variable
coming in in this case we're using
height of students
you're limited as far as what you can do
with that data so you can come up and
draw
different patterns and conclusions from
those patterns using the means
the median the mode dispersion range
minimum maximum so we're describing the
data
so all those words would describe the
data and that's about all you can do
with them data like that there's no
correlation there's nothing
to go beyond that as far as guessing or
predicting anything
so we move into bivariate you know uni
means one
by means two bivariate this type of data
involves two different variables
the analysis of this type of data deals
with causes and relationships and the
analysis is done to find out the
relationship among the two variables
and this is always a favorite one
because everybody loves ice cream in the
summer when it's hot and very few people
go for ice cream in the winter when it's
really cold so it's easy to see the
correlation in the data the temperature
and ice cream sells in summer season
and you can see here where the
temperature goes from 20 to 35
and as the temperature goes up so does
the sales of ice cream it goes from
2 000 i'm not sure two thousand what's
i'm guessing it's a very large
chain because if they're selling two
thousand ice cream cones and they have a
lot of business good for them
a little vendor on the corner selling
two thousand ice cream cones a day and
thirty one hundred the next day
here the relationship is visible from
the table that temperature in
cells are directly proportional to each
other so the hotter the temperature we
can predict an increase in cells
so the word prediction should come up so
we have description and prediction when
the data involves three or more
variables it is categorized under
multivariate it is similar to bivariate
but contains more than one dependent
variable
in this example another really common
one the data for house price prediction
the patterns can be studied by drawing
conclusions using mean median and mode
dispersion or range minimum maximum etc
and so you can start describing the data
that's what all that was
and then using that description to guess
what the price is going to be so this is
very good if you're in the market and
you
have already looked at the area and you
already know that a two bedroom
zero floor 900 square foot house is
usually runs about 40 000. you can guess
what the next one that looks similar to
it is
and i'll just throw in another word in
there i don't see very often unless
you're really a hardcore data science
we talked about describing the data
descriptive we talked about predictive
and there's also postscriptive
postscriptive means we're going to
change
the variables to try to guess what the
outcome is if we change what's going on
so that would be the next step but that
usually doesn't show up unless you're
dealing with some really hardcore data
science groups
what are the feature selection methods
to select the right
variables there are two main methods for
feature selection there's
filter methods and wrapper methods and
when you're filtering your
before we discuss the two methods real
quick the best analogy
for selecting features is bad
data in bad answer out so when we're
limiting or selecting our features it's
all about cleaning up the data
coming in so it's cleaner and is more
representative of what we're trying to
predict
filter method filter methods as they
come in we have linear discrimination
analysis
anova chi squared chi square is probably
the most common one
and these are all part of pre-processing
we're taking out all the
outliers all the things that have a
difference that is very different from
the data we're looking at the odd ones
and sometimes you take the odd ones out
and then you analyze them separately to
see why they're odd but remember your
filter methods you want to pull all that
weird stuff out
wrapper methods on the other hand are
forward selection
backward selection recursive feature
elimination
and one of the most important things to
remember about wrapper methods is
they're very labor intensive
you have to have some pretty high end
computers if you're doing a lot of data
analysis with the wrapper method
and just quickly forward selection means
you
have all your different features they're
off to the side and we test just one
feature at a time
we keep adding them in until we get a
good fit backward as we have all the
features and we start we run a test on
that to see how well it does and then we
start removing features to see what
works
and recursive which is the most
processing hungry
algorithm out there goes through and
just recursively looks through all the
different features and how they pair
together
but again we have filter method and
wrapper method and it's important to
understand that we're
sorting the data out and finding out
which features are going to represent
the data the best and which ones are not
going to really add any value to
our models let's jump number eight in
your choice of language
write a program that prints the numbers
from 1 to 50. but for multiples of 3
print fizz instead of the number and for
the multiples of 5
print abuzz for numbers which are
multiples of both
three and five print fizz buzz
and this really is testing your
knowledge and iterating over data very
important my sister who runs
at the university the data science team
is in charge of their department
it's the first question she asks in her
interview of anybody who comes in
is how do they iterate through data
so if this question comes up a lot and
it's very important you have an
understanding
and there's actually a slight error on
this code which i'll point out in just a
second
the concept is we have fizz buzz in
range and you have range 51
which in this case goes from 0 to 51 and
i'm gonna challenge you to see if you
can catch the error and i'll tell you at
the end of the code where the error is
what that means is that we're going to
go through all the numbers 0 1 2 3 4 and
we're going to process through this loop
if the remainder of fizzbuzz divided by
3 equals 0 and fizzbuzz
divided by 5 also equals 0 then print
fizzbuzz continue and if fizzbuzz
divided by three equals zero
then print fizz print fizz continue else
if
is buzz divided by five equals zero
print buzz continue and print
fizzbuzz you fit the print the answer in
this case
fizzbuzz is either going to be the
number we generated which is zero or
it'll be the fizz buzz fizz or buzz
that's a mouthful now if you didn't
catch the error in the code
which is always a fun game find the
error it has to do with the range
and it's important to remember the range
here says range to 51 that's 0
to 51 which is is correct we want to go
to 51 because it stops
it gets to 50 and it stops so that's 0
to 50. but if you remember the question
asked from
1 to 50. so the range should be 1 comma
51 not just 51 which does 0 to 51.
in this particular script in python you
can leave out the continue
but the continue in this script skips
the next lcf so it doesn't keep
processing it going down and in
programming
a lot of scripts you don't need the
continuance this would depend on what
script you chose and there's probably
some other ways to do this it's a lot of
fun
and you can see here from the output we
end up with fizz buzz for zero
which shouldn't be there one two fizz
for buzz fizz seven eight fizzbuzz
11 fizz and so on sounds like a drinking
game from my college days
so long ago many decades ago you are
given a data set consisting of variables
having more than 30
missing values how will you deal with
them oh
the joy of messy data coming in ways to
handle missing data values
data set is huge we can just simply
remove the rows with missing data values
there's the quickest way
i.e we use the rest of the data to
predict the values you just go in there
and say any row
of our data that has a n a in it get rid
of it that doesn't work with smaller
data
so a smaller data you start running into
problems because you lose a lot of data
and so we can substitute missing values
with the mean or average of the rest of
the data using panda's data frame in
python
there's different ways to do this
obviously in different languages and
even in
python there's different ways to do this
but in python it's real easy you can do
the df.mean
so you get the mean value so if you set
mean equal to that then you can do a
df.fill in a
with the mean value very easy to do in a
python panda script
and if you're using python you should
really know pandas and numpy
number python and pandas data frames for
the given points
how will you calculate the euclidean
distance in
python so back to our basic algebra from
high school
euclidean distance is the line on the
triangle
and so if we're given the points plot
one equals one comma three
plot two equals two comma 5 we know that
from
this we can take the difference of each
one of those points
square them and then take the square
root of everything so the euclidean
distance equals the square root of
plot 1 0 minus plot 2 of 0 squared plus
plus one of one minus plot two of one
squared mouthful there and you can
remember if you have multiple dimensions
that go past two dimensions you could
have plot three
can simply be the distance from plot one
you only need to do one side of that
or plot two you can do either way and
square that and take the square root of
that
another mind bender how to uh calculate
some how to figure out the solution to
something
what is the angle between the hour and
minute hands
of a clock when the time is halfed past
six so you want to kind of imagine that
clock where the
large hand is pointed down to the 30 and
the other half
is going to be right between the six and
the seven because it's half past six
there's actually a couple ways to solve
this but let's take a look and see how
they did it
note a clock is a complete circle having
360 degrees
in one hour the hour hand covers 360
over 12 so it equals 30 degrees for each
hour
in one minute the minute hand covers 360
degrees over
60 minutes or 6 degrees per minute the
minute hand has traveled for 30 minutes
so it has covered 30 times 6 which
equals 180 degrees
so we know that's 180 degrees from the
12. the hour hand has traveled
for six point five hours six and a half
six point five so it's covered six point
five times thirty which equals 195
degrees
the difference between the two will give
the angle between the two hands
thus the required angle equals 195 minus
180 equals 15 degrees
and this is nice the way they solved it
because you can now punch in any kind of
time within reason the hard part is on
the hours
is you have to be able to convert the
hours into decimals explain
dimensionality
reduction and list its benefits
dimension reduction refers to the
process of converting a set of data
having vast dimensions
into data with lesser dimensions fills
to convey
similar information concisely it helps
in data compressing and reducing the
storage space
it reduces computation time as less
dimensions lead to less computing it
removes redundant features for example
there's no point in storing a value in
two different unit
units meters and inches and i certainly
rented a lot with this with
text analysis i've been known to run a
text analysis over a series of documents
ends up with over
1.4 million different features that's a
lot of different words being used
and if you do what they call uh buy
connect them you connect two words
together
now you're up to four point eight
million different features
and you start having to figure ways to
bring that down what can we get rid of
that kind of thing so you can see where
that can get really high in on
processing and learning how to reduce
the list
dimensions is very important how will
you calculate
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of a three
by three
matrix and what they're really looking
for here is when you write it out
for the eigen is that you know that
you're going to use the lambda that's
the most common one obviously you can
use any symbol you want but lambda is
usually what they use and that you do it
down the middle diagonal and so when you
take that matrix and you
take the characteristic equation you end
up with the determinant
and that's the minus two minus lambda
minus four two
minus two one minus lambda two four two
five minus lambda and that's what
they're looking for and you know that's
equal to zero so when you're doing a
matrix in the eigen set up with the
eigenvectors
that's all going to come out equal to 0
and then you can go ahead and write the
whole equation out so we can expand the
determinant
as you can see right here the minus 2
minus lambda times
it's a mouthful i'll leave it up here
for a second so you can look at it when
you
break it down into the algebraic
functions you end up with
minus lambda cubed plus 4 lambda squared
plus 27 lambda minus
90 equals 0. so now we have a nice
algebraic
equation built from the eigenvectors
and always remember you can hit the
pause button and you can also send a
note send a note to
simply learn if you have more questions
on vectors or on this definitely have
that
resource available to you or post down
in below
on the youtube video comments and so
when we calculate the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of a three by three matrix
as we continue on down the math of this
and to be honest i really don't like
working with matrixes like this
it's important to understand the math
behind it and it's important to know the
code
just enough so that you're not lost when
someone's explaining it or it comes up
when i'm working on different data
science models
um of course if you're dealing with the
high-end math side of it then you better
know this
first is by hitting trial so you try in
different variables to solve for zero
and you can come in here and you'll find
that if we put in the three in there
we end up with a zero at the end and
substitute the three
hence we end up with lambda minus three
as one of the factors
and you can do the math going out on
that where we have lambda cubed minus
four lambda squared minus 27 lambda
plus 90 equals lambda minus 3
times lambda squared minus lambda minus
30. so eigenvalues
based on that one are 3 minus 5 and
6. and then from there we can calculate
the eigenvector for
lambda equals three and you can see here
where the matrix as we write it out is
the minus five minus four
two minus two minus two minus two four
two two that's from the beginning
put in the x y and z equals zero zero
zero
and so when we put in those numbers and
we calculate them out we have for
x equals one we have the minus five
minus four y plus two z equals zero
minus two minus two y
plus two z equals zero and subtracting
the two equations we just had
we get 3 plus 2 y equals 0 y equals
minus 3 over 2 and z
equals minus 1 over 2. that's going back
to the first equation and similarly we
can calculate the eigenvectors for minus
5
and 6. how should you maintain your
deployed
model distribution time my favorite i
spent
10 years in software distribution so
first thing and this is true not just of
your data science model but of any
computer code going out there this
basic setup can work although usually
there's a little added steps in there
first we're going to monitor it
so we have a constant monitoring of all
the model is needed to determine
the performance accuracy of the models
so yeah we want to just keep an eye on
it we want to make sure they're accurate
we want to make sure that whatever
they're
supposed to predict or i threw in that
bonus word
post script where you change something
and you want to figure out how your
changes are going to affect things we
need to monitor it and make sure it's
doing what it's supposed to do
evaluation metrics of the current model
is calculated to determine
if new algorithm is needed and then we
compare it the new models
are compared against each other to
determine which model performs the best
and then we do a rebuild the best
performing model is rebuilt on the
current state of data
this is interesting i found this out
just recently if you're in weather
prediction
the really big weather areas have about
seven or eight
different models depending on what's
going on and so you actually have almost
a
little force going on there where
they're like which model is going to fit
best and this is what we're going to use
to predict the weather with
so not only do you don't necessarily get
rid of the models but you figure out
which models fit
data of what's going on or the current
state of data
what are recommender systems most
commonly used nowadays in marketing
so very big industry understanding
recommender systems
predicts the rating or preference a user
would give to a product
and they they're split into two
different areas one is collaborative
filtering and a good example of that is
the last.fm
recommends tracks that are often played
by other users
with similar interests so people who if
you're on amazon
people who bought this also bought that
this got me a few times
and then there's contact based filtering
and we're looking at content instead of
looking at who else is listening to the
music
leave the example pandora which uses the
properties of a song
to recommend music with similar
properties so you have collaborative
filtering and content based filtering
how to find rmse and msc in linear
regression
model hopefully you remember what the
two acronyms mean because that is like
half the answer
we have the root mean square error and
the mean square
error in linear regression model so
we're looking for error
the rmse and the msc are the two of the
most common measures of accuracy for a
linear regression model and you can see
here we have the root mean square error
rmse equals and this is the square root
of
the sum of the predicted minus the
actual squared
over the total number so we're just
looking for the
average mean so we're looking for the
average over the end and
the reason you need to know about the
difference between rmse versus msc
is when you're doing a lot of these
models and you're building your own
model why do you need to take the square
root of it
it doesn't change the value as far as
the way you're using it because you're
looking as to see whether the error is
greater or less than
so why add that extra computation in so
a lot of models use the
msc which indicates the mean square
error or the average
error and it's the same formula minus
the square root at the end
or across the whole thing another riddle
to solve
if it rains on saturday with a
probability of 0.6
and it rains on sunday with a
probability 0.2
what is the probability that it rains
this weekend
and the trick in probabilities on this
case is we're not we need to know
what is the probability of it not
raining what's it not what's the chance
of it not raining
on saturday and if it doesn't rain on
saturday we want to take that and
combine that with the chance of it not
raining on sunday
the total probability which in this case
we're just going to use 1
minus the probability that it will not
rain on saturday so it's 1 minus 0.6
we're going to take that as a union
which we simply just multiply them
together
of the probability they will not rain on
sunday
and it's important to recognize the
union here or the
and you can see by the formula down here
we end up with 0.68 or
68 chance that it will rain on the
weekend
and there are a couple other ways to
solve this but this is probably the most
traditional way of doing that
how can you select k for k means so
first you better understand that what k
means is and that k
is the number of different groupings and
most commonly we use
is the elbow method to select k for k
means the idea of the elbow method is to
run k-means clustering on the data set
where k is the number of clusters
within the sum of squares wss is defined
as the sum
of the squared distance between each
member of the cluster and its centroid
and you should know all the terms for
your k means on there and with the elbow
point
and again here's our iteration in our
code we talked about that earlier
you iterate starting with um usually you
don't start right at one
but you might start with two three or
four and you just see where it comes out
and you can see the nice elbow there
which is easy to see graphically where
the
number of k clusters and the wss value
drops
and then it just kind of flattens out
there's no reason to take the k means
any further
what is the significance of p-value oh
good one especially if you're dealing
with r because that's the first thing
that pops up
p-value typically less than or equal to
0.05
indicates a strong evidence against the
null hypothesis
and you should know what a difference
why we use null hypothesis instead of
the hypothesis so you reject the null
hypothesis
very important that term null hypothesis
in any scientific
setup and also in data science it
doesn't mean that it's true
it means that there's a high correlation
that it's true
so if your null hypothesis means it's
not true your hypothesis
is has a high correlation that it's
probably true and if the p-value
is typically greater than 0.05 it
indicates a weak evidence against the
null hypothesis
so you fail to reject the whole null
hypothesis and if you reject that then
your
actual hypothesis is probably not true
the correlation of your data with what
you think it's saying is is probably
incorrect
and if you're right at the cutoff of
0.05 it's considered to be marginal
could go either way and again you can
use that p value
on different features to decide whether
you're going to include your features
as far as something worth exploring in
your data science model
how can outlier values be treated oh
good one
you can drop outliers only if it is a
garbage value
so sometimes you end up with like one
outlier that just is probably
someone's measurement sway off height of
an adult equals abc
feet this cannot be true as height
cannot be a string value
in this case outliers can be removed if
the outliers have extreme values they
can be removed
for example if all the data points are
clustered between 0 to 10
but one point lies at 100 then we can
remove this point
and again sometimes you just look for
the outlier so you can see what's going
on if there's something unusual there so
maybe the equipment's not calibrated
correctly
if you cannot drop outliers you can try
the following
try a different model data detected as
outliers by linear model can be fit by
non-linear model
so we be sure you are choosing the right
model
so if it has like more of a curved look
to it instead of a straight line you
might need to use something other than
just a straight line linear model
try normalizing the data this way the
extreme data points are pulled to a
similar range
if you can use algorithms which are less
affected by outliers example random
forest
so there is another solution is you can
come up with the random force which a
lot of times completely
bypasses your outliers how can you say
that a time
series data is stationary oh that's an
interesting term stationary meaning it's
not moving but it's a time series
we can say that a time series is
stationary when the variance and mean of
the series
is constant with time and this graphic
example is very easy to see
we have our the variance is constant
with time so we have our first variable
y and x
and x being the time factor and y being
the variable as you can see
goes through the same values all the
time it's not changing
in the long period of time so that's
stationary and then you can see in the
second example the waves get bigger and
bigger
so that's non-stationary here the
variance is changing with time
again we have y which stays constant so
that if you look at the bigger picture
it's the same wave over and over again
and then of course we have uh where
the wave is growing in size going up
it can also go down so it also be
non-stationary how can you calculate
accuracy using confusion matrix
oh great one confusion matrixes are so
useful
when you're taking that first look at
data and also when you're showing the
shareholders
and you want to ask them for money how
can you calculate accuracy using
confusion matrix
so you have your total data that we're
looking at is 650
and you have your predicted values and
your actual values and you have your
predicted p
and your actual p and so we look at this
you'll note that if the
predicted p and the actual p are 262
but our predicted p also had 15 that
weren't
correct so you can see there's a false
positive there of 15
and the same thing with the n you can
see where n predicts n and it has a
false negative of 26 out of the total
number of n
values in there and so we can do an
accuracy on there
the true positive plus the true negative
is our total observations
so you have a total of 0.93 accuracy or
93 percent
and just a quick note on this this is so
important because it's one thing if
someone is being diagnosed with
say cancer you know this is life death
or is my nuclear reactor going to blow
up
suddenly if the p is the probability of
it blowing up
and this can say you have 15 that's a
lot less than say the 26 chances of it
blowing up
you know so the actual domain of your
data is very important
so if you're non-positive you don't
really care about the predicted value
having non-positive as positive because
they're going to do a biopsy on the
cancer or whatever anyway but you're
very interested if you have a positive
an actual positive value which is looked
at as negative
a false negative that's really important
in that domain depending on what domain
you're in
write the equation and calculate
precision and recall rate
and so continuing with our confusion
matrix
i was just talking about the different
domains we have the precision
equals 262 over 277 so your precision is
the true positive
over the true positive plus false
positive and the recall rate is your
true positive over the total positive
plus false negative and you can see here
we have that 262 over
uh 277 equals a 94 percent and the
recall over here is the 262 over 280
which equals 9.9 or 90 and oh good we're
going to take a pause for another brain
teaser
if a drawer contains 12 red socks
16 blue socks and 20 white socks
how many must pull out to be sure of
having a matching
pair the last time i went through these
kind of brain teaser
things was like 20 years ago and i had
six people sitting across the table
waiting for my answer that's kind of
mind-numbing when you're in an interview
like that hopefully
you're not stuck in an interview like
that but uh on this
you need to ask yourself how many
different colors of socks
are there so they've thrown a lot of
extra data in here that you don't need
to solve the answer
the answer is four an example your first
pick is white
your second pick is red third pick is
blue so no pairs yet
and that means when you get to the
fourth pick there's a hundred percent
chance you're going to have a match
so the most is going to be four that you
ever have to pull out of your drawer
if it was four colors the answer would
be five and so on it doesn't matter how
many white socks you have or how many
red socks or blue socks
different pairs you have it's the
different colors a number of different
colors
people who bought this also bought
recommendations seen on amazon
as a result of which algorithm we
covered this earlier
recommendation engine is done with
collaborative
filtering collaborative filtering
exploits the behavior of other users in
their purchase history
in terms of ratings selection etc it
makes predictions on what you might
interest a person based on the
preference of many other users
and this algorithm features of the items
are not known
and we have a nice example here where
they took a snapshot of a cells
page it says for example suppose x
number people buy a
new phone and then also buy tempered
glass with it
next time when a person buys a phone
he'll be recommended to buy tempered
glass along with it
and if you remember the vocabulary words
we covered earlier this is the
recommendation this is collaborative the
other word was
content based so looking at things with
similar content versus collaborative
which is similar people
remember you know you're not going to
know every vocabulary word
but it also doesn't hurt to get your
three by five cards out and make
yourself a vocabulary stack of cards
buy an app on your phone for it sql
query i remember back in the
90s it was so important to know sql
query and only a few people
got it nowadays it's just part of your
kit you have to know some basic sql so
write a basic sql query to list all
orders
with customer information and you can
kind of make up your own name for the
database
and you can pause it here if you want to
write that down on a paper and let's go
ahead and look at this we have
to list all orders with customer
information and so usually you have an
order table and a customer table and you
have an order id
a customer id order number total amount
and then from your customer table you
have id
first name last name city county and so
if we're going to write in sql with this
we're going to
select keyword there for sql selecting
order number
total amount first name last name city
country so that's the columns we're
going to look at
we're going to do that from our order
where we're going to join it with our
customer and we're going to join it on
the order customer id
equals the customer id so very basic sql
query that's going to return
a table of data for us you are given a
data set on
cancer detection you've built a
classification model and achieved an
accuracy of 96
96 why shouldn't you be happy with your
model performance
what can you do about it that's an
interesting one because this comes up
that's one of the standard data sets on
there is for
cancer detection cancer detection
results in imbalanced
data in an imbalanced data set accuracy
should not be based
as a measure of performance because it
is important to focus on the remaining
four percent which are the people who
were wrongly diagnosed
we talked a little bit about this
earlier you have to know your domain you
know this is the medical
cancer domain versus weather domain you
know whether channel they get by with 50
wrong in cancer you don't want four
percent of the people being wrongly
diagnosed
wrong diagnosis is of a major concern
because there can be people who have
cancer but we're not
predicted so in an imbalanced data set
accuracy should not be used as a
measurement performance
which of the following machine learning
algorithm can be used for inputting
missing values of both
categorical and continuous variables so
we have a couple choices here we have k
means clustering we have linear
regression we have the k
n n nearest neighbor and decision tree
in which of the following machine
learning algorithms can be used for
inputting
missing values of both categorical and
continuous variables
now certainly you can use some
pre-processing to do some of that but
you should have gone with the
k nearest neighbor because it can
compute the nearest neighbor and if it
doesn't have the value it just computes
the nearest neighbor based on all the
other
features where when you're dealing with
k means clustering or linear regression
you need to do that in your
pre-processing
otherwise it'll crash decision trees
also although there's some variants on
that too
can you solve another riddle always fun
ones given a box of matches
and two ropes not necessarily identical
measure a period of 45 minutes
and in this particular setup the ropes
are not uniform in nature and the rope
takes exactly
60 minutes to completely burn out so
each rope takes up to 60 minutes to burn
out
and there's actually a couple different
solutions to this but let me go ahead
and one of the things is they're not
uniform in nature so even though they
take 60 minutes
anyways let's go ahead and see what they
did to solve it and then we can also
look at different options
we have two ropes a and b light a from
both ends
and b from one end okay when a is
finished burning we know that 30 minutes
have elapsed and b
has 30 minutes remaining now light the
other end of b
also so that the remaining part of b
will burn taking 15 minutes to burn
this we have gotten 30 plus 15 equals 45
minutes
excellent solution mine which i like
was to take one rope fold it in two so
we know it's a half hour
take the other rope fold it in four
places so we know that that one's 15
minutes and then you can just connect
the two and burn it straight across
i think they're trying to cover that by
saying they're not regular the ropes are
have some irregularities maybe that's
what they meant by that you couldn't do
something like that
that's my solution below are the eight
actual values of target variable in
the train file so we have a training
file not to be confused with the train
on the tracks we have zero zero zero one
one one one
what is the entropy of the target
variable
we mentioned earlier that you should
know your entropy and how to calculate
the entropy what is the entropy of the
target variable
so we have a couple options here we have
minus five over eight
logarithm of five over eight plus three
over eight logarithm of three over eight
okay let's just see where they got those
numbers from we have
one which is going to be five ones and
three
zeros and then we have a total of eight
okay
and then we have the option of five uh
which is number of ones five eight
logarithm of five eighths
plus three eighths logarithm of 3 8 and
we also have 3 8 logarithm of 5 8 plus 5
8 logarithm of 3 8
and then we kind of reverse those
numbers around and let's see what you're
going to get here which one did you
think it was
you should check the first one so what
is the entropy of the target variable
the key there is a target variable so
we're looking at the target in this case
is going to be one usually that's what
you're looking for and so the entropy of
that one we want to subtract
out the entropy of the non-targeted
variable whoops i had that backwards we
want to we're looking at 0 so we want to
subtract out the 5 8 from there so 5 8
logarithm 5
8 or negative 5 8 logarithm 5 8 plus 3 8
logarithm 3
8. and they have the hint on the bottom
entropy equals i
of p of n so we have a negative p plus p
and n times the logarithm
base 2 of p over p plus n minus
the n over p plus n times logarithm 2 of
n over p
plus n we want to predict the
probability of death from heart disease
based on three risk factors
age gender and blood cholesterol level
what is the most appropriate algorithm
for this case
so we have three features and we want to
know the predictability of
death okay a little morbid there choose
a right algorithm do we want to use
logistic regression for this
linear regression k means clustering or
the appropriate
algorithm and if you selected logistic
regression
then you've probably got the right
answer linear regression remember deals
with like
you take your line and draw a line
through the data of course you don't
necessarily have to use a straight line
there's other means for that but you're
dealing with a lot of numbers and
k-means means we're just going to
cluster objects together with the
logistic regression though you can mix
those things together in buckets so
really the logistic regression is what
you want to use in that model would be
the most
apt fit after studying the behavior of a
population
you have identified four specific
individual types who are valuable to
your study you would like to find all
users who are most
similar to each individual type which
algorithm is most appropriate for
this study certainly identifying census
and just about a lot of different
markets is common so
maybe they have a census or whatever it
means but let's take a look at some of
the different
algorithms we might use on this we have
k means clustering
linear regression association rules and
decision trees
and i'll give you a hint we're looking
for
grouping people together by similarities
and by four different similarities so
very specific
they gave you one of the values
specifically the k value
so k means clustering would be great for
this particular problem
you have run the association rules
algorithm on your data set
and the two rules banana apple is
associated with grape
and apple orange is associated with
grape have been found to be relevant
what else must be true so this would
change you to understand association
rules
you could picture in this particular one
you're going
shopping and uh you almost always see
somebody who has bananas they usually
have
grapes in their bag also and somebody
who has apples usually has grapes in
their bags
and then apples and oranges is also
associated with grapes and let's go and
take a look at that
and we have a couple different options
here first one is banana apple and grape
orange must be a frequent item set
not so much banana apples oranges must
be relevant rule
grape is common with banana apple must
be a relevant rule and how about
grape apple must be a frequent item set
let's go back and take a look at that
and we notice that we have bananas
apples to grapes we have apple orange to
grape boy there's a lot of grapes and a
lot of apples in there
and so if you said the last one grape
and apple must be a frequent item set
then you got it correct your
organization has a website where
visitors
randomly receive one of two coupons it
is also possible that visitors to the
website will not receive a coupon you
have been asked to determine if offering
a coupon to visitors to your website has
any impact on their purchase decision
which analysis method should you use
and so let's go ahead and start by
giving you another hint and give you
some
limiting your selection we have a one
way anova
k means clustering association rules and
student
t test so obviously you should know what
each one of these means
but let's take a look at the question
again so you want to know which method
should you use to see if the coupons
valid for their purchase well we're not
clustering
and we're not associating things
together we want to know the end result
student t-test also drawing a little t
in boxes and
switch them around there's really only
one answer that works in here and that's
a one-way
anova thank you all for watching this
video tutorial on data science full
course
i hope you liked it if you have any
questions then please put them in the
comments section below
our team will help you solve your
queries thanks again stay tuned for more
from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here